Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und
begrüßt alle zur 1004 Ausgabe von UKW und äh wenig überraschend schon eine Woche nachdem wir hier die letzte Sendung gemacht haben geht es
wieder um die Ukraine mit mir und mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Denn es geht rund in der Ukraine.
Geht's in gewisser Hinsicht natürlich jetzt auch schon seit 7 Monaten, aber derzeit äh ist einfach eine Menge los und nicht nur dort, sondern überhaupt in äh ganz Europa ähm gab's doch eine ganze Menge Aufregung
kaum, dass wir die letzte Sendung veröffentlicht hatten äh gab's Explosionen, nicht nur in der Ukraine.
Ja und äh überhaupt hat das ganze Geschehen erneut an Dramatik zugenommen und ähm
Ja, es gibt eine Menge einzuordnen. Äh ich dachte schon, wir also ich habe so die Hoffnung, dass wir vielleicht zwischendurch mal so eine Sendung machen, wo man mal so,
bisschen zusammenfasst, was so ein bisschen passiert ist, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, die Zeit ist vorbei.
Äh jetzt ähm müssen wir wieder dranbleiben. Nicht wahr?
So, was ist äh alles passiert? Also vielleicht mal so als,
Überblick heute. Ähm wir wollen mal so ein bisschen darüber reden, wie wir eigentlich so unsere Informationen
gewinnen und was an sich eigentlich auch in diesem Informationskrieg so stattfindet. Da müssen wir natürlich über Nordstream reden, über den Anschlag auf die Gaspipeline. Wir wollen die Mobilisierung
ähm thematisieren in äh Russland, wie das so gelaufen ist und natürlich auch die von Putin verkündete Annexion, dieser vier ukrainischen Oblaster.
Und dann äh gehen wir auch noch mal auf die konkrete militärische Situation ein, weil da ist eine ganze Menge passiert, sowohl in äh der Region als auch ähm Johannes und Cresson, also eine Menge los.
Und dann wollen wir nochmal so ein bisschen über ja das sonstige Eskalations,
sprechen, was so drin ist. Haben wir auch letzte Woche schon gemacht, aber ähm
wollen wir auch noch mal so ein bisschen was nachlegen. Also volles Programm, würde sagen wir fangen einfach mal an.
So bist du Mitglied der?
Nicht wirklich kein offizielles Mitglied und auch kein Identifizierbares Mitglied aber irgendwie ähm ja.
Sympathisant.
Sympathisant, Naphrosypartisant, ja, so könnte man es vielleicht äh bezeichnen.
Mhm, genau. Wovon reden wir? Wir reden von der North Atlantik Fellers Organisation, die nicht ohne Grund, so ähnlich wie NATO klingt.
Ich hatte das hier schon länger auf dem Zettel mittlerweile ähm.
Wird sehr viel darüber äh berichtet.
Was ist das? Also das hat sich so ein bisschen.
Wieder im Internet äh herausgebildet und war so ein bisschen also bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich die vollständige Genese schon äh komplett verstanden habe, aber im Wesentlichen sind es einfach Leute auf äh Twitter und auch natürlich auf anderen Kanälen, die sich äh zusammengetan haben und gesagt haben, okay wir wir
unterstützen jetzt hier irgendwie diese Ukrainer und uns stört vor allem diese ganze Disinformation, die in Social Media unterwegs ist und wir setzen dem jetzt mal was entgegen.
Und dann wurde eben das gesamte Meme
Potential des Internets auch abgerufen und das Ganze ist dann mit sehr viel Schieberino äh Hundchen ähm bekleidet, also das sind so, falls ihr das schon mal so dieser typische Dosch von also dieser Dosch Hund.
Von der ne ähm der.
Kommt hier zum Einsatz und man sieht also sehr viele irgendwie Hunde mit in Militärkleidung et cetera und äh auch in Twitter-Avataren findet man das oft.
Ganze ist sozusagen so ein Zusammenschluss von von Leuten, die die Ukraine unterstützen möchten und die sich darauf konzentriert haben ähm ja
vor allem russischen Trollen und solchen Informations- äh Eskapaden etwas entgegenzusetzen, indem sie das halt widerlegen und äh sonst wie betreuen und dabei vor allem auch sehr humorvoll unterwegs sind.
Und was ich auch bemerkenswert finde, ist, dass da auch sehr viel Geld eingesammelt wird,
Also es finden da so diverse Spendenaktionen statt, da sind die auch nicht die einzigen, gibt's ja überhaupt
einige Aktivitäten, wo immer wieder Kohle eingesammelt wird für bestimmte Ausrüstung, von Soldaten und irgendwie Autos werden da gekauft und
Bayracta Drohnen werden da äh gekauft. Also es ist äh neben dieser ganzen offiziellen äh finanziellen Befeuerung,
äh das,
Nicht des Konflikts, aber sagen wir mal der finanziellen Unterstützung äh der Ukraine über Staaten gibt's halt auch sehr viel auf privater Ebene, was läuft und da ist die NAFO.
Keine Ausnahme. Wie hast du das wahrgenommen.
Ja, ich habe halt nur mitbekommen, dass die Tschechen jetzt grade irgendwie einen Kampfpanzer äh geschenkt haben äh so.
Tschechischen Bürger, ne.
Die tschechischen Burger
und äh das war halt auch äh irgendwie so bisschen mit mit Meme und mit speziellen Aufklebern und ähm ja äh der hat auch einen Namen bekommen und so.
Also und äh überhaupt gibt's ja dann so Aktionen wie.
Dass man irgendwelche Granaten dann beschriften lassen kann äh und dann äh äh.
Sign Mai Rocket Dot com.
Genau. Ja genau und äh alle möglichen Dinge dann gibt's halt auch viele äh YouTube-Streamer, die,
dann auch regelmäßig so Kampagnen fahren und Geld äh einsammeln für die Ukraine überwiegend so für humanitäre Zwecke dann allerdings gibt's irgendwie einen.
Relativ jungen äh Mann, der irgendwie eigentlich mittlerweile, glaube ich, schon zweihundertfünfzigtausend Dollar alleine in seinen Streams äh eingesammelt hat. Äh sie entforcelt er sich irgendwie auf auf YouTube.
Und äh der macht wie sehr was heißt.
Ähm also mit,
mit sehr viel Inbrunst, so würde ich das mal äh äh sagen, ähm treibt ja die Leute zum Spenden an und holt dann schon mal so 20.000 Dollar ähm,
einem Abend an Spenden über diese YouTube-Spendenfunktion ähm ein.
Für irgendeine humanitäre Organisation meistens für die Ukraine.
Mhm.
Ja, es ist äh irre, lässt sich wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht zusammenrechnen, was da äh auf vielen Freunden zusammengesammelt wird. Auch hier äh auch so eine Aktion.
Gesehen, wo jemand aufgerufen hat. So hier medizinische Versorgung für die
jüngst freigelassenen Kämpfer da von äh die Assowstal äh verteidigt haben in Mario Pool und so und da war dann irgendwie auch in 0Komma nichts 120.000 Dollar zusammen und so weiter. Also überhaupt merkt man eben, wie sich,
so ein ja das das.
So ein so ein internationales Engagement dort breit macht und das einfach auch viele Gesellschaftsschichten auch erfasst.
Und außerdem ist ja jetzt auch noch Mark Hemmel.
Der Schauspieler, der Luke Skywalker in Star Wars gemacht hat, ist jetzt offizieller Embassia da auf The Army of Jones.
Geworden. Also der ist da jetzt auch noch ins Boot eingesprungen und das passt natürlich wie die Faust aufs Auge.
Äh war natürlich dieses ganze Star Wars Meme von irgendwie die unter finanzierten Rebellen gegen das größere größere äh Imperium so das äh passt natürlich da
perfekt und ähm ja passt natürlich da auch perfekt, weil er auch einfach.
Einfach ein cooler äh Typ ist, ich weiß nicht, ob die auf Twitter folgst, kann ich sie sehr empfehlen, Mark Hammel.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Wirklich also das ist wirklich echt so. Ich meine berühmte Leute sind ja manchmal auch ein echtes Problem. Wir kommen am Ende der Sendung auch nochmal auf einen.
Ist so Mark Hammel gehört definitiv nicht dazu. Der hat echt alle beisammen und ist einfach äh eine coole Sau und ähm
finde hat auch einfach eine sehr charmante Art und Weise mit seinen ganzen Fans umzugehen.
Großartig ist da einfach komplett gesettelt in dieser Rolle und ja, es äh nach wie vor im Kampf gegen das Imperium unterwegs ist. Muss man ihm Wut anrechnen.
Tatsächlich noch nicht gefolgt, aber tue ich jetzt.
Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Andere Frage ist natürlich auch immer so, wo,
denn so unsere Informationen her. Ich hatte ja schon mal äh hier
äh kündigt, dass ich so eine Twitterliste habe. Kann ich auch nochmal verlinken, ähm wo ich einfach
ja alle Leute auf Twitter so zusammengeworfen habe von denen ich denke, dass sie sinnvolle
Beiträge zu dem ganzen Spiel leisten. Das ist natürlich einerseits so allgemeine Beobachter und Kommentatoren, die irgendwie die Lage einschätzen et cetera, aber eben auch sehr viele Leute aus dieser O sind
äh Community. Steht für opensource intelligence und ja das,
glaube ich auch mal erwähnen, weil es wirklich enorm ist, was da äh auch geleistet wird, insbesondere
im Bereich der Geo-Location, wie das so schön heißt. Also Ursin steht für Open Source Intelligence und das,
halt einfach, dass Leute in the open ähm ja Intelligence machen. Also die forschen einfach Dingen hinterher
und äh teilen ihre Informationen dann auf Twitter.
Konkret bedeutet das natürlich, dass hier viele Leute vor allem den Russen irgendwie hinterher recherchieren und versuchen, irgendwas rauszubekommen. Da gibt's dann so Aktivitäten, wie das Leute sich einfach stundenlang über irgendwelche Satellitenbilder ähm rübergehen.
Und sich dann auch wiederum von ihrer Community aktuelle Satellitenbilder finanzieren lassen.
Ne, also die haben dann alle so, wie's äh Sandal so schick mir Geld für eine Map so, kauft mir eine Map, dass er sich bei so maxer und anderen äh Satellitenbildanbietern, die ja sozusagen
Material haben, bestimmte Koordinaten einfach kaufen kann, um die sich dann genauer anzuschauen.
Ja, einer zählt äh so alle paar Monate mal
die Panzer in den russischen Depots durch zum Beispiel ja der hat halt der hat sich halt Aufnahmen, kauft er sich dann regelmäßig, äh der weiß halt wo die
russischen Panzerdepots sind und die Panzer stehen da halt meistens im Offenen und dann zählt er die halt einfach. So und veröffentlicht
das und dann halt wie wie viel sind denn da jetzt weniger geworden so im Depot und in welchem Zustand sind denn die und
und so eigentlich und schätze dann, wie viel ja wie viel da jetzt raus sind und wie viel jetzt noch in Reserve äh sind sich.
Oder natürlich dann hier Ohrrings äh der Name ist so ein bisschen noch komplizierter, aber die zum Beispiel ja dokumentieren äh die Verluste an Material auf beiden Seiten und
indem sie halt Fotos analysieren und dann gucken, gab's das schon und
äh wenn nicht, was ist denn das und das dann entsprechend einsortieren und verlinken, so dass es eine komplette Fotodokumentation im Internet gibt,
von jedem zerstörten.
Technik äh oder äh von dem es ein Foto gibt, was öffentlich geworden ist, das wird da dann einsortiert und das ermöglicht natürlich auch äh wirklich tiefe,
Einblicke so.
Und was halt immer noch mit reinspielt, sind natürlich dann immer, immer wenn neues Videomaterial oder Fotos kommen
oder Leute behaupten, dass irgendwas neu sei oder dass irgendwas aus irgendeiner Region sei, insbesondere wenn so russische Accounts sagen, ja hier Angriff,
da und da und irgendwelche Videos veröffentlichen, dann stürzt sich halt äh diese Szene, dieser Geologator da drauf. Da gibt's einfach Leute, die haben einfach,
die sind in der Lage in Windeseile von solchen Videos, die also wirklich teilweise frage ich mich wirklich so wie wie macht ihr das, ja? Also jeder Baum und jede Straßendiagonale
dort irgendwie auch nur für einen kurzen Moment zu sehen ist. Jedes irgendwie halbwegs hervorstechende Feature deiner Hand mit äh Google Earth oder eben auch mit Stre
interessanterweise ist ja die Ukraine sehr gut mit von Google Streetview auch erfasst im Gegensatz zu Deutschland natürlich.
Und ähm ja und dann ähm,
Machen sie halt relativ schnell fest, ähm wo etwas ist, ja, beziehungsweise
etwas irgendwo wirklich äh gewesen ist. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Vorstöße berichtet werden, dass jetzt dieses und jenes Dorf befreit oder angegriffen worden äh ist und es gibt dazu halt in irgendeiner Form Bilder, zum Beispiel eben auch von diesen zerstörten,
Fahrzeugen dann dauert's meistens nicht lange, bis dann halt diese gelocation ähm Leute kommen.
Und sagen ja hier dieser Tweet, das Bild was hier drin ist, irgendwie geocatet und dann zack, bumm GPS Koordinate und dann kann man das halt irgendwie sofort
auch überprüfen und das äh ist dann wiederum eine Dienstleistung für die allgemeinen Analysten, die dann eben auch ihre Map,
es gibt irgendwie zahlreiche die also verschiedene
Karten äh online äh pflegen ähm ich folge da mehreren, weil alle haben so ein bisschen so ihre Qualität,
man hier so ein bisschen aktueller, manche sind ein bisschen konservativer. Manche sind ein bisschen besser zu lesen ähm und
ja bieten von daher so eine Möglichkeit äh auch so einen Überblick über Vorstöße zu bekommen. Und dann gibt's natürlich wieder andere, die sich diese Karten nehmen und dann irgendwie mit einem
Stift reinkritzeln, äh was sie denken, wie's jetzt als nächstes weitergeht.
Ja, das findet ihr alles in dieser Twitter äh Liste. Mal gucken, vielleicht ähm machen wir auch nochmal ein paar Links dazu.
Vor allem eine äh Karte, die ich besonders schätze, weil sie von Anfang an.
Aktualisiert wird und auch.
Wie ich finde immer ziemlich akkurat, dass äh wiedergibt und besonders äh deshalb für mich äh hilfreich ist, weil sie auf Google mymaps.
Angelegt ist. Da sind so einige Karten, nicht andere, aber andere machen benutzen auch andere Kartensysteme. Gibt da mittlerweile so einiges im Netz. Aber alles, was auf Google my Maps ist, hat den Vorteil,
man sich das eben mit so einem Network-Link auch in Google Earth reinschmeißen kann. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie über Google Earth, über die Ukraine rüberfliege, dann wird diese Karte einfach direkt mit eingeblendet und ist aber auch immer alle sozusagen immer aktuell, also wenn irgendeine Änderung stattfindet, dann aktualisiert sich das dann auch und so kann man dann eben, wenn
ortsnahm und Straßen und was nicht alles genannt werden oder irgendwo was explodiert ist oder irgendein Damm angegriffen wurde oder ein Flussverlauf mal relevant ist kann man das dann halt eben sehr schnell auch äh in Konkurrenz bringen mit dem aktuellen Kriegsverlauf.
Und das Schöne an der Karte ist auch noch, dass sie eben so auch immer für die letzten paar Wochen so ein bisschen auch so die Bewegungshistorie noch mit drin hat, dass man auf einen Blick sehen kann, aha okay, hier.
Gerade äh zur Sache und äh hier war zwar früher mal Bewegung, aber schon lange nicht mehr. Ja und man das ganze Kriegsgeschehen damit
ähm sehr schön visualisiert bekommt. Also das sind alles so diese Tools die sich hier so zeigen und überhaupt ist dieser ganze Krieg.
Eine Art und Weise sichtbar? Wie es glaube ich noch nie ein Krieg jemals zuvor gewesen ist.
Das kann man, glaube ich, sagen. Wobei äh gut ist natürlich in früheren äh Kriegen gab's halt äh dann.
Journalisten, die dann mit vorne waren, die gibt's natürlich jetzt auch so, aber es ist natürlich schon was ganz anderes ähm.
Wenn man das quasi auf auf dieser Ebene bekommt, also nicht nur jetzt nochmal Reportagen vor Ort hier so, die ergänzen natürlich, dass das Bild ganz gut, aber quasi auch nochmal.
The Big Picture äh zu haben einfach, den den Überblick und Dinge auch quantifizieren äh zu können und
Dinge auch dann verifizieren äh zu können. Das ist ja auch das Ding ist ja immer so schön heißt so die Wahrheit äh ist halt, dass
immer das erste Opfer im Krieg und ich glaube äh diese ganze ja Open Source ähm
Datensammlung ermöglicht es halt da äh der Wahrheit äh vielleicht ein bisschen näher äh zu kommen und äh eben
zu ja auch zu entlarven, äh wenn dort irgend,
Fehlinformationen oder Propaganda gestreut wurden oder dass dann einordnen kann, wenn,
irgendeine Seite, irgendetwas sagt, äh wie wie nah das denn jetzt äh an die Situation am Boden tatsächlich herankommen.
Man merkt natürlich auch bei denen, also es gibt auch eine Kategorie von äh Twitterern, die ich vergessen habe. Es gibt auch noch so ein paar Leute, die einfach sehr nah auch am
konkreten, militärischen Geschehen sind. Das sind dann also entweder selber Soldaten oder zumindest Ukrainer, die sehr viel Kontakt zu Soldaten haben.
Warme Bar drei zum Beispiel ist da äh ganz weit vorne. Da äh schießen sozusagen die ähm befreiten.
Tschaften irgendwie sofort auf Twitter, äh wenn es soweit äh ist oder wenn sie also noch bevor sie konfirmt sind, also das ist natürlich dann auch immer Gerüchteküche und da muss man dann auch ein bisschen aufpassen,
passen auch auf, sagen auch oft so ja äh good News ist,
aber ich kann jetzt äh noch nix zu sagen, ne, weil sie dann aus ihren
auch sozusagen gesagt bekommen haben, ja findet statt, aber darfst du noch nicht sagen, weil,
kann hier unsere Operational Security gefährden und äh dementsprechend halten sich alle sehr bedeckt.
Nicht nur das, sondern die konkrete Gefahr ist natürlich, wenn grade ich,
irgendeine Ortschaft man da jetzt drin ist, aber da sind jetzt noch, was weiß ich, Russen
und jetzt wird vermeldet frühzeitig irgendwie ja, die Ortschaft ist unter Kontrolle.
Äh so und dann kommen die Leute raus und äh rennen dann vielleicht mitten äh ja noch in irgendwelche Kampfhandlungen hinein
äh und insofern äh glaube ich, will man da auch immer vorsichtig sein und dann immer nur wirklich vermelden äh möglichst, wenn äh quasi offiziell gesagt wird, okay, wir haben jetzt
sind jetzt einmal durchgegangen und äh hm es ist jetzt wirklich unsers da versteckt sich jetzt keiner mehr.
Genau und das ist auch gecleant und manchmal einmal durch alle Häuser durch und die Fahne ist auf dem Rathaus gehiest et cetera. Das ist so der Moment, aber trotzdem ist natürlich einfach der Delay ist halt einfach sehr viel,
kleiner geworden. Also man kann so heute Abend so jetzt.
Bevor wir hier mit dieser Sendung aufgenommen haben, denke ich mal, habe ich so im Wesentlichen die militärischen Ereignisse,
so weitgehend nachvollzogen. So da bin ich vielleicht ein paar Kilometer hinterher hier und da und es gibt äh sicherlich nochmal ein paar Sachen, die noch nicht so verkündet worden sind, aber im Großen und Ganzen ähm ja, habe ich ein.
Das Gefühl ein ganz gutes Verständnis davon gewonnen haben zu können äh was denn nun tatsächlich passiert und das sind dann auch so diese Eindrücke, die wir hier teilen, die das hatte ich ja letzte Mal schon gesagt oder vorletztes Mal.
Wir nicht unbedingt jetzt immer für alles.
So hier ist der Link und hier ist der Artikel, der das jetzt genau äh belegt sagen können, sondern das ist halt einfach so ein hm so eine so eine
Summary aus dem, was man so insgesamt an Informationen so wahrnimmt und wo sich einfach genug verstärkt hat, dass man sagen kann, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auch das, was hier passiert ist.
Ja und gesprinkelt ist das Ganze dann noch mit so richtig tiefgehenden ja würde ich sagen Militär Nerds so oft.
Irgendwelche meistens ehemaligen Soldaten, die dann irgendwie irgend ein Spezialgebiet hatten, äh was weiß ich
äh dann ähm irgendwo mitgeflogen sind als äh
Ja bei der elektronischen Kampfführung äh zum Beispiel oder eben so ein Thema, was
bisher nicht so allzu viel auch beleuchtet wurde, wo wir auch ein bisschen was drüber gesagt hatten, weil ich den einer der nächsten Sendungen mal das Thema elektronische Kampfführung äh da hat ist auch eine ganze Menge passiert. Da wird wenig drüber berichtet.
Oder andere Spezialdisziplinen, äh wo dann äh ja.
Die äh Fähigkeiten der Luftabwehr äh Systeme geredet wird oder.
Ähm ja einfach tief in bestimmte Waffensysteme und Strategien halt hineingegangen wird. Fähigkeiten.
Gibt's natürlich auch noch eine ganze Menge. Also man erfährt halt sehr viel und das hatten wir auch am Anfang
Hier äh Anfang des Kriegs so ein bisschen eingestiegen sind haben wir glaube ich sehr viel in dieser Hinsicht äh konsumiert, um einfach auch mal das eigene Wissen zu aktualisieren. Ja was ist denn jetzt hier eigentlich mit Russland und wie ist denn das überhaupt alles mit
Osteuropa und was ist denn eigentlich so die letzten paar hundert Jahre mit der Ukraine äh passiert? Das ist ja nun einfach mal so Wissen. Das hat man nicht äh so ohne Weiteres auf der Kette.
Da äh ja sind diese ganzen Twitter es reizt sicherlich auch viele andere Artikel aber ich fand das immer sehr informativ auch die Art und Weise wie man auf Twitter sowohl äh verkürzt als auch.
Dann aber auch in in so einer Kaskade mehrerer kurz den,
Informationen ganz gut rüberbringen kann. Das finde ich hat einen.
Hat eine interessante Konsumierbarkeit, also für mich zumindest.
Und dann vielleicht zum Abschluss äh euch noch zwei weitere Quellen äh äh erwähnen, die auch sehr interessant sind. Also zum einen hat äh einfach die US-Regierung, was so Militär angeht,
sind die in manchen Bereichen erstaunlich transparent.
Ähm so was weiß ich, ja die müssen sich ja rechtfertigen wofür sie das Geld ausgeben, das heißt dann so Lagerbestände an Munition und wie viel pro Jahr gekauft wird von von welcher Sorte und so weiter.
Da gibt es halt überall ganz gute Angaben.
So der USA auch dann zu bestimmten Militärdoktrinen äh und so. Da ist ist sehr viel öffentlich. Das heißt, nicht nur in den USA, sondern ähm auch in vielen anderen Ländern.
Aber in den USA fällt es speziell auf äh dass die da doch sehr offen äh sind und der andere Bereich äh sind halt einfach wissenschaftliche Papers.
So ähm die dann auch manchmal äh sehr nützlich sind und Dinge einfach besser zu verstehen. Also wie ist denn jetzt die,
Sprengwirkung, von welcher Waffe eigentlich und welche Reichweiten äh äh hat das denn oder wie verhalten sich bestimmte Materialien? Das war jetzt bei bei Nordstream war das äh sehr interessant
aber da kommen wir ja gleich noch zu.
Genau. Ja, also das dürft ihr euch so in etwa ein.
Einblick geben, woraus wir uns quasi so informationell ernähren und ja und das ist äh so ein bisschen die äh die Grundlage hier.
Ja und wir verdauen das und scheiden das dann wieder.
Genau, ne, das ist.
Sozusagen wir fassen für euch die ganzen Kram zusammen so. Es wird manchmal auch ein bisschen äh viel so. Also wenn man's wirklich so mit zwei-, 3000 Tweets pro Tag äh zu tun hat, wo man dann so quer lesen muss aber ja man gewöhnt sich dran und äh
kriegt's auch irgendwie auffette.
Gut, dann steigen wir mal in die ja eine Woche her, dass wir die letzte Sendung veröffentlicht haben.
Das ist echt so krass. Ich habe das Gefühl, die sind schon wieder drei Wochen vergangen. Es ist so viel passiert. Also.
Es gab einen Anschlag auf die Gaspipeline.
Sagen wir mal so Gaspipelines sind explodiert. Können wir vielleicht also.
Okay, gut, also es gab Explosionen also zumindest wurden sie als solche gemeldet, ja
Dieses Programm schlugen aus und zumindest die Wissenschaftler, die diese Seismographen,
betreiben meinten, das wäre halt wären halt Explosionen gewesen.
Leid zu den Details noch mehr sagen, du hast dich da deutlich mehr eingelesen als ich und äh.
Es wurde dann auch offensichtlich, weil es blubberte einfach seitdem irgendwie Gas äh aus der Ostsee heraus und es wurde dann,
tief schnell klar, dass es hierbei um die Nord Stream eins und die Nord Stream zwei Pipeline handelt, die jeweils ja zwei Rohre haben, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Von diesen vier Rohren insgesamt waren drei davon betroffen. Es wurde ja nochmal ein viertes Leck äh gemeldet. War das dann auch noch die andere sind alle Röhren jetzt betroffen oder ist eine wirklich noch.
Nee, also eine Röhre ist äh nach letzten Meldungen,
noch intakt von Nord Stream zwei.
Ja, auf jeden Fall das war äh ein großer äh Schock und ähm alle fragten sich natürlich, was ist da passiert und wer war's?
Tja also.
Genau, also mich hat das Thema ähm einfach nicht losgelassen, weil äh ich meine, das ist natürlich ein wichtiges
super wichtiges, weltpolitisches Thema und äh für die Frage äh,
Wer war's oder ähm was ist da eigentlich passiert? Ähm so äh habe ich dann angefangen wirklich wirklich.
Tief zu graben, weil natürlich ähm auch der Verdacht aufkam, so so bin ich überhaupt drauf aufmerksam
äh äh geworden, dass da äh dann Debatte läuft, weil ja Präsident Biden irgendwie vor ja weiß ich nicht
einem Jahr oder so
äh gesagt hat, na ja, wenn äh sagen, wenn die Ukraine äh von äh Russland überfallen wird, dann äh werden wir äh Nordstream zwei.
Abschalten so äh wie auch auch immer er das äh äh formuliert hat ähm.
Und das ging dann natürlich rum äh ah ja, die USA und dann hat auch noch der ehemalige polnische Außenminister irgendwie getwittert. Danke USA äh über einem Bild mit einem dieser Gasstrudel und
äh ja und ich habe mich dann gefragt, hm äh was ist da jetzt, was ist da jetzt passiert? Was ist da jetzt los? So.
Und ähm dann wurden ja äh dort diese Explosionen gemeldet. Ähm.
So und dann dachte ich mir, hm es gibt irgendwie ganz viele, es gibt ja im Internet ganz viele Netzwerke.
Wo man, sei es mische Daten direkt.
Rufen kann, wo man sich das halt wirklich angucken kann, wo man halt nach seismischen Events suchen kann, wo man sagen kann, hier
Was war denn in dem Gebiet, in der und der Zeit los und dann wirft er einem halt die ganzen Events einschließlich wie Stärke und äh Positionen. Wo waren das?
Und so wirft er einem alles alles aus und dann kann man sich teilweise eben auch die Signale angucken. Da gibt's eben haufenweise Netzwerke äh und und Seiten, die das Ganze dann aggregieren und,
habe ich mich halt auf die Suche gemacht so nach diesem,
ja, sei es Mischen Aufnahmen. Das war so mein mein Einstieg in das Ganze und.
Bis heute ist es mir tatsächlich nur gelungen einen Event zu finden.
In äh diesem äh Ding, es ist heißt ähm,
dass es zwei große gewesen sein sollen und ein kleiner, ich konnte nur einen Großen finden und äh die anderen müssten, wenn dann so klein gewesen sein oder in irgendwelchen anderen Netzwerken, wo die Daten nicht öffentlich sind.
Drin sein, aber ich ich konnte nur einen finden.
So da das ist das war schon mal so ein bisschen die erste unbefriedigende.
Äh ja äh Sache an gefragt habe, warum finde ich nur einen in den öffentlichen Daten, aber dann wird behauptet, es sind zwei. Aber ich habe dann gesagt, okay,
Auf Twitter gab's dann Bilder zumindest, auch von dem zweiten äh Event.
Und äh das Programm, was dabei veröffentlicht wurde von dem.
Beziehungsweise von dem ersten Event. Also ich habe nur ähm.
Die Daten von dem zweiten gefunden mit äh ja auf der Richterskala zwei Kommazwei ungefähr.
Und äh von dem ersten habe ich nur ein Bild gesehen und.
Die beiden im Vergleich, da war sozusagen der erste Event, war auch nur sehr, sehr klein auf dem äh Seismogramm, wo ich mich dann auch gefragt habe, okay, also Faktor zehn oder hundert kleiner.
Ähm also unbefriedigend. Ja die ganze Situation.
Du wolltest also einfach erstmal rausfinden, was was ist denn da jetzt wirklich gesehen worden, weil man hat ja sozusagen außer der Blubberrei oben in dem Sinne noch überhaupt gar keine Bilder jetzt von dem Geschehen.
Genau, also das Einzige, was wir bisher äh an Fakten haben, ist einmal sagen die.
Die Gasblasen oder des des des schäumenden Meer oder wie man das äh auch immer nennen will und
äh dass dort Methan austritt, also es ist dann relativ klar, dass
äh die Pipeline leer ist Plus ähm Druckabfall auf deutscher Seite, von hieß es zuerst 120 Bar auf sieben Bar.
Und 7 Bar entspricht 70 Meter Wassertiefe. Das passt
also und dann habe ich mir halt auch geguckt bei Nordstream ist auf der Webseite gibt's auch jede Menge Informationen und
aus den Umwelt genehmigungsverfahren liegen die ganzen Anträge offen. Da kann man eben auch sehr viel äh erfahren und unter anderem dann auch eine Karte mit dem tiefen Verlauf, wo,
die Pipeline eigentlich, wie tief liegt und ähm.
Auch eine Karte, wie weit die beiden Rohre dann an welcher Stelle auseinander liegen. Das schwankt halt auch sehr.
Die laufen halt auch also jeweils von Nord Stream eins und von Nord Stream zwei, die laufen ungefähr dieselbe Route, aber weichen ab und die beiden Rohre jeweils.
Sind auch nicht auf konstanten Abstand von fünf oder zehn Metern, sondern das geht ich glaube.
Fünf Meter ist glaube ich der kleinste Abstand und an manchen sind sie hunderte von Metern auseinander die beiden Rohre. So
Dann habe ich erst mal das äh verifiziert und gesagt, okay, die die Tiefe und die Stelle und der Druck und so, das passt alles zusammen, das das glaube ich.
Und,
Programme, dann habe ich das halt äh als erstes äh natürlich mal umgerechnet in die beliebte Energieeinheit Kilogramm TNT.
Und.
Ja, es ist ist tatsächlich einfach nur eine Einheit. Also du kannst es dann auch, äh weiß ich nicht, im Kino-Joule oder,
äh so, aber eben auch Kilogramm äh TNT äh seit,
quasi eine genormte äh Einheit, die äh mit der man dann eine gewisse Vorstellungskraft äh verbi,
dann so. Und wenn man mein nächster Punkt.
Was ich dann äh gemacht habe bis ich habe dann gefragt okay wie viel Sprengstoff bräuchte man denn ähm damit.
Auf einem im seismischen Netzwerk das Ganze als einen Beben von 2,2 auf der Richterskala.
Registriert wird und das sind je nachdem ja 30 bis 60 Kilogramm TNT.
Warum jetzt 2,2 auf der Richterskala, warum genau dieser.
Ja, weil das war sozusagen das, was die Auswertungssoftware von den Seismogrammen ergeben hat.
Ja, also das war sozusagen ein ein Beben der Stärke 2,2 an der Oberfläche, die Tiefe auch an der Oberfläche, also null Meter Tiefe ähm.
In äh eben äh an diesen Koordinaten mit
der Stärke 2,2 wurde gemessen und du es gibt dann auch eben, ich mein Richter ist logarithmisch und es gibt dann auch eine direkte Umrechnungsskala, also von Richterin TNT, ja, weil das ist alles am Ende nur Energie
so. Das heißt, das kann man halt alles umrechnen, ne. Dann ähm ja, äh dachte ich mir, okay, also.
60 Kilo ungefähr äh also eine sechzig,
eine Explosion von 60 Kilo TNT äh entspricht das mindestens. Es ist natürlich dann wieder die nächste Frage, die ich mir dann gestellt hatte, war hm okay, aber,
wenn man jetzt, wenn jetzt so eine Bombe im Wasser explodiert, mhm wieviel geht denn davon tatsächlich in seismische Netzwerke und dann gibt es auch Papers, wo hm,
man das ausprobiert hat so vor.
Ja, Jahrzehnten oder ja für viele Jahrzehnte lang und Daten äh gesammelt hat äh von Explosionen, von Bomben, die man, also man hat,
springen, Sätze explodieren lassen. Man hat dann Sensoren drumgepackt, wo man dann Druckwellen gemessen hat und man hat dann geguckt, in den vorhandenen seismischen Netzwerken, als was wird denn das da registriert? Also wie viel sagen.
Geht in die Erde eigentlich rein, äh so. Und das hängt dann wiederum davon ab, hm wie nah
Also von die Wassertiefe spielt eine Rolle und aber natürlich wie nah der Sprengsatz äh hört tatsächlich am Erdboden ist und es steht dann auch oft dabei, ob das jetzt am Boden war oder ähm eben irgendwo mitten im Wasser und
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ähm hm es.
Passt ungefähr, also die hm sagen wir so, die Bombe, die da explodiert, ist äh dürften also wenn es eine Bombe war, so. Ähm dann äh dürfte sie äh nicht.
Über 500 Kilogramm TNT gewesen sein, weil äh ich
habe halt sämtliche Events bin ich dann durchgegangen, habe halt geguckt, was war äh quasi
ähm das Wenigste, äh was äh äh angekommen ist ähm bei eben entsprechend großen Bomben. Also die sind bis 680 Kilo hochgegangen und so und jedenfalls.
Passte, sagen das, was da gemessen wurde ja äh war jetzt nicht unplausibel, so also
sagen wir mal so könnte ein Sprengsatz zwischen irgendwo neunzig.
500 Kilo ungefähr gewesen sein, der so zwei Komma zwei.
Der Richter äh Skala äh beben verursachen.
Um mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen. Ich meine, es ist schwierig, ein Gefühl für Sprengkraft zu bekommen. Also das spürt man ja auch jetzt normalerweise nicht. Aber wenn jetzt so so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Leopard-Panzer, so seine Standardmunition äh verschießt und die explodiert.
Wie viel TNT Äquivalent ist das denn?
Ähm also das das kommt natürlich wieder wieder ganz drauf an äh äh weil äh was für ein Sprengstoff da
da drin ist, ähm aber Größenordnungsmäßig, also sagen wir so, mit einer Hand fangen wir mal mit einer Handgranate an äh das ist nur in der in der Größenordnung hundert Gramm ungefähr.
Ähm an an TNT Äquivalent mit.
Ähm ja mit einem Gramm TNT.
So ähm das zerfetzten Mülleimer.
Wenn äh und ja und 100 Gramm.
Äh TNT wie gesagt Handgranate äh ist ja.
Das heißt 500 Kilogramm TNT, was da explodiert sein soll, das wäre so 5000 Handgranaten.
Mhm genau oder eine ziemlich große Bombe oder ein großer Torpedo also Torpedos äh den man Schiffe versenkt äh liegen halt auch äh in der Größenordnung, so 2hundertfünfzig Kilo.
Also auch nicht außergewöhnlich viel oder so. Es ist.
Ja, nee.
Also wenn das so top pedosize ist, dann ist das so handelsüblich. Habe mal rum.
Könnte man sagen, ja so 250 Kilo TNT Äquivalent ist glaube ich.
Das war aber jetzt pro Explosion, weil es gab ja vier.
Ja
Oder mindestens drei.
Wurde berichtet. Wie gesagt, finden konnte ich nur wirklich die Daten für eine,
und es wurde gesagt, dass eine mit zwei Komma eins und eine mit 2,3ähäh war. Ich konnte nur eine mit 2,2 finden.
Okay.
Ja äh und die an und äh das System, äh wo ich da gesucht habe, hätte mir halt alles rausgegeben, was äh über äh null Komma sechs auf der Richterskala.
Äh war. Also das ist ein sehr empfindliches System und ich weiß es nicht, ob's ein technisches Problem ist, ob jemand die Daten daraus zensiert hat. Äh äh
äh oder äh ich mich zu dumm angestellt habe, aber ich glaube nicht, ich bin mehrmals auch noch dann äh reingegangen, wo ich mir dachte, vielleicht
kommen sie ja mit Verspätung oder so, aber das hat mich halt schon mal so ein bisschen äh ja unruhig gemacht. So dann habe ich mich gefragt, okay
All diese äh so eine Pipeline hundertzwanzig Bar. Ähm das ist mal äh eine Menge Druck
ja so allein nur Gasdruck und dann habe ich gefragt, okay was ist denn so bei Boiler Explosionen?
Wenn die hochgehen, da wird ja dann auch eine Menge Energie freigesetzt oder Pressluftbehälter.
Ja und da gibt's dann natürlich auch äh überall Berechnungs
Grundlagen gibt's sogar, kann man sich sogar äh runterladen, wo man dann,
einfach eingibt, okay so und so viel bar äh das und das Gas äh
entladen sich in äh
den und den Umgebungsdruck und äh da muss man noch die Kubikmeter angeben äh an an Gas und dann kriegt man auch die freigesetzte Energie, wobei das dann noch davon
abhängt ist es dann äh diabatisch oder addiabtisch, also kühlt sich das dabei ab oder wird dabei irgendwie die Hitze erhalten.
Durch irgendeine chemische Reaktion in dem Fall kühlt sich das natürlich ab so, das heißt das nimmt man an den den kleineren Wert und dann stört man aber auch fest, dass ungefähr ja ein Kubikmeter
an an Pipeline ebenfalls äh wenn das jetzt.
Platzt einfach nur, wenn diese 120 Bar in,
sieben Bar Umgebungsdruck reingehen,
dann ähm.
Habe ich auch eine äh Bombe in der Größenordnung äh von einigen zehn Kilogramm äh TNT. Ja, also allein nur, weil selbst wenn da Pressluft drin wäre und.
Das Ding platzt, auf einen Meter aufplatzt oder äh dann habe ich auch schon eine Explosion von 30 Kilogramm
äh äh TNT und wenn das Ding jetzt auf zehn Meter aufplatzt oder vorne aufplatzt und dann ein bisschen mehr rausschießt, kann ich ohne Probleme auch ein Signal, einen sei es misches Signal erzeugen.
Was äh in der Größenordnung eben von 2,2 auf der Richterskala war. Also, dass ich mich dann gefragt habe, okay, also es braucht nicht unbedingt eine Bombe, sondern das Ding könnte auch
sein. Es könnte aber auch durch eine Bombe zum Platzen gebracht worden äh sein. So. Ja?
Und äh das äh ließ sich für mich zumindest aus den öffentlichen Informationen.
Ließ sich weder das eine noch das das andere ähm belegen. Und wenn ich gefragt okay, aber so eine Pipeline.
Ja eigentlich nicht äh so einfach so, ja.
Passt mal ja auf. Die wird ja regelmäßig gewartet und
inspiziert und vor allen Dingen äh gut eine könnte ja vielleicht sein, aber gleich drei äh innerhalb von zehn Stunden ungefähr oder zwanzig Stunden.
So ein bisschen auch gibt da verwirrende ähm Aussagen über die über die Timeline äh wann eigentlich was passiert ist.
Wobei äh die Zeiten sozusagen die die beiden die ersten beiden Explosionen,
auf die Minute genau äh so um null zwei jeweils. Ich glaube sieben Uhr zwei und äh siebzehn Uhr zwei oder so äh waren sie jetzt nicht mehr genau im
im Kopf, was was die beiden.
Äh Zeiten waren, aber die lagen eben genau auch noch mal eine feste Zeit auseinander. Aber wie gesagt, eine von beiden konnte ich halt nicht finden. So.
Und ähm dann war natürlich die Frage, okay ähm.
Kann das vielleicht sein, dass es Fehlbedienung war oder ein Unfall oder ähm
ja die einfach zu viel Druck auf die Leitung gegeben haben in Russland und die dann geplatzt ist. Das war so ein bisschen meine erste Theorie. Dann habe ich geguckt, okay wo würde denn, wenn man jetzt auf die Leitung in Russland.
Draufgibt. Wo würde die denn dann platzen? Und das hängt dann natürlich davon ab. Äh ich habe festgestellt,
dass die Leitung immer dünner wird, je näher sie an Deutschland rankommt, weil
wie es halt so ein bisschen unidirektional ausgelegt, das heißt
weil's einen Druckabfall gibt, muss die halt an der in der Nähe der Pumpstation in Russland muss ist die halt dicker, ist die 43 Millimeter dick und
die dann an Greifswald äh rankommt, geht's dann bis 22 Millimeter halt runter.
Die Außenwand nicht der.
Ja, die Außenwand, genau, die Außenwand, der Durchmesser ist über der Innendurchmesser ist überall gleich die sozusagen die die Außenwand, also der der.
Also sie kann dann dünner sein, weil man nicht mehr braucht oder äh wäre es ein Problem, wenn sie dicker ist.
Geld. Es war einfach wegen Geld. Es war einfach nur, weil.
Genau, die kann dünner sein und äh je tiefer sie auch liegt, umso dünner kann sie halt auch noch äh sein, beziehungsweise dann hast du ja den Gegendruck vom Wasser quasi der
und da gibt's dann auch genau ein Diagramm, wie sie das enginiert haben, damit das genau mit der Tiefe und ähm den den Auslegungs- und
Betriebs äh Druck.
Der da der da erwartet wird äh so das das ist also ökonomisch haben sie das ganz gut durchoptimiert, dass ich mir dachte, okay hm wenn jetzt also.
Bei uns dünner wird und vor allen Dingen dort auch an die Oberfläche kommt. Mhm.
So, dann ist quasi könnte es durchaus sein, wenn man da zuviel Druck äh draufgibt, äh dass sie dann genau dort platzen würde, wo sie geplatzt ist.
Aber diese Theorie scheitert dann daran. Ich habe dann geguckt, okay was,
wie groß sind denn die die Reserven für also die sind für 200 Barbe.
Spezifiziert. Gefahren wurde sie bei hundert120. Die Turbinen haben sind bis können bis 155 so und da hatten wir okay aber wenn man jetzt irgendwie Sicherungen ausschaltet und die Turbinen da richtig
Gas gibt, kann man die dann vielleicht überpowern äh oder zu viel Druck drauf machen oder was weiß ich Cyber-Atta
äh war dann war dann so die Überlegung, was für ihn einfach nur die Turbine irgendwie aus der Ferne voll aufgedreht hat, ähm aber
die 200 Barbetriebsdruck äh bedeuten, soweit ich das dann
nachrecherchieren konnte, dass die erst ungefähr beim Fünffachen des Drucks wirklich platzen.
Dass sie auf wahrscheinlich auf Faktor 5äh ausgelegt äh sind, aber hm.
Du hast es zumindest mal durchgerechnet, aber zusammenfassen darf, ist es sozusagen ziemlich ausgeschlossen, dass durch Überdruck diese Leitung zum Platzen gebracht werden kann oder äh auch nur wurde?
Also nicht durch, also jetzt nicht durch, ich sage mal statischen Überdruck und man hätte das halt auch merken, gemerkt, weil
der der steigt da ja nicht schlagartig, sondern
ähm da hätte man lange lange Pumpen müssen bis äh auch der Druck so hoch gewesen wäre. Also tagelang wahrscheinlich hätte man pumpen müssen, um das überhaupt auf den Druck zu kriegen oder eine Woche oder so und
Dann ist es auch noch so eine interessantes Detail, äh dass es ungefähr 45 Minuten dauert bis äh
eine Druckwelle in Greifswald ankommt. Also wenn, sagen der Druck in Russland erhöht wird äh obwohl sich die.
Dass äh dieser Druck quasi mit Schallgeschwindigkeit, die,
450 Meter pro Sekunde beträgt in Methan äh Gas, ungefähr mit tausendsechshundert
KMH ungefähr, pflanzt sich quasi die Druckerhöhung äh äh durch, aber ja die Pipeline 1200 Kilometer lang ist, dauert's halt fünfundvierzig Minuten, äh bis sie am anderen Ende,
ankommt. So das wird für für gleich nochmal wichtig, sondern äh hatte ich das quasi ad acta gelegt und dann
kam aber äh das Thema über über Artikel äh verlinkt von jemandem, der irgendwie
In der Gasindustrie aufgewachsen ist, der einen Blogartikel geschrieben hat und er meinte, dass er's gehört hat. Oh, stillgelegte Pipeline. Ähm
Die war doch bestimmt irgendwie zugefroren. Da haben sich doch bestimmt
äh Methan-Propfen gebildet und äh dann hat vielleicht jemand versucht Druck.
Und dann äh ja hat das die die Pipeline äh zerstört so.
Okay, interessante Theorie äh so und bin dann äh richtig tief eingetaucht
in Hydratbildung, äh also es ist so, dass.
Bei hohen Drücken unterhalb einer bestimmten Temperatur bei vorhanden sein von Wasser bildet sich sogenanntes Methanhydrat. Das ist eben äh
Methan, also Gas, was in einem Wasser äh Kristallgerüst
äh sich dann einlagert und es sieht sieht im Prinzip aus wie Eis und es ist halt fest und solide
und nennt sich dann auch brennendes Eis. Kann man sich im Internet auch wunderschön angucken. Also das man so ein Stück Hydrat hat. Dann kann man das anzünden, dann sieht dann aus wie brennendes Gas.
Das bildet sich auch unter natürlichen Bedingungen im Meer äh in in der entsprechenden Meeres äh Tiefe und bildet sich aber
insbesondere eben auch in Pipelines, äh so das hat man in den 30er Jahren festgestellt, dass dass man da plötzlich,
hat und das dann untersuchen, sollte man überhaupt äh Methanhündung hat als chemische Verbindung erst entdeckt, weil, wie gesagt, findest du nur in großer Tiefe oder bei hohem Druck, so.
Äh und dann ja gibt's natürlich jede Menge Literatur äh drüber und äh dann geguckt ja äh also Druck und.
Äh also Druck und Temperatur passt auf jeden Fall so. Also die sind äh,
jeden Fall gegeben. Habe ich geguckt, okay wie schnell bildet sich das denn und
ähm ja bei denen äh Druckverhältnissen, man kann's nicht genau äh äh sagen, aber so vom vom Range her äh innerhalb von Minuten, ja bei den richtigen
äh äh also es geht, geht halt
vergleichsweise schnell, kann aber im Meer auch 1hundert.tausend Jahre dauern, so bis sich da äh bis sich das bildet, aber in der Pipeline unter den Verhältnissen, also das passte alles
Jetzt war halt nur die Frage, okay, wie viel was äh ist, war denn da jetzt Wasser drin in der in der äh Pipeline.
Normalerweise dürfte da ja eigentlich keins drin sein.
Ja, das ist äh wobei.
In nennenswerten Mengen.
Äh ja, es gibt da auch eben gewisse Standards, denen ich dann hinterher recherchiert habe so, wie viel Gas äh wie viel darf denn
äh drin sein oder wie in in welchen Größenordnungen bewegt sich das, weil es,
verschiedene Trocknungsanlagen, dann habe ich.
So was leisten in diese Trocknungsanlagen und,
Es ist wenig ähm es ist zwischen, ich weiß nicht ja, zwischen 30 und 70,
Teile pro Billion, also.
PPM V in den Größenordnungen bewegt sich das. Ähm das heißt, es ist halt ein bisschen Wasserdampf in der Regel ähm.
Immer enthalten, aber das ist normalerweise auch kein Problem, weil wenn der
durchströmt, das das ja äh ist in bewegten,
ist das ist das halt nicht nicht so das das große Problem, aber ähm die gesamte Leitung äh
enthält. Äh ja, je nachdem,
hundert Kubikmeter äh äh Wasser, wenn man das äh so.
Vermutlich auf ganzer Länge oder.
Paar hundert Kubikmeter Wasser. Also so Schwimmbad.
Ja äh aber eben äh weil weil die da ist halt gewaltig viel Volumen.
Ja, ist schon klar, aber es ist so die Menge an Wasser, die insgesamt in dieser Pipeline zu jedem Zeitpunkt drin ist, könnte so ein kleines Schwimmbad füllen.
Also äh ja, aber äh jetzt kippt das dann runtergerechnet auf zu sagen, was ist denn das pro Meter und was ist da sozusagen in einem Kubikmeter also die Pipeline hat ungefähr auch einen Querschnitt von.
Jetzt ein Quadratmeter, sodass man ungefähr rechnen kann quasi ein Meter Pipeline äh äh sind ungefähr auch ein Kubikmeter und das sind dann so zwischen ja zwanzig und
80 Milliliter pro Meter
Pipeline. Ja, wenn man das äh umrechnet, also zwei bis vier Schnapspinnchen ähm
pro Meter, die dann aber, wenn die wiederum kondensieren würden oder wenn sich da Hydrat bildet, eine mehrere Millimeter dicke Schicht
sich bilden wird. Also das ist ungefähr der Wasseranteil in der in der Pipeline. So kann man sich das das vorstellen.
Ja, nur das ist natürlich die Pipeline auf und ab geht und unterschiedliche Temperaturen an verschiedenen Stellen äh äh herrschen. Ähm sodass,
sich die Pipeline eben nicht äh gleichmäßig äh so sagen,
mit mit äh so einer Eis- oder Schneeschicht oder Methanhydalschicht äh.
Ähm füllt, sondern wenn jetzt das Wasser zum Beispiel auch kondensiert einfach, wenn der Wasserdampf.
Äh ähm dann äh kann man ja von ausgehen, äh dass es eben bestimmte Stellen gibt, was weiß ich, die tiefer liegen, wo ähm,
das Ganze dann zusammenfließt oder zusammenkommt oder wo das dann wächst, weil's halt vielleicht ein bisschen kälter ist oder ein bisschen wärmer die Temperatur ein bisschen optimaler ist.
Und dann ausgerechnet es ungefähr
der Wasserdampf von 12 Kilometern Pipeline an einer Stelle zusammenkommen muss, um so ein Kubikmeter hydrat zu bilden, also einen ein Meter tiefen.
Tropfen, der äh das das gesamte Rohr abdichtet. So zu dem zu den Größenordnungen.
Würde denn so eine Abdichtung dann auch schon reichen, also selbst wenn die jetzt sozusagen überhaupt zustande käme, würde denn das überhaupt reichen, um dann so einen Effekt äh auszulösen?
Na ja.
Da muss dann noch was Weiteres dazukommen und zwar, ich meine, das erste Problem ist natürlich und.
Auch diverse Untersuchungen und Papers äh drüber. Ähm.
Paar Tage sind kein wohl auch kein Problem, so eine Pipeline stillzulegen, äh so ähm aber,
sagt über Wochen oder so von ausgehen, gibt's dann Probleme. Ähm da kann es Probleme geben und,
ähm das äußert sich dann erstmal einfach als Verstopfung. Es kommt dann am anderen Ende nix raus. So. Deswegen muss man halt sehr vorsichtig sein beim.
Beim Wiederanfahren, äh wenn man die ein paar Tage äh liegengelassen hat.
Um diesen Tropfen wieder aufzutauen, könnte man entweder die Pipeline erwärmen, das ist aber nicht wirklich möglich und das hat auch jemand in Russland mal versucht dabei mit einem mit einer Lötlampe äh das ist nicht gut gegangen.
Ähm äh es gibt dann auch wieder Pipelines, die beheizt sind, aber äh da man einen bestimmten Mindestdruck braucht, kann man diese.
Auch wieder auftauen, indem man einfach Druck aus der Leitung lässt. So, also ich habe dann ausreichend ungefähr, man muss den Druck dann unter 20 Bar senken, um so ein Plaque äh wirklich
aufzutauen ähm.
Aber hm wenn man jetzt davon ausgehen, da sind jetzt 120 Bar in der Leitung. Das sind 120 Kilogramm.
Pro Quadratzentimeter, ja? Äh oder.
Ja umgerechnet an Druck, also eigentlich äh hm bist du meist von Kilo in Newton äh pro von zehn Kilo Newton pro Quadrat äh äh Zentimeter äh äh ja ähm.
So ganz gut vorstellen.
Ja, eher zehn Kilogramm pro Quadrat äh äh Zentimeter und wie gesagt, dieser Plug hat jetzt aber.
Ähm ja ungefähr einen Quadratmeter, ist sehr groß. Das sind eben hundert mal hundert Zentimeter. Äh das sind halt zehn.000 Quadratzentimeter, sind also dann zehntausend Mal
ein Kilo pro Bar Druckunterschied. Ja?
Ganze überlegen, wie viel Druck da jetzt zusammenkommt, selbst nur bei einem Druckunterschied von 10 oder,
wenn du also jetzt da Druck ablässt. Ähm,
und.
Irgendwann bei irgendeinem Druck äh löst sich dann halt der Tropfen beziehungsweise wenn du halt den Druck zu sehr senkst, kann es eben passieren, dass der dann halt von der Wand abreißt, der Tropfen
und äh wird dann, das habe ich dann auch, schön nachgerechnet, kann man in meinen meinen Tweets äh äh sehen.
Wird dann ungefähr auf
äh ja Schallgeschwindigkeit äh beschleunigt und zwar bei zehn Bardruckunterschied würde das eine halbe Sekunde dauern.
Bis äh eben dieser Plug,
in dieser Leitung Schallgeschwindigkeit erreicht hat, also vierhundertfünfzig Meter pro Sekunde oder tausendsechshundert KMH ja
und äh schneller wird er aber auch nicht, dass ich dann auch weil äh wiederum die Schallgeschwindigkeit äh in Gasen hängt nur von der Temperatur ab, aber nicht vom vom Druck.
Und jedenfalls ja habe ich habe ich dann nochmal ausgerechnet und was passiert dann äh äh gut erstmal passiert nix, der Plug schießt halt einfach nur nur los, das ist jetzt erstmal nicht so schlimm solange er in Bewegung.
Ist. Aber äh jetzt macht die.
Halt auch Biegungen und Kurven und geht halt rauf und äh äh runter und äh na sozusagen das eine Problem.
Äh wenn das dieser Plaque dann halt jetzt in die Kurve geht
dann entsteht natürlich eine entsprechende Zentrifugalkraft plus hinter dem Plug bewegt sich dann auch nochmal 66 Kilogramm Gas pro Meter, das heißt da kommt dann auch nochmal, wenn du jetzt 1 Meter Gas noch
dahinter hast, die unterwegs sind, dann machen die auch noch mal 660m Kilo aus oder wenn du.
Einen einen Radius, einen Kurvenradius hast von, sagen wir mal 200 Metern oder so.
Ähm äh ja, dann kommen 2hundert mal sechs6 Kilo, die dann mit 450 Metern pro Sekunde äh um die Kurve schießen und,
Ja, da kommt man dann so auf mehrere,
tausend Tonnen, also bis zu 20.000 Tonnen, die dann an seitlicher äh Kraft quasi wirken äh selbst wenn der Plug nur um die Kurve fährt, ja? Ähm
dass die Pipeline aushält eher unwahrscheinlich, aber es gibt halt noch ein zweites äh Szenario, wenn du nämlich irgendwo.
Was bevor so ein Plug entsteht, entstehen halt Engstellen. Der wächst halt quasi so von außen zusammen und
das kann dann halt gut sein, dass dann dieser Plaque, selbst wenn er nicht um die Kurve fährt
in irgendeinen anderen sagen halbzugewachsenen Plug äh hinein äh fährt und,
der released dann auch seine gesamte Energie, also
sagt einen Kubikmeter ungefähr ein Gewicht von einer Tonne, also 900 Kilogramm äh wären ein Kubikmeter Methan Hydrat äh
Wenn der dann äh irgendwo rein äh rammt, wie gesagt, in so einen anderen Halbplaque
habe ich ausgerechnet werden auch äh Größenordnungsmäßig so 60 Kilogramm äh TNT Äquivalent.
Freigesetzt. Das ist überall komischerweise sind wir überall in der Größenordnung 30 bis 60 Kilogramm,
Bei platzen der Pipeline so ein großer Hydrat-Plaque äh oder
eben auch einen ja Sprengstoff. So. Ja, jetzt war halt die Frage.
Okay, äh dass so was theoretisch passieren kann mit den, heißt nicht, dass es jetzt auch tatsächlich passiert ist, weil
dazu hätte halt schon jemand irgendetwas tun müssen und vor allen Dingen würde es wahrscheinlich nicht mit
drei Pipelines gleichzeitig passieren. Es sei denn und ich meine, das ist jetzt alles, wie gesagt, ist jetzt bisher alles noch spekulation, aber
nehmen wir mal an eine dieser Pipelines äh
Wollten die warten und haben dann deswegen entweder äh ein bisschen Druck abgelassen oder aus irgendeinem anderen Grund, hat jetzt eine Pipeline irgendwo in Russland Druckverlust, weiß ich nicht.
Aus welchen Gründen auch auch immer so und das hat jetzt in einer Pipeline, ich sage mal so einen ja.
Dieses Szenario ausgelöst mit äh Druckdifferenz und äh eine Pipeline wird jetzt,
quasi durch so ein Hydrat-Plaque, äh der da aus der Kurve fliegt. Äh ein Schock ähm zerstört. So.
Wir stellen jetzt fest, oh Gott äh so eine der Pipelines ist jetzt leckgeschlagen.
Ähm und überlegen sich dann, äh äh dann lass uns lieber mal jetzt äh den Druck aus der zweiten Pipeline vielleicht,
äh äh rauslassen oder es war einen Wartungsplan und Sie haben's halt nicht nicht wirklich gemerkt so.
Ähm und äh,
ja und erst erst dann bei der vierten Pipeline, als dann als ihn dann die dritte Pipeline um die Ohren gefallen ist, äh um die Ohren geflogen ist, haben sie dann gesagt, okay stopp, das reicht jetzt. So das äh
quasi einziehen, aber weiteres Szenario äh wäre noch okay, es ist erstmal eine,
explodiert und zehn und da ist jetzt äh die ganze Zeit Gas ausgetreten und zehn Stunden später war aber das Loch, was vielleicht.
Gegraben wurde, an der Stelle so groß, dass die Zweite einfach abgeknickt ist, weil sie nicht mehr auf äh nicht mehr genug stabilen Grund hatte.
Insofern äh gäb's da äh durchaus jetzt eine ganze Reihe von Szenarien, äh die das Ganze,
erklären könnten, die jetzt aus meiner Sicht auch nicht unwahrscheinlicher sind als und jetzt kommen wir zu dem Anschlagsszenario, würde ich sagen mal langsam. Ähm.
Wäre ganz gut, ja.
Ja wenn man es jetzt als Anschlag betrachtet,
ist es aber auch irgendwie komisch. Okay äh da wird erst eine Pipeline gesprengt und dann wartet man zehn Stunden.
Um die nächste Pipeline zu sprengen so äh warum,
vielleicht einfach nur dann jemand, weiß ich nicht, Zeitzünder falschgestellt oder äh.
Wie kannst du nochmal sagen, wann waren denn also wie sind denn diese Impacts gemessen worden, mit welchem zeitlichen Abstand.
Mit genau zehn Stunden.
Der ersten und der zweiten oder der dritten oder.
Zwischen der ersten und der zweiten waren genau die dritte gewesen sein soll,
So, da habe ich nur widersprüchliche Informationen äh drüber.
So und eine und eine vierte über eine Vierte wurde auch gemutmaßt, ja. Gefunden habe ich persönlich, also verbürgen tue ich mich nur für eine.
Glauben tue ich durchaus auch die Zweite, ja? So und ich meine, klar, es könnte natürlich auch einen verbockter Anschlag gewesen äh äh sein, wo man dann halt
irgendwie eine Bombe hat nicht funktioniert oder man hat man jetzt auch spekulieren, okay, wer auch immer das gemacht hat, wollte jetzt nicht alle kaputtmachen, sondern irgendwie aus irgendwelchen dubiosen Gründen
eine von den Pipelines.
Intakt halten, ja und ja hat aber zwischendurch gewahrt, ich meine äh ja kann.
Alles sein, ja? Alles möglich, kann's alles Gründe für geben, aber äh so aus militärischer Sicht,
ist das Ganze wirkt es für mich auch nicht wirklich plausibel, ja? Ähm und.
Insofern solange das war so ein bisschen ich sage mal mein äh Resümee erstmal bevor nicht,
wirklich klare Anhaltspunkte oder mehr Anhaltspunkte äh für eine Sprengung oder eine Bombe äh,
irgendwo da sind, wie zum Beispiel ja Fotos, wo man dann drauf sehen kann, wie denn die Beschädigung eigentlich ist oder irgendwelche chemischen Reste oder Reste von irgendeiner Bombe oder von irgendeinem.
Sprengstoff, also ja äh aber offensichtlich also es gibt keine Bilder äh davon äh bisher. Und in insofern,
halte ich im Moment für äh sozusagen einen.
Unfall für genauso wahrscheinlich oder möglich äh wie einen Anschlag. Ich würde sogar
eher aus Gründen von Handel und Rasiermesser ähm so äh nehme ich nicht Böswilligkeit zu unterstellen, wo halt Inkompetenz äh äh ja ausreicht, um
ähm etwas zu erklären, bin ich erstmal bei Hanlon an der Stelle, äh solange wie gesagt, äh ich äh,
da keine glaubwürdigen Informationen darüber habe, dass es sich wirklich um Sprengsätze gehandelt hat. Aber.
Wenn es sich denn dann um Sprengsätze gehandelt äh hat, ähm wer könnte es denn gewesen sein?
Ja also ich habe jetzt hier auch nochmal nachgeguckt also diese ersten Explosionen waren am sechsundzwanzigsten neunten um neunzehn Uhr drei.
Und das waren ja sozusagen da das ist auch eine Stelle, wo Nord Stream eins und zwei.
Relativ nah beieinander sind, das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, wie nahe die beieinander sind, aber wo sie im wesentlichen denselben Verlauf haben. Und die andere äh Explosion war halt um zwei Uhr drei, also.
Zehn Stunden davor und die betrifft nur Nord Stream zwei.
Das nehme ich jetzt äh dem Wikipedia Artikel dazu.
Mhm.
Also nicht zehn Stunden, sondern siebzehn Stunden.
Äh okay, mir war's nicht siebzehn, war's nicht siebzehn Uhr, sondern siebzehn Stunden, ja. Äh genau.
Genau siebzehn Stunden. Zwei.
Mhm.
Dreiundneunzig Uhr drei. Als ob da einer den Timer falsch programmiert hat.
Ja genau, lass mich nochmal kurz äh.
Ah ja. Ja. Also ich habe ich habe nur äh das äh bis siebzehn Uhr drei äh siebzehn Uhr drei hm?
Neunzehn Uhr drei.
Siebzehn Uhr drei UTC. Äh.
Ach so äh ja OTC jetzt weiß ich nicht.
Neunzehn Uhr drei, neunzehn Uhr drei GMT, ja.
Doch neunzehn Uhr drei.
Genau. Also den den neunzehn Uhr drei Event, das ist der einzige, äh den ich gefunden habe mit 2,2 auf der Richterskala, sagt ähm.
Wikipedia meint, neunzehn Uhr drei im ES äh ESC, ach so Sommerzeit, das ist dann GMT.
Mhm.
Genau. Also den anderen, der dann äh was siebzehn Stunden davor gewesen sein soll.
Mhm, so den den finde ich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, das kann kann jetzt sein, dass das irgendwie eine technischer Glitch ist.
Bevor wir jetzt auf die Anschlags äh Theorie äh kommen, nochmal kurz, also äh deine Überlegungen, was es sonst auch noch vielleicht hätte sein können, dass man, also du hast das ja sozusagen mal durchgerechnet und durchgeforscht, um einfach mal,
die Option so auf dem Tisch äh zu haben, ne? Äh das geht ja auch noch zusammen mit einer Druckmessung auf der deutschen Seite. Also wir hatten ja dann einen relativ deutlichen Druck.
Abfall.
Ja, aber der war dann vermutlich eher äh sagen, durch die geplatzte
Leitung dann, weil dort das Gas entwichen ist und der wäre dann genau eben auf die sieben Bar, wenn das Loch in in 70 Meter Tiefe ist, wäre der Druck eben genau auf sieben Bar dann runtergegangen.
Bis zu sagen im äh in im deutschen Teil, weil,
die ist ja relativ nah äh schon auf auf deutscher äh Seite äh das das Ganze.
Also äh ja mindestens hundert, 200 Kilometer ungefähr größenordnungsmäßig. Ähm.
Ja
Jetzt kann man also, ich meine die Berichte also bist du denn jetzt sozusagen mit der Darstellung, dass es sich hierbei um Explosionen handelt, zufrieden?
Ja, also wie gesagt, explodiert. Also es gab, ich ich glaube, dass es mindestens eine Explosion gab. So.
Ähm und äh äh oder ich oder ja.
Es sieht so aus, als wenn es mindestens eine in den Spiegel schrieb mindestens zwei Explosionen, ja? Ähm so, okay, zwei.
Explosionen. Die Frage ist eben nur äh äh.
Waren diese Explosionen jetzt Sprengsätze oder war das einfach ein Platz ein der Pipeline oder einem Platzen der Pipeline in Verbindung mit einem Hydrat äh Plug, der ähm.
Ja irgendwo äh reingelaufen äh ist oder eine Kombination aus beidem so. Also mit anderen Worten um diese diese Explosion zu erklären, äh brauche ich erstmal keine Bomben. Ja.
Das ist der Punkt. Das Einzige und und wie man ja.
Der Grund, warum er von Sabotage jetzt ausgeht, ist halt dieser zeitliche Zusammenhang. Ähm es ist der einzige, muss sagen.
Ja verdächtige Punkt äh an der ganzen Sache, äh dass eben drei,
Rohre betroffen sind, aber habe ich ja schon gesagt ähm.
Durch den Zeiten der zeitliche Abstand. Also ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass eben eine Explosion und zehn Stunden später ist das Ding halt gebrochen.
Siebzehn Stunden später, nachdem da siebzehn Stunden mit 120 Bar Gas rausgesprudelt
ist und vielleicht irgendwie ein tiefes Loch äh äh da unten in den Meeresgrund gegraben äh hat, dass die zweite Pipeline halt hinterher gestürzt ist. Und dass man dann aus Panik
äh irgendwo bei der dritten Pipeline dann angefangen hat ähm irgendwas abzulassen und dann nochmal so ein Hydrat äh Plaque um die Ohren geflogen.
Also ich halte das für na ja also.
Nicht sonderlich ähm wie soll ich sagen, einleuchtend diese Erklärung, ne? Um vielleicht auch mal die zeitliche Abforderung mal ganz klar zu machen. Also Nord Stream zwei.
Genauso wie Nord Stream eins, zwei Röhren. Eine Röhre davon ist im Eimer und das war die erste Explosion und dann.
Siebzehn Stunden später die zweite. An der Stelle, wo Nord Stream eins und zwei relativ nahe beieinander sind. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie wie nah und äh ja da seien jetzt vielleicht drei äh Lexi.
Räumlich relativ nahe beieinander sind. Also es klingt halt schon, also sagen wir mal jetzt mal.
Vielleicht mal die ganze Nerdargumentation mal kurz äh zur Seite gelegt.
Und du hast ja gerade Handlons äh Rasiermesser äh.
Das erklärt ja dann Sachen irgendwie mit Dummheit, ne? Ähm ich würde mal sagen.
Es ist genauso naheliegend, dass es sich hierbei jetzt wirklich um eine extern herbeigeführte Sabotage-Explosion handelt. Das ist also,
äh auch äh einen Ansatz, der alles erklärt. Und ähm da wir uns ja nun mal gerade in einer großen Krise befinden, wo es sehr viel
Gas und Energieversorgung geht und auch noch Russland irgendwie eine gewisse Vertrautheit mit dieser Pipeline äh hat äh kann man natürlich auch die Vermutungen in den Raum stellen
dass äh hier Russland unter Umständen einer der Akteure äh gewesen ist oder der Akteur gewesen ist.
Ja, nicht nicht nur das, sondern äh und das war das andere Ding. Irgendwie haben.
Alle Länder irgendwie vor und Nachteile davon. Ich weiß nicht oder oder man kann zumindest postulieren, dass sie alle irgendwie vor und Nachteile davon haben, komischerweise. So.
Russland hätte mindestens fünf Motive oder mögliche Motive äh äh.
Und wenn es irgendjemand gesprengt hat, würde ich auch erstmal auf Russland äh tippen, weil äh die halt, wie gesagt, einmal, ich meine, sie haben ja schon geschwindelt mit den kaputten Turbinen äh und äh
ein starkes Motiv könnte halt sein, tut uns leid, aber,
Nord Stream eins ist halt jetzt.
Und das ist jetzt höhere Gewalt und irgendjemand hat unsere Leitung kaputt gemacht und ähm
Und wenn ihr aber jetzt unbedingt äh jetzt Gas haben
wollt und unseren Forderungen nachkommt. Wir haben ja noch diese eine Nord Stream zwei, da müsst ihr jetzt gucken und wenn wir die und wenn wir das jetzt reparieren sollen, müsst ihr auch
irgendwie Sanktionen aufheben, weil dann muss muss irgendwie die Firma äh äh um das zu reparieren, muss sie halt
tätig werden und so. Also das wäre quasi mal so ein Ding auf der anderen Seite.
Ist es eine Teil deren Pipeline und das erscheint jetzt auch erstmal nicht unbedingt plausibel äh dass die Russen ihre eigene Pipeline oder zu gut Nord Stream zwei gehört zu neunundvierzig Prozent den äh Nordstream eins gehört zu neunundvierzig Prozent ähm
diversen europäischen Firmen und zu einundfünfzig Prozent Gaspromo und Nord Stream zwei ist halt komplett russisch so.
Und ähm ja mhm also.
Viele Leute, warum sollte Russland erst mal seine eigene Pipeline in die in die Luft jagen und irgendwie sich da so einen Schaden äh äh mit mit verursachen.
Aber da kann man sagen zum Schaden der dürfte aus finanzieller Sicht nicht nicht so groß äh sein, also ich sage mal.
Paar hundert Millionen wahrscheinlich äh lässt sich das alles äh wieder äh reparieren so in der Größenordnung dürfte der Schaden äh liegen, aber da kommt man dann zu reparier äh kann man vielleicht noch extra was sagen.
Ähm ja und dann gab's natürlich noch noch eine Reihe weiterer äh Gründe spekuliert habe für Russ die vorteilhaft für Russland sind zum einen schafft's das natürlich erstmal Angst
ja und Unsicherheit in Europa, so dass vielleicht die Deutschen dann die sowieso ja solche Schisser sind wie
zumindest Putin äh glaubt.
Ähm das äh ja wir dann ein bisschen mehr Panik kriegen oder hier bisschen mehr Instabilität und Unruhe in Europa und dadurch die Unterstützung für den für den Krieg äh vielleicht
wankt, also das ist sicherlich auch äh einen äh ein potenzielles Motiv
für Russland und Eskalation ist halt immer gut und abstreiten können sie's halt.
Auch. Das ist halt auch nicht schlecht. Gut für den Gaspreis geht in die Höhe, aber davon hat Russland halt eher nicht so viel, weil sie ja ja nicht wirklich Gas exportieren können und dann wurde noch gemutmaßt, dass,
Vielleicht das auch ähm,
eine eine innenpolitische Bedeutung in Russland haben könnte, dass quasi das den Hardlinern die Möglichkeit nimmt mit,
putscht dann ganz schnell die Energielieferung wieder aufzunehmen. So ja obwohl das eben auch Quatsch ist, weil äh
da ist halt jetzt eine Leitung ist ja noch in Ordnung so und da kommt man eine Menge Gast durchpumpen. Das würde völlig reichen, eine Leitung.
Kann natürlich jetzt auch argumentieren, dass Russland es sozusagen schon äh aufgegeben hat daran zu glauben, dass äh die Deutschen nochmal diese Leitungen in Betrieb nehmen und da ist sicherlich auch einiges dran.
Ähm jetzt stellt sich natürlich noch ein bisschen die Frage und das geht jetzt vielleicht so in Richtung Reparatur auch.
Wie schnell müsste man die denn jetzt eigentlich reparieren? Also auch darüber, ob die denn jetzt quasi.
Nur gerade kaputt sind oder für immer kaputt sind. Da gibt's ja offensichtlich auch verschiedenste Darstellungen. Ich habe von irgendwie alles kein Problem bis äh oh wenn da erstmal äh ganz viel Wasser durchläuft, dann ist alles vorbei.
Alles äh gelesen, was äh ist denn da deine Erkenntnis zu?
Ja wenn man da.
Das hat mich natürlich auch interessiert, weil das stand dann auch in dem Spiegelartikel wurde dann oder die mehrfach nicht nur im,
Fokus schrieb's auch und andere Medien hätten das auch kolportiert, dass ja nach dass Experten.
Befürchten, dass nach dem Eindringen jetzt von Meerwasser halt äh diese Pipeline für den Gastransport nicht mehr geeignet wäre. So haben Sie das formuliert.
So und dann dachte ich mir, hm okay kann das sein, dass irgendwie,
äh das Ding durch Meerwasser kaputt geht äh keine Ahnung.
Aber äh habe mich dann eben auf die Suche gemacht äh und dann geguckt, woraus besteht denn die Pipeline? Was was ist denn das? Und ähm
neben diesem, was wir schon hatten, wie gesagt, relativ hochwertigen zweiundzwanzig bis 40
Millimeter dicken Stahl, also muss man auch noch sagen. Das ist ungefähr doppelt so dick wie jetzt der die Panzerung beim Kampfpanzer Mada. Ja und entspricht ungefähr der dicke äh der Hülle der Druckhülle eines Atom.
Diese Pipeline, also die Pipeline ist äh mächtig, ja, also schon mal der also der Stahl. Wenn man sagen, also es dauert äh also um dann
Also durchrosten wird das Ding in 100 Jahren nicht, ja. Zumal.
Äh es außen auch noch nochmal äh eine vier Zentimeter dicke Betonschicht hat, die noch mal mit Eisenerz äh gefüllt ist.
Ding schwer genug ist, damit es nicht nicht aufschwimmt und alle sieben bis 9 Pipeline Segmente sind auch noch mal Opfer an Noten.
Angebracht, entweder aus Aluminium oder Zink, die halt äh als Korrosionsschutz dienen. Aber das ist halt alles außen.
Innen ist das ganze Epoxid,
harzbeschichtet, also im Prinzip Autollack äh kann man sagen, ist halt lackiert von innen. Äh
Aber das ist weniger korrosions äh Schutz oder eigentlich gar nicht Korrosionsschutz, sondern soll halt in erster Linie dazu dienen, die Reibung
zu reduzieren, damit halt das Gas besser strömt. Aber ähm die ist halt.
Äh
ja nicht durchgängig beschichtet, sondern an den Schweißstellen äh äh wiederum, weil man da eben schweißen muss und das verträgt sich mit dem Epoxy nicht. Das wird halt vorher aufgetragen. Äh gibt's halt dann eben
da wo die aneinander geschweißt sind ist es ist halt keine Beschichtung. So so äh äh ist die Pipeline, dachte ich mir hm also,
Sieht jetzt erstmal nicht so aus, als wenn das äh.
Problem wäre, aber wer weiß und dann am Ende äh eines äh dieser Reports stand dann, wie denn die Inbetriebnahme erfolgt ist und.
Nachdem die Pipeline eben jetzt zusammengeschweißt war und so äh wird das Ding halt gespült und gespült wird das mit mehr Wasser.
Mit gefiltertem Meerwasser. Da war eben auch wegen Umwelt-Impact
äh sagen, waren dann genau die Mengen kalkuliert und wo das dann wieder abgelassen wird und dass man dann schon lieber weniger salzhaltiges Wasser nimmt und gefiltert einfach nur, damit da halt kein.
Dreck äh.
Nicht noch zusätzlich Dreck reinkommt oder Fische oder weiß der Geier, Algen, die will man da nicht drin haben, aber ansonsten äh,
diese Pipeline vor der Inbetriebnahme haben einfach mehrere Monate mit Meerwasser gefüllt. Ja und das äh ja ist zumindest äh dann offenbar kein Problem.
Danach wird das Wasser irgendwie rausgepumpt und die Pipeline.
Geputzt und äh ja so funktioniert das und wenn man.
Jetzt die Pipeline reparieren müsste, was eben auch relativ,
einfach ist. Da gibt's viele Methoden. Einige davon wurden speziell auch für Nordstream entwickelt. Hm man kann die Pipeline entweder anheben.
Und dann an der Oberfläche zusammenschweißen und wieder runterlassen.
So eine Variante oder äh man kann halt äh entsprechend so einen ja Druckgefäß
absenken, wo dann ähm Leute drin arbeiten können und in 70 Meter Tiefe ist das jetzt auch nicht das große Problem und äh ja die.
Und diese ganzen äh Schiffe, die man dafür braucht, also sind ja spezielle Schiffe, die so solche Sachen machen, die gibt's ja auch, also weil die das ist eh Teil der Wartung, ne?
Ja beziehungsweise äh werden ja auch noch andere Pipelines äh gebaut. Äh so wurde ja gerade jetzt die zwischen Norwegen
und äh Polen fertiggestellt. Da wurde dann auch wiederum gemutmaßt, ja die Norweger und die Polen und die Engländer und die Amerikaner haben sich zusammengetan aus irgendwelchen Gründen, um die Pipeline zu sprengen.
Ja, also ich meine mit diesen ganzen Gerüchten kaum war das äh die News äh raus, dann war ja irgendwie das Internet schon wieder voll mit solchen äh Vermutungen so, also äh und.
Geschwindigkeit dieser der Verbreitung solcher Verschwörungs äh Erzählungen war dann wieder so schnell
Das ist schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck macht, äh dass da äh jemand gut vorbereitet war und es ging dann alles so mit ja die USA hat das jetzt
weil Biden hat das ja gesagt, hat's ja äh am Anfang auch schon erwähnt.
Ich meine, dass sie das ausgerechnet jetzt machen, wo sowieso äh diese Leitungen weitgehend stillgelegt sind, einerseits weil sie nicht in Betrieb genommen wurden im Fall von Nordstream eins und andererseits weil halt die Russen jetzt irgendwie aufgehört haben, Gas zu liefern im Fall von,
Nordstream eins.
Gibt's da überhaupt gar keine Motivation, ne? Abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich auch für die USA eigentlich auch für alle westlichen Länder.
Aus meiner Warte her überhaupt keine Motivation gibt, das zu tun, geschweige denn, dass dass man das den zutrauen würde.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, dass Deutschland irgendwie sowas äh durchführen würde? Nie im Leben. Und äh das gilt sicherlich auch für alle anderen äh Beteiligten. Von daher,
ist es so ein bisschen und vielleicht sollten wir da jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen drauf äh kommen und enden auch. Äh es ist schon nicht komplett.
Unwahrscheinlich davon auszugehen, dass hier Russland.
Welcher Motivation im Einzelnen auch immer und wenn es dann auch nur die Motivation ist, der fortwährenden Destabilisierung und latenten Bedrohungen.
Ja, weil das ist nun mal das Spiel, was Putin hier äh die ganze Zeit spielt und nicht erst jetzt, seitdem er in die Ukraine einmarschiert ist, sondern eigentlich.
Schon immer. Also diese ganze Angst vor Russland, die hier.
Omnipräsent ist und die wir ja auch im Verlauf dieser ganzen Kriegsdebatte auch immer wieder aufkochen sehen.
Das wird natürlich durch durch solche Dinge auch genährt und äh letzten Endes.
Kommen wir dann im Verlauf dieses äh des Kriegsgeschehens ja auch noch mal drauf äh macht es halt einen zunehmenden Maße den Eindruck als äh als ob hier sich äh ein System.
Gefährlicher äh dargestellt hat, als es am Ende wirklich ist.
Hast du jetzt noch was äh konkretes äh dem noch,
hinzuzufügen, ansonsten würde ich weiter äh schreiten wollen, weil es ist halt derzeit.
Alles noch etwas unklar und es ist vor allem unklar, inwiefern hier überhaupt noch Klarheit reinkommen.
Ist wir werden jetzt in absehbarer Zeit durch diese,
Pipelines kein Gas mehr erhalten. Weil natürlich jetzt auch so eine Reparatur und eine Aufhebung der Sanktionen auch komplett.
Ausgeschlossen zu sein scheint. Also das kann ich mir irgendwie nicht äh vorstellen. Und dann muss man auch mal sehen, wie viele Fische sich da eingenistet haben und ob man irgendwie das Ding in zehn Jahren dann doch noch mal wieder in Betrieb nehmen kann oder ob irgendjemand wirklich sagt so oh ja ein Jahr.
Mal, jetzt haben wir da so viel Geld ausgegeben. Jetzt machen wir's zumindest mal wieder heile. Zumal wir ja dann davon ausgehen muss, dass wir auch immer das getan hat, ja? Vielleicht die Russen.
Gleich wieder den nächsten Sprengsatz äh zünden.
Ja ich sehe das im Prinzip auch so, es macht gerade im Moment
alles keinen Sinn. So also es äh ja am ehesten macht es noch Sinn wirklich das,
Russland da irgendwas getan hat, aber
auch für Russland macht es jetzt nicht so viel Sinn, wobei Russland viele Dinge tut, die keinen Sinn äh ergeben so, insofern, auch das würde irgendwie auf Russland weisen, dass es einfach äh so eine total kranke
Aktion wäre, wenn das jetzt Absicht äh wäre, ja. Aber ähm wie gesagt, ich äh
ich glaube, also solange es keine konkreten Hinweise äh gibt.
Ähm für einen Anschlag, also mehr als das, was jetzt da ist so.
Äh bin ich erstmal bei äh irgendeinen Freak Excedent
äh äh es es passiert, ja halte ich für die, ich sage mal, gebe ich sechzig, siebzig Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit äh dreißig, 40 Prozent
äh das äh hm ja es ein Anschlag war und.
Wenn es ein Anschlag war, mich zu achtzig, 90 Prozent würde ich sagen, war's war's Russland und ich glaube, wir werden auch.
Den nächsten
Jahre und Jahrzehnte mit Verschwörungstheorien es zu tun haben und äh egal, was da jetzt wahrscheinlich hochkommt, so
es Leute geben, die das einfach anzweifeln und äh das nicht glauben und ich hoffe, ich werde nicht zu denen gehören, sondern ich hoffe, dass ich bald
ja Dinge zu sehen oder präsentiert bekomme, die ich dann auch für glaubwürdig halte
ja, aber bisher äh hinterlässt das Ganze für mich äh einfach nur einen
komischen Geschmack äh und alle Stochern im Dunkeln und äh keiner weiß so richtig irgendwie was los ist, aber.
Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Gut, nach dieser kurzen Einführung kommen wir auf.
Anderes äh Thema, was äh ausführliche Würdigung verdient.
Nämlich äh die Mobilisierung, die hatten wir in der letzten Sendung bereits angesprochen. Da lief sie in den ersten Tagen an.
Und das Bild war noch ein bisschen unklar. Es hat sich schon ein bisschen abgezeichnet, dass das, was
verkündet hat, was sie dort vorhaben, nämlich nur bestimmte Gruppen zu äh mobilisieren und auch erstmal nur dreihunderttausend et cetera, dass das ja.
Dass das dann doch irgendwie alles äh anders kam. Sie haben dann äh versucht zumindest in bestimmten Gebieten so ziemlich jeden zu bekommen, den sie irgendwie kriegen konnten und äh da wurden äh,
selbst da zurückrudern musste und um die öffentlich gesagt hat
ja, da ist ja nicht immer alles richtig gelaufen. Russland-typisch kommt dann immer äh schnell dann so dieses
Ja, da gibt es dann Schuldige in der Bürokratie, die müssen bestraft werden, et cetera, so läuft das ja irgendwie immer, ne? Niemals ist Putin schuld, sondern es sind immer irgendwelche ausführende
die äh alles falsch verstanden haben. Aber man kann jetzt auch glaube ich nach der Woche sagen
Insgesamt läuft diese ganze Mobilisierung nicht so geil und das vor allem aus den Gründen, die ja eigentlich auch alle schon vorher prophezeit haben, nämlich dass
einfach äh dieses Land ähm gar nicht mehr die Infrastruktur hat, die militärische Infrastruktur hat, um eine solche Mobilisierung,
durchzuführen, weil das war etwas, was die Sowjetarmee damals äh hatte mit entsprechenden Ausbildungszentren, mit zurückgehaltenen Kapazitäten, also Leuten, die nur als Ausbilder fungieren, Orte und et cetera dafür.
Ganze ist dann eben ersetzt worden durch eine ja Lean Army, die äh ihre Ausbildung in den Unit selber
macht, die aber jetzt alle im Krieg sind und deswegen läuft es alles äh.
Nicht besonders gut. Es läuft auch logistisch nicht besonders gut. Die Leute werden dann auf irgendwelchen,
Plätzen ausgesetzt. Es gibt keine Ausrüstung, es gibt keine Ernährung teilweise, wenn die einfach in irgendeiner Wiese im Freien äh abgesetzt. Also es gibt alle möglichen Horror-Stories, was da alles äh falsch läuft.
Aber vor allem hat Russland es jetzt die Bevölkerung irgendwie, hat äh Schiss bekommen.
Jüngste Schätzung liegt so bei 600 bis 700tausend Leuten, die also Männern, die theoretisch,
einberufbar wären, die das Land verlassen haben. Also es gab lange Schlangen, hatten wir schon erwähnt, schnell hat sich da ein,
ein Stau gebildet, noch schlimmer war's. Nach Georgien, Kasachstan überall, also an allen Grenzen, wo die Russen das Land verlassen konnten, ohne dass sie ein Visa für das Zielland brauchten, ähm.
Drängelten sich äh die Leute geradezu nur ja und äh.
Die Zahl ist offen, aber 700.000 wäre schon eine Menge.
Ja, also meine, die Zahlen, die ich gehört habe, waren halt mindestens 200.000 auf jeden Fall, was auf jeden Fall schon mal, also das ist auf jeden Fall mehr sind,
als im Februar einmarschiert sind in die Ukraine, die das Land verlassen haben, so das scheint relativ,
sicher zu sein und äh ja würde mich nicht wundern. Also es sind auf jeden Fall mehrere hunderttausend äh so, die das Land verlassen haben. Insofern ja, es äh.
Sind da Leute tatsächlich mobilisiert worden, aber nicht in der Art, äh mhm wie Putin sich das vorgestellt hat, äh wobei.
Wobei dort die Sicht halt dieses äh ich sage mal auch eher mit einem weinenden und einem lachenden Auge äh sehen, dass die Leute gehen. Die sagen sich, na ja gut
äh was soll man mit denen so? Das sind da sind wir dann halt Leute los, mit denen wir sowieso nichts oder die
ja die nicht sowieso nicht zu Russland stehen und potenziell irgendwie.
Ärger machen und dann sollen sie doch gehen, wenn sie nicht bleiben wollen. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen die Attitüde äh.
Also er hatte so ein Treffen mit Lukaschenker, der äh ja der ähm ne also der Präsident von von Belarus der.
Vielleicht schon, ja, aber,
erstmal diese Zahl von Leuten ja ich meine all die richtigen Regime-Gegner, die sind ja schon alle gegangen.
Also das sind ja schon ein paar hunderttausend sind ja schon abgehauen in den letzten Monaten. Das ist jetzt sozusagen ausschließlich die Reaktion
aus äh einer Mittelschicht vor allem, die ähm ja einfach auch mit Krieg gar nix zu tun haben will. Das sind jetzt keine Pazifisten.
Sondern das sind eben diese 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung, die immer so stillschweigend äh das alles ertragen haben.
Und ignoriert haben, habe ich ja nichts mit zu tun, ah ja, lass mal den Putin da seinen Krieg mit seinen Soldaten, die sich da weißt du, Vertragssold.
Die sich dafür ja auch gemeldet haben, sollen die das mal machen, äh mir doch egal äh ich gehe shoppen.
Hilde.
Der Punkt ist natürlich, dass all diese, ich sage mal Reservisten, gerade die jetzt erst, ich sage mal in den letzten zwölf Monaten ihren Wehrdienst beendet haben oder ihren,
ja oder ihren Kontakt beendet haben, ähm die hatten ja alle gute Angebote
äh sich länger zu verpflichten, ja? Das sind alles Leute, die gesagt haben, nee, ich will nicht, ja äh,
ich ich will's auch nicht irgendwie für das das Geld machen und die sind natürlich jetzt alles andere als begeistert.
Ähm wir müssen natürlich aber auch ein bisschen aufpassen, dass wir.
Aus den Bildern, die da kommen, die sind natürlich dann immer sagen die spektakulären Versager, sage ich mal. Das ist äh ist jetzt nicht,
überall äh so und es sind jetzt nicht nur äh lauter alte Betrunkene, mhm die sie da irgendwie rekrutieren, sondern und nicht alle kriegen
auch Schrott ausgehändigt so wie Russenhamm Material durchaus aber hm.
Umgekehrt, kann man glaube ich auch sagen, selbst wenn man wenn man mit maximaler Kritik und Vorsicht an die ganze Sache rangeht und sagt, okay, wir kriegen nur die extremsten Auswüchse hier zu sehen.
Dann sind das aber so viele Auswüchse und so extreme Auswüchse, dass man äh glaube ich sagen kann, ja es gibt da offensichtlich große, große Probleme. So
das.
Überhaupt nur halbwegs organisiert äh zu kriegen. Ich glaube einiges rüttelt sich dann glaube ich auch ein bisschen ein, aber.
Was sich halt nicht einrüttelt ist, dass die Leute einfach.
Sehr viele von denen oder die meisten nach nur ein paar Tagen Training an die Front geschickt werden. So das äh,
rüttelt sich halt so schnell nicht ein. Man und das Problem ist, äh die ganzen Ausbilder sind auch an der Front. Vielleicht haben sie sich gedacht, hm.
Okay, dann schicken wir sie gleich dahin, da sind dann auch die Ausbilder, können sie dann gleich kämpfen, da können sie's gleich dann so learning by doing nach dem nach dem Motto.
Aber ein anderes Problem ist äh dass teilweise ja die Einheiten so stark dezimiert.
Sind oder mehr als dezimiert dezimiert hast ja zehn Prozent, aber viele Einheiten sind ja fünfzig, 60, 70, 80 Prozent
zerstört oder verwundet oder geflohen oder Dienst zuende oder wie auch immer.
So dass das auch auch da ganz ganz schwer wird.
Ich glaube, es ist es sind Mängel,
allen Ebenen, aber am entscheidensten sind wahrscheinlich die, die in die Mängel äh an in Organisationen, Logistik, Ausbildung und Zusammenspiel vor allen Dingen der Truppen, das
scheint mir auch so eine große Schwäche
zu sein, dass die linke Hand nicht weiß, was die Rechte tut äh dort und das ist ja auch nach wie vor kein,
einheitliches Oberkommando gibt, sondern da sind alle möglichen Truppen, die sich auch alle nicht so grün sind. Da sind dann diese Wagner-Leute und da sind die,
PR und LPR-Leute mit den die Russen dann teilweise nichts zu tun haben wollen und dann gibt es irgendwie natürlich auch Rivalitäten zwischen verschiedenen
Einheiten, äh die sich auch von anderen wieder nicht sagen lassen und weil das Oberkommando eben so schwach ist, müsste dann unter sich aushandeln.
Wer jetzt wohin geht äh und so und das alles äh ja das alles wird,
durch diese Mobilmachung ähm eher verschlimmert, ja, dieses dieses Problem.
Es wird verschlimmert, vor allem, weil ja solche Kampfgruppen müssen ja auch in irgendeiner Form zusammenwachsen
Wenn die nicht irgendwie füreinander äh da sind und dann können die halt auch nicht äh kämpfen und es gibt einfach genug
Berichte, äh dass dass einfach der Zustand in den russischen Truppen in der Ukraine halt mehr so ein hätte sich wer kann, ist als äh,
das hier wirklich zusammengearbeitet wird, ja, da werden Verwundete äh in Massen zurückgelassen, so nach dem Motto, dass die Liegen irgendwie, Hauptsache du kommst jetzt hier äh weg und
und äh so eine so ein Bataillons-Gruppe wird halt auch nicht dadurch besser, wenn du einfach unerfahrene Leute mit reinbringst, ne? Zumal die dann halt
auch äh teilweise äh mit ein bisschen Equipment, mit dem die dann angekommen sind was sie dann auch teilweise noch selber haben, bezahlen müssen, ne, weil sie nichts bekommen haben. Es sind irgendwie alles selber mitbringen.
Bis hin zu Tampons, um irgendwie ihre Schusswunden damit zu stopfen. Ähm das wird ihn dann irgendwie
den Soldaten, wo sie dann ankommen, gleich äh äh abgenommen und äh,
solche Geschichten. Also es ist alles krass und diese Ausrüstung ist vor allem halt ein echtes Problem. Einerseits weil's halt nicht genug gibt. Es gab dann diesen Fall, dass irgendwie 1,5 Millionen Uniformen auf einmal nicht auffindbar waren
Ja und dann hat so der Verantwortliche ja im Fernsehen so ja kann ich auch nicht erklären, wo die jetzt sind.
Ja, also es gab da sozusagen Bestand, aber den Bestand gab's
nicht und jetzt wird er auf einmal gebraucht und ist natürlich klar, was da passiert ist. Es ist halt das, was äh das ganze russische äh System und speziell das Militär halt.
Halt einfach Korruption. Da wird das Geld da irgendwie reingegeben, macht mal Uniformen und dann wird irgendwann zurückgemeldet, ja super Uniformen liegen hier alle rum. Ja aber wir wurden halt nie Uniformen produziert, sondern wurde halt einfach die Kohle verteilt.
Ja also auf ja auf jeden Fall äh ja glaube ich gibt's riesige Probleme, aber.
Es gibt nichtsdestotrotz auch äh funktionierende Truppen, die äh und es gibt auch Profis. Also es ist nicht so.
Dass jetzt quasi durchgängig äh äh die Qualität äh der russischen Truppen so miserabel äh äh wäre, aber sie wird jetzt nicht besser, ja.
Durch die Mobilisierung.
Sie wird nicht besser und viele dieser guten Truppen sind halt auch mittlerweile schon zerschlagen. Also das ist ja äh einfach.
Das kann sich, kann man sich dann gerne nochmal anhören äh und so.
These war ja äh dass ohne Qualität äh wird Putin nicht gewinnen können. Das.
Da ja sogar schon schon nachgerechnet und mit reiner Quantität wird wird es nicht reichen
das ist wir leben nicht mehr im Anfang des 2. Jahrhunderts mit Geburtenraten von sechs, sieben, acht und mit Jahrgängen, mit einzelnen äh von vielen
Millionen, sondern ähm ja auch auch in Russland sind
wenn auch Menschenleben vielleicht scheinbar nicht ganz so viel wert zu sein scheinen an an vielen Stellen.
Ist sind sie aber deutlich wertvoller geworden gegenüber. Vor 80 Jahren, ja? Also so so.
Kann man's eigentlich heutzutage auch äh einfach nicht mehr machen, alleine aus demografischen Gründen.
Genau und die Demografie spricht halt eh dagegen, ne? Also diese Zahl, die ich vorhin genannt habe, ist natürlich unbestätigt, ja, sagen wir mal 700.000 Leute haben jetzt das Land verlassen, nur damit sie nicht mobilisiert werden. Das wären allein schon mal 1 Prozent aller Männer.
Und zwar einschließlich aller männlichen Kinder und aller.
Männlichen Kreise. Also das ist schon eine schon eine große Zahl. Und es ist halt.
Klar die Leute, die jetzt sofort dahin geleitet werden, die haben überhaupt gar keine Chance, die verbessern dort überhaupt nix. Die, die vielleicht dann doch irgendwo nochmal ausgebildet werden, sind bestenfalls in ein paar Monaten,
vor Ort und dann ist Winter und es gibt keine Winterkleidung in ausreichenden Mengen
offensichtlich überhaupt gar keine richtige Ausrüstung. Aber was hat jetzt noch ein viel größeres Problem ist, außer dieser militärischen Komponente ist, dass einfach,
Mobilisierung auch in Russland jetzt für einen wirklichen Stimmungsumschwung sorgt.
Die Leute sind jetzt besorgt. Das sieht man jetzt eben schon mal daran, dass eben viele auch einfach flüchten. Ja, ist ja nicht nur die Männer, ist ja teilweise auch.
Äh Familien, weil sie halt einfach auch ja
aufgegeben haben, weil sie auf der einen Seite zu viel Angst vor diesem System haben, weil sie einfach zu viel Repression schon gesehen haben und kennen und äh dann einfach gesagt haben, ich muss jetzt hier einfach weg. Ich weiß zwar nicht, was ich hier für eine,
habe, aber ich verlasse jetzt eher das Land und ich meine, das sagt sich so leicht, ich verlasse mal eben das Land.
Also du gehst halt irgendwo hin wo du ähm ja nobody bist so und,
eben hast du noch ein Leben gehabt und jetzt hast du einfach gar nichts und du verlässt dich dann sozusagen von heute auf morgen äh auf dein Glück.
Dass du in irgendeiner Form irgendwo unterkommst. Sicherlich ein paar Leute werden das schon haben und das führt natürlich auch bei den Zurückgebliebenen jetzt für
äh ein Stimmungswandel, weil die natürlich alle ihre Freunde ziehen sehen, selber sich natürlich Sorgen machen um sich selber oder um ihre Familie und ähm was natürlich auch noch so ein Effekt ist.
700.tausend Leute, ich bleibe jetzt einfach mal bei dieser Zahl. Lass es 5hunderttausend sein. Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr, sehr viele. Ja, also ich glaube allein Kasachstan hat
über 150.000 und in Georgien sind äh äh sicherlich noch mehr gelandet und es geht hält ja auch noch an, dass ja kein abgeschlossener Prozess. Ähm
Das ist sozusagen auch genau die Demografie.
Erstmal Russland mangels äh entsprechender Geburtenraten in den letzten Jahrzehnten sowieso sehr schlecht, wo sie ohnehin sehr schlecht darstellen, wie du schon sagtest
wurden viele geboren. Äh insbesondere in den Neunzigern gab's da halt einen richtigen Knick
Leute, die jetzt aus Firmen rausgehen auf einmal fehlt da ein Prozent der Workforce. So was ähm,
bemerkbar und sorgt natürlich jetzt für Widerstände, also ist rumort. Man merkt das auch in den Medien. Es gibt Widerspruch. Es ist zwar alles nicht irgendwie Putin ist schuld, sondern es ist irgendwie hier irgendjemand muss Schuld sein, also es war ein permanentes Finger pointing, was da jetzt begonnen hat und das ist an sich schon mal
extremer äh ja eine extreme Änderung und es gibt auch erste wo halt einfach klar wird, dass die Leute eben jetzt nicht mehr so bedingungslos sagen, ja führt mal weiter, Krieg ist mir doch egal
die sagen, ja nee, ich bin äh besorgt und wir müssen das nicht unbedingt fortmachen, weil sie eigentlich nie damit was zu tun haben wollten und durch diese Mobilisierung, durch dieses Kriegsszenario, wird ihnen jetzt einfach klar
dass sie davon so oder so betroffen sein werden.
Ja und das, ich sage mal was auch selbst wenn man jetzt, ich sage mal, der der größte Russland-Fan ist und sagt, ach so schlimm.
Ist, dass alles äh gar nicht alles äh völlig übertrieben. Allein nur die Tatsache, dass Putin sich genötigt sah.
Sich im Fernsehen dann nochmal hinzustellen und öffentlich zu
na ja sich nicht wirklich zu entschuldigen, aber so ein bisschen quasi zu sagen, ja äh oder einzugestehen, dass es nicht nicht rund läuft und dass Fehler gemacht worden sind und sagt dann zwar diese Fehler äh äh müssen korrigiert,
werden und werden korrigiert werden und hat dann ja klargestellt, ja, dass eben auch Leute eingezogen worden sind, die.
Ja zu alt sind oder krank sind oder äh viele Kinder haben.
Tot sind.
Ja
Nee, aber diese äh diese drei Gruppen hat er dann dann spezifisch erwähnt, so was aber auch nicht zur Beruhigung der Massen beigetragen hat, weil anfangs war nur die Rede, also,
Nur Leute mir die mit militärischer Ausbildung äh äh werden gezogen, also nur Reservisten. Aber
war dann halt überhaupt nicht nicht mehr die Rede auch in dieser Klarstellung nicht.
So sodass viele Leute haben haben halt sehr genau hingehört und nach der zweiten Rede hat dann glaube ich nochmal nach der Klarstellung hat dann der Flüchtlingsstrom nochmal weiter zugenommen, weil äh äh die Leute dann schon ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen lesen und auch genau
sehr laut hören, was er nicht gesagt hat, ja.
Und insofern äh kann man noch so, kann man noch so sehr äh also so sehr man das vielleicht schönreden möchte oder oder will, gibt ja nur so Leute, die
irgendwie der Meinung sind, ist alles ganz anders und Russland äh ist ja irgendwie wird,
ungerecht behandelt und ist ja alles nur Propaganda. Das äh in dem Fall, glaube ich, kann man
kann man sagen äh nee äh die Schlangen an den Grenzen sind sind real und das Putin sich hingestellt hat ist real und das glaube ich auch der da der.
Der Chef von Dargestan war das, glaube ich, den kompletten Ausraster hatte, weil
in einer Stadt dort, die Rekrutierer einfach rumgefahren sind mit einem Lautsprecherwagen und gesagt haben, alle Männer haben sich jetzt gefälligst beim Rekrutierungszentrum zu melden, ja.
Alle Männer so mit Lautsprecherwagen durch die Straßen so und da hat er wirklich
komplett den Anfall gekriegt, weil die Reaktion darauf hin war, dass die Hälfte der Männer.
Die Stadt verlassen haben nach dieser Lautsprecherdurchsage.
Die waren dann erstmal weg oder haben sich versteckt so, weil äh und und da der halt,
ist ein ist auch ähm auf YouTube äh äh findet sich das auch. Es ist wirklich ein schöner Ausraster, der hätte irgendwie fast.
Weil ich den Tisch kurz und klein geschlagen und meinte, wie kann man nur so blöd sein irgendwie und äh ja also.
Nee, nee, das das läuft nicht rund. Ähm und.
Am Ende auf auf jeden Fall ja ob's jetzt ob man soweit gehen kann und sagen würde, dass das diese Mobilmachung jetzt die,
schwächt, so weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen, sondern sie werden halt jetzt äh eines ihrer dringendsten Probleme.
Zumindest ein Stück weit gelöst kriegen, nämlich dass sie einfach schlichtweg zu wenig Personal haben, aber äh,
es kommt zu spät. Die Mobiemachung kommt einfach zu spät. Das hätten Sie vor der Invasion machen müssen. Dann hätte's vielleicht.
Geklappt und die Leute irgendwie trainieren müssen, aber äh ja ich gebe dem, wie gesagt, vor allem deswegen wenig Hoffnung, weil.
Putin offenbar unter Druck steht, unter Zeitdruck steht und äh das Vernünftige wäre jetzt gewesen, mhm.
Die Leute vernünftig auszubilden, Einheiten aufzustellen, die zu trainieren und sich ein halbes, dreiviertel Jahr oder so Zeit zu lassen, um wirklich dann ähm,
mit guten Truppen, die ein bisschen geübt haben schon mal ohne dabei gleich
äh das gleich wieder zehn, 20 Prozent dabei draufgehen. Ja, das ist halt auch nicht gut. Wenn du sozusagen learning by by doing äh dann
nennenswert deine die Leute, die da mit dir eingezogen äh wurden ähm
dann niedergemetzelt werden, dass es nicht gut oder wenn wenn du gleich die Leute von Anfang an dann erstmal mit solchen äh katastrophalen Bedingungen schon mal so abschreckst, dann noch mal die Kurve zu kriegen
ja wird schwierig aber die Erwartung ist.
Dass jetzt Putin das erstmal nicht sofort um Kopf und Kragen bringen wird.
Sondern dass er weiter die Kontrolle behalten wird und ähm.
Das aber erwartet wird, dass irgendwann in den nächsten Monaten ähm das Ganze auch Resultate zeigt,
so Putin hat wohl aus,
meiner Sicht eben von Russland Experten, sage ich mal, denen ich glaube, also auch Großen, hat da noch ein paar Monate Zeit, aber eben das hatten wir dann.
Beim letzten Mal ja schon, aber irgendwann im Frühjahr wahrscheinlich ähm oder wenn.
Das jetzt mit der Offensive so weitergeht äh wie wir.
Wie es im Moment läuft und äh die Truppen sehr schnell äh geschlagen äh äh werden, so dass weitere katastrophale Niederlagen gibt, könnte es schneller gehen, aber
ja irgendwann wird der Punkt kommen wo Putin von der Bevölkerung die Rechnung präsentiert kriegt und gesagt okay jetzt hast du hier mobilisiert
und ähm es hat jetzt trotzdem nichts gebracht äh so jetzt ist Schluss.
Ja, die Botschaft könnte auch schon relativ bald äh kommen, aber glaube ich, das.
Größte Fehler, der mit dieser Mobilisierung einhergeht und den er vielleicht hätte abmindern können, wenn er von vornherein eine sehr viel sanftere,
Mobilisierung gemacht hätte, sagen wir mal gleich nach der Niederlage in Kiew. Dann ähm,
wäre es nicht so aufgefallen, ja, so dass man ne, stattdessen haben sie ja versucht so aktiv Leute äh ranzuwerben, mit Geld zu holen. Das hat alles schon nicht funktioniert.
Und ähm jetzt müssen wir mal äh gucken, wie das äh an der Stelle weitergeht. Wer äh.
Ja äh nicht mobilisiert wird, ist übrigens etwas Snowden, der hat ja Knochen jetzt auch noch die russische Staatsbürgerschaft angenommen,
hieß wohl, er sollte äh nicht eingezogen werden äh und nochmal Glück gehabt so. Es gab jetzt auch noch mal einen Gerücht, dass ähm.
Gegebenenfalls äh vielleicht auch noch irgendwie über Belarus äh Loche mobilisiert werden, ja oder das Belarus selber noch mit in den Krieg einsteigt.
Das halte ich eher für unwahrscheinlich. Ich glaube nicht, dass zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt überhaupt irgendjemand noch in diesen Krieg einsteigen möchte, weil das ist einfach mal ein brennendes Schiff und da möchte keiner mehr äh richtig äh drauf und ich glaube auch Angriffe aus,
Belarus. Ich glaube, die haben alle jetzt äh ordentlich Respekt, aber werden wir nochmal drauf äh eingehen, wenn wir gleich zum militärischen Teil kommen.
Jetzt äh ist ja diese Mobilisierung nicht das einzige geblieben, sondern Putin hat äh alle Register gezogen und das getan, was ich ja ohnehin schon
angedeutet hat. Er hat ja diese sogenannten Referenten durchführen lassen oder zumindest irgendwas veranstaltet, von dem man dann behauptet hat, dass während welche gewesen. Gut, das Ergebnis ist äh natürlich,
veranstaltet.
Ähm wo dann irgendwie die ganzen Auguren äh in so einem Saal rumsaßen, wo sie dann groß die Annektion dieser vier Oblasse, also
Donetskund und Luhansk verkündet haben und das wäre ja jetzt alles irgendwie Russland, es wäre für immer Russland.
Ja genau, so.
Diese Veranstaltung als solche sollten wir vielleicht erstmal besprechen. Die bestand ja aus zwei Teilen. Da gab's ja immer diese offizielle Zeremonie und allein schon so, da war dann was weiß ich, zwei-, dreihundert,
Großkopferte, die da irgendwie rumsaßen und sich das Ganze äh anschauten und in diesen Gesichtern war.
Die totale Leere. Also das war ja so eine große Zelebration und jetzt Russland und jetzt sind wir irgendwie ein großes Land und überhaupt und irgendwie äh neue Ge,
treten uns bei und man würde ja nur denken, dass könnte dann dem einen oder anderen doch mal ein Lächeln ins Gesicht ziehen. Es war einfach nur Leere in diesen Gesichtern.
Ja und das und äh ich weiß nicht, ob es Zufall war oder Absicht, aber äh der Tag war halt zufällig auch derselbe, an dem Hitler, das Sudetenland annektiert hat.
Ja? Mhm.
Ja.
An Parallelen ist das Ganze äh nicht arm, aber ich fand's halt einfach bezeichnend, dass du eigentlich diesen Leuten schon angesehen hast, wie sie sich in die Hose schissen
und ähm dass da irgendwie so richtig keine Stimmung aufkommen wollte,
auch nicht sehr viel anders vor dem Kreml, wo sie dann irgendwie auch noch so eine große Popanz-Show gemacht haben, wie es vor ein paar Monaten äh schon mal gab als äh Putin da in unserem Stadion aufgetreten ist, wo sie dann alle ihren Z-Wahnsinn äh gefeiert haben und jetzt auch
so wie bei der Veranstaltung damals als auch bei dieser bestanden diese ganzen
Jubelperser, die da rumstanden, alle aus irgendwelchen Staatsbediensteten, die halt mit Bussen rangekarrt wurden.
Mit Hunderten von Bussen.
Ne, so macht man das und also wenn's so gelaufen ist wie beim letzten Mal, wovon ich mal schwer ausgehe, da gab's ja so schöne äh Interviews noch mit den Leuten, als sie dann irgendwie da draußen rumstanden danach
äh wegfahren sollten, mit ihren Bussen, da sind so Teams rumgelaufen, da haben wir gefragt, ja warum habt ihr hier dran teilgenommen? Manche wollten gar nicht antworten.
Man hat's richtig gemerkt, wie sie sich geschämt haben und äh,
haben dann einfach erklärt, ja, sie hätten äh heute Morgen noch gar nicht gewusst, worum's geht. Die werden einfach in irgendwelche Busse geladen worden und dahin gefahren worden. Hätten dann Allianz,
Ort gemerkt an, was sie da dran teilnehmen. Ich schätze mal, das dürfte auch hier ähnlich äh gelaufen sein. Vielleicht haben sie die genommen, die nochmal sich
besonders ähm jubeln verhalten können, aber na ja, am Ende äh war da irgend so ein Schauspieler, der dann irgendwie da groß eine versucht hat, daraus eine Party zu machen und hat irgendwie eine völlig absurde Rede gehalten, wo er den heiligen Krieg ausgerufen hat und versucht hat, hier noch irgendwie
so 'n Schlachtruf zu etablieren der sich meines Wissens bisher nicht sonderlich durchgesetzt hat. Dieses.
Mhm. Nee.
Unsere Zarengeschichte und äh die waren ja schreckliche und äh so weiter, also die nehmen die ganze Zeit auf irgend so eine,
Vergangenheit Russlands äh Bezug, die von großen Taten und großen Erfolgen könnten sollte und von großen Empire und Ruhm und Ehre und was nicht alles.
Aber na ja, am Ende.
Ist das Ganze äh mit dieser Annexion wunderbar äh absurd, weil es gab ja dann Leute, die nachgefragt haben, ja okay gut, also das war jetzt die Annektion. Könnt ihr uns mal sagen, wo genau jetzt die Grenze verläuft,
von eurem neuen Land.
Ja, ja, also das.
Das konnten sie dann nicht.
Ich meine, äh aber äh ja dazu aber ein Einkommen nah äh noch
muss sagen zu dieser Zeremonie da hat jemand denn auch sie einen Hitlervergleich äh angestellt.
Und nach dem Motto man auch Bilder von damals gezeigt und Kommentar war nur also Hitler konnte das besser ja so.
Ja ein Kommentator der der auch diese äh sagen die Begeisterung oder den Mangel an Begeisterung ähm
und hat dann sozusagen quasi auch diese diese Versuch bestimmte
äh äh Rufe zu etablieren oder äh oder so oder die Leute dann quasi zum ja zum hurra hurra hurra und so also da da
meinte er nur also ja.
Nee, also Begeisterung äh wollte da nun wirklich überhaupt nicht äh aufkommen und das, obwohl man sagen kann, das ist jetzt das ist bestimmt.
Sagen wir 20Prozent Putin, wirklich Putin-Fans,
in Russland. Nur offensichtlich waren das nicht die Leute, die er da angekarrt äh hat äh so. Das waren nicht nicht die wahren Fans äh so, äh die da waren. Ja und jetzt bei der ja,
bei der bei der Geschichte mit hin Grenzen
so da war mein erster Kommentar irgendwie, was darf real Satire so ja du annektierst irgendwie etwas
Gefahr, ja was habt ihr denn jetzt annektiert? Ja, hm also ähm.
Müssen wir nochmal Rücksprache halten.
Nee, die Antwort war dann irgendwann na ja da wo äh wo wir das Land besetzt halten, da
annektieren wir, so.
Ähm das heißt, es ist eine dynamische Annektion, dachte ich mir dann, weil sie annektieren halt nur das, wo sie's
auch grade besetzt halten, das heißt
Äh es ist halt wahrscheinlich dynamisch. So je nachdem dann wie der Frontverlauf ist äh ist dann weniger oder mehr offiziell annektiert.
Irgendwie so. Es ist natürlich ein Riesenproblem äh so wenn und.
Ist das natürlich praktisch, weil sie können jetzt sozusagen die Länder einfach rückannektieren so, ne.
Mhm ja beziehungsweise äh äh ist äh sozusagen nimmt Russland ja dann quasi seine Grenzen zurück äh nach Bedarf, ja?
Das ist so jetzt so überhaupt noch mal besonders irre, weil äh mittlerweile hat ja auch dann dieses Verfassungsgericht das irgendwie bestätigt so, was ja auch sehr interessant ist, also es hat
glaube ich, diese Frage ausgelöst, weil wenn sie schon das Verfassungsgericht dann irgendwie sagt, so ja hm oder weiß nicht, ob das Verfassungsgericht, ich krieg's gleich durcheinander vielleicht irgendeine verfassungsgebende
Entität auf jeden Fall, die das noch absegnen muss, hat das dann äh getan. Na ja, aber offensichtlich ohne klare Informationen darüber zu haben
welcher Bereich denn jetzt eigentlich genau äh gemeint ist. Und das ist jetzt,
nochmal besonders lustig, weil die für russische Verfassung wiederum sieht gar nicht vor, dass russisches Gebiet zurückgegeben wird. Also es gibt keinen Prozess.
Man kann zwar was annektieren, aber das irgendwas wieder äh hergegeben wird, dafür gibt's sozusagen überhaupt gar keinen
Vorgang. Wenn also Putin jetzt irgendwann mal gestürzt wird und irgendein Nachfolger äh sich dann vielleicht benötigt, sieht hier äh die Sachen wieder zurückzudrehen.
Ist das irgendwie rechtlich auch erstmal alles gar nicht möglich. Na gut, das Problem werden Sie sicherlich dann noch in irgendeiner Form gelöst bekommen?
Aber die Rede von von Putin ist halt einfach so dermaßen äh die rangewesen.
Ja mit Andeutung über ja und der ganze Westen ist jetzt irgendwie gegen uns und das ist auch das Interessante, ne? Es ist jetzt gar nicht mehr von der Zerschlag,
der Ukraine äh die Rede und irgendwie es werden auch auf einmal gar nicht mehr Nazis verfolgt, sondern ähm jetzt ist der ganze Westen die NATO äh ist jetzt gegen Russland, also
zieht jetzt auch schon wirklich die ganz große Keule raus. Und das wirkt natürlich echt verzweifelt.
Na ja, also der ganze Westen ist böse und äh er droht mit Atomwaffen. Da reden wir nachher auch noch mal drüber. Interessant ist das allerdings, dieser ganze Vorgang, dieser Annexion.
Den ganzen New Cycle im Rest der Welt nicht nennenswert beeinflusst hat. Also alle haben da ja sowieso schon mit gerechnet und äh keiner war irgendwie bereit, da überhaupt groß drauf einzugehen auch nur so, ja.
Mhm, ja.
Reagieren wir gar nicht drauf. So, wir haben hier was äh zu tun. Stattdessen hat er äh.
Eine Natomitgliedschaft beantragt sozusagen,
Fastpath äh Regelung, die ist, glaube ich, so gar nicht äh gibt, aber die er dann einfach mal rausgehauen hat. Das war dann sozusagen seine Antwort, einfach eine interessante Methode hier auch wiederum, die es
Thema zu wechseln und natürlich auch eine gute Gelegenheit, weil natürlich durch diese Annexion auch alle.
Argumentationen, die sowieso immer schon auf dünnen Eis waren, mit fast jetzt irgendwie hier mit Friedensgesprächen und so weiter laufen sollte, sowieso hinfällig sind. Ne und die USA haben auch einfach nur ein neues Hilfspaket vorgestellt.
Und mittlerweile sogar noch ein zweites äh Binnen einer Woche. Also das äh läuft nicht gut.
Und ähm ja
das Ganze erscheint in der Tat als äh überhastete Verzweiflungstat, sage ich mal, auch um wiederum bestimmte rechtliche Probleme umgehen zu können, nämlich einfach jetzt
ähm die Leute,
auch äh sagen nicht ins Ausland zu kämpfen zu schicken mehr, was ja mit äh Wehrpflichtigen oder normale Wehrpflichtige nicht,
dürfen äh so also äh quasi auch so eine für ihn interne technische Geschichte.
Aber ich glaube politisch hat er sich damit äh wirklich
äh auch noch mal in äh beide Füße und Knie geschossen, weil ähm.
Jetzt natürlich jeder äh auch denkt, okay ähm was ist jetzt denn der Unterschied zwischen Krim und den
anderen Gegenden so ähm weil
Vorher konnte man noch sagen, vorher war ja so ein bisschen im Westen auch äh ja Krim und so, die gehört ja zu Russland und wenn quasi da jetzt ja russischer Boden oder so
aber das macht ja jetzt eh keinen Unterschied mehr. Das heißt, ich glaube, dass dadurch durch diese Annexion.
Auch äh eher politisch äh einfach, ich sage mal, die unantastbarkeit der Krim ganz klar in Frage gestellt hat,
äh ja äh und jetzt jetzt ist auch äh ich sage mal die
die Krim quasi eher auf das Level runtergezogen worden äh in der in der Wahrnehmung des des Auslands.
Äh auf die anderen besetzten Gebiete und nicht die anderen besetzten Gebiete quasi gedanklich auf das Level der Krim hochgezogen, was er eigentlich tun wollte.
Das ist äh auch ein interessanter Aspekt. Ja, also man merkt ohnehin, also Putin hat einfach,
Deutungshoheit komplett eingebüßt und das eben nicht nur im Ausland, wo er sie eh nie hatte, sondern eben auch im Inland. Also es ist halt einfach
Keiner nimmt ihm den Scheiß nochmal äh ab und irgendwie das Eskalationspotential, das nicht militärische Eskalationspotential ist jetzt auch irgendwie ausgereizt. Also schlimmer kann's jetzt irgendwie gar nicht mehr kommen und niemand ist mehr nennenswert,
überrascht über das, was er macht, außer vielleicht Pipelines äh in die Luft jagen, was ja auch irgendwie eine total weirde Geschichte ist.
Vielleicht noch ein, zwei Worte zu dieser äh Nato-Mitgliedschaft. Das ist natürlich unwahrscheinlich, dass jetzt äh die Ukrainer jetzt irgendwie morgen in die NATO aufgenommen wird. Wobei man sagen muss, bei der öffentlichen Stimmung hat es sicherlich geholfen, diese Annektion.
Zu sagen so äh es ist es ist klar dass die Ukraine langfristig irgendwann in der NATO landen.
Muss, ne, weil ohne Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine wird es eh nicht laufen und äh de facto.
Wird das, was dabei herauskommt, auch nicht groß anders wirken als eine
NATO-Mitgliedschaft. Abgesehen davon, dass, glaube ich, äh die meisten in der NATO, auch wenn sie das jetzt so offen nicht zugeben würden, die Ukraine definitiv auch in der NATO haben möchten.
Einfach weil das ist so das ist so eine Armee.
Die möchte man jetzt nicht, dass die jetzt irgendwie so eine so so eine Israel-Insel da auf einmal mitten in Europa bildet.
Sagt so was, ihr wollt uns nicht helfen? Die Russen äh müssen eingedämmt werden. Ja sorry, dann müssen wir halt auch Atom äh Raketen.
Heranzüchten. Wir hatten das auch schon mal. Wir konnten das auch. Wir haben auch mal versprochen, dass wir die abschaffen, weil die Russen gesagt haben, dass sie uns nicht angreifen. Das machen sie aber trotzdem. NATO will uns nicht helfen. Na dann sorry, dann müssen wir uns halt selber helfen.
Allein, um das zu verhindern, wird so eine Nato-Mitgliedschaft überhaupt nicht äh zu vermeiden sein.
Kanada, Tschechien, die baltischen Staaten natürlich sowieso, ein paar andere auch noch, die sind auch schon äh dabei und sagen, ja klar, machen wir so, aber ich denke mal äh gut Deutschland wird am Ende das machen, was die USA sagen, die USA sagen, warten wir mal ab
und äh Türkei und Ungarn sollen erstmal hier äh Schweden und Finnland aufnehmen. Das äh.
Ist auf jeden Fall auch hier.
Geschickt von Selenski politisch gespielt, ne. Ja und in der Zwischenzeit schickt also USA einfach noch mehr Waffen und ich glaube, das zweite Waffenpaket, was jetzt auch noch hinterher geschoben wurde, dass ähm.
Ist noch mal more of the same, aber es wird jetzt wohl hinter den Türen auch schon kräftig darüber verhandelt, wie denn diese Long-Range-Munition und diese Attacke MS äh äh Waffen dann doch vielleicht in die Hände der Ukraine geraten können. Äh
bietet die Ukraine äh den USA sozusagen ein ein Veto pro Einsatz äh an, so nach dem Motto,
sagen ihnen, ja wir wollen das hier irgendwie angreifen und so, ob das die USA machen werden, weiß ich nicht, weil sie damit ja im Prinzip aktiver
der der dem Militärhandlungen werden, aber die die Debatte nimmt
einfach an Geschwindigkeiten, Entschärfe zu und Putin tut halt alles dafür, um Vorlagen zu liefern, dass man sagt,
also jetzt ist schon wieder Eskalationspotenzial ausgeschöpft worden, dann können wir halt auch ein bisschen nacheskalieren, ohne dass jetzt hier äh uns jemand groß einen.
Vorwurf machen könnte. Gut, schließen wir mal äh diesen Teil äh mit der Annexion auch äh.
Und kommen wir mal auf die konkrete, militärische Lage, denn,
da geht's rund. Am Tag der Annexion von äh Luhansk,
wurde äh Entschuldigung nee von äh Dunetsk
Also von allen Oblasten natürlich so, ne, wurde dann auch gleich einen Tag später so eine ist also gleich eine Stadt wieder ausgetreten und zwar Lyman.
Was ist passiert? Also wir hatten ja jetzt in den letzten Wochen die Rakive Offensive, wo
die äh Ukraine ja extreme Landgewinne gemacht hat, indem sie einfach
geschwächte Stellung der äh Russen ausgemacht und ausgenutzt hat und dabei irgendwie dann mal eben zehntausend Quadrat
Kilometer Land wieder zurückgewonnen hat. Diese Offensive ist dann weitergegangen. Also das war ja das, womit dann damit geendet wurde, dass einerseits die Stadt Isum eingenommen wurde, wichtiges Truppenzentrum und sich danach im Prinzip erstmal eine neue Frontlinie an diesem Osthilfluss.
Bildet hat, der da so Nord, Süden in diesem Gebiet.
Durchgeht und damit war auch fast die gesamte der gesamte Oblast raktiv äh befreit, fehlten noch ein paar Meter.
Dann passierte erstmal eine Woche nix. Beziehungsweise da wird nicht nichts passiert sein, sondern vor allem mussten natürlich diese Gebiete erstmal äh gesichert werden und auch viel dafür getan werden, dass die Leute dort versorgt werden et cetera und man muss ja auch die ganzen Panzer erstmal,
schleppen, die da rumstehen, damit die irgendwie wieder repariert und wieder benutzt werden können
aber natürlich äh hat die Ukraine nicht aufgehört, hier militärisch weiterzudenken und äh hatte äh zumindest einzelne Truppen und natürlich auch ihre Artillerie und Hamas äh Raketen am Start.
Um dieses Shaping auch weiter voranzutreiben und das ist dann eben vor einer Woche äh richtig losgegangen. Es
dann einen weiteren Vorstoß nach Osten im südlichen Teil von äh und äh.
Es ist dann relativ schnell gelungen, den Vorschlag es so so zu machen, dass eben diese Stadt Lüman komplett,
eingeschlossen wurde oder fast komplett eingeschlossen wurde und das ist überhaupt grade so ein bisschen die,
Strategie wie die Ukraine vorgibt. Man setzt nicht unbedingt dadrauf jetzt voll frontal auf irgendwelche Städte zu prallen, wo die großen Truppenkonzentrationen sind, sondern man konzentriert sich eigentlich eher auf diese Bereiche drumherum
die einfach schlecht abgedeckt sind, weil den Russen einfach die Infanterie
die nicht mehr diese ganzen Stellungen besetzen können beziehungsweise die einfach von demoralisierten und ausgehungerten, ausgemergelten und viel zu lange im Krieg befindlichen Menschen.
Geführt wird, so dass dann eben die Special Forces hier,
äh den ganzen technischen Vorteil, den die Ukraine mittlerweile hat, Nachtsichtgeräte äh et cetera halt die besser Artillerie, die bessere Aufklärung, die ganze Drohnentechnik, also das ist ja einfach ähm alles enorm modernisiert worden und vor allem ist die Kampftechnik
enorm äh angestiegen und.
Gibt da keine Zahlen, aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass die Ukraine auch sehr viele neue Truppen mobilisiert hat und das tun sie ja halt auch schon seit Anfang des Krieges. Und die kommen jetzt eben zum Einsatz, das heißt sie haben ausgeruhte, durchrotierte.
Kräfte, die gut ausgebildet sind, die gut ausgerüstet sind und die jetzt eben auch mit der ganzen Aufklärung der Amerikaner und den Möglichkeiten, die die Ukraine sich selber geschaffen hat,
hier äh klug vorangehen und die Russen sind einfach,
komplett überfordert damit. Das heißt, sie stoßen jetzt in diese unbesiedelten oder schlecht geschützten Gebiete ein und umzingeln einfach diese ganzen anderen äh Städte.
Und Zentren, sodass dann den Russen nichts übrig anderes übrig bleibt als zu flüchten. Und genau das ist halt hier in Lüman passiert.
Das ist also die zweite große Niederlage jetzt nach äh Isum und ähm,
Bedeutung von Lyman ist auch nicht zu unterschätzen, weil das ist halt ein ganz wichtiges Eisenbahnkreuz in dieser Donezregion
und äh das äh bedeutet natürlich für die Russen ein weiterer großer Verlust äh von Eisenbahninfrastruktur, die einfach für ihre Verstärkungstechnik sehr wichtig ist und da sie kaum noch über Transporter verfügen und
mittlerweile irgendwie mit Reisebussen irgendwie äh ihre Truppen durch die Gegend fahren, also komplett ungeschützt. Ähm sieht man
einfach das ganze Gerüst der russischen Verteidigung auseinanderbricht.
S we speak stoßen die Truppen auch äh noch weiter nach Osten.
Da wird's äh demnächst wahrscheinlich die Verkündigung geben, dass der gesamte Oblast
Rakie von Russen befreit ist. Da fehlt jetzt nicht mehr viel. Es sind nur noch wenige Kilometer nach Norden, die noch mit eingenommen werden müssen. Das wird mit Sicherheit ähm nächste Woche
abgeschlossen sein, wenn ich's schon sehr viel früher.
Und es sieht jetzt so aus, als ob die nächsten Städte äh in Angriff genommen werden. Also Kriminal, das sind so die Worte, die man hier demnächst häufiger hören wird und es droht dann sogar auch eine Umzingelung.
Der schwer umkämpften Gebiete, wo wir monatelang drüber geredet haben
Also Sivero äh Dunets und äh das war ja da dieser
Nutzungskrieg über den ganzen Sommer hinweg und es sieht einfach in zunehmende Maße so aus, als ob die Russen da große Probleme haben werden, diese Gebiete zu halten.
Und dann könnte diese ganze Dunets-Frontlinie total zusammenbrechen. Wenn man nicht sowieso schon festhalten kann, dass eigentlich die ganze Frontlinie der Russen dabei ist, äh um zu,
Kippen wie so Dominosteine.
Ich meine gut, sie werden natürlich irgendwie oder sie müssen halt jetzt reagieren so, dass dass,
Problem, das größte Problem scheint
zu sein, was ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe, die Führung, einfach die russische Führung ist einfach
Mist. Die äh ja ähm und deswegen ist es ihnen dann auch nicht
gelungen oder ja einfach die Front da wirklich zu schließen, lückenlos zu schließen oder äh solche Verteidigungsstellungen auf zu bauen.
Ähm ja äh das äh die die Ukrainer ähm.
Zum Stillstand gebracht, haben gesagt, die Ukrainer haben halt dann immer irgendwo dann, wie du schon sagtest, halt Stellen gefunden, die dann einfach nicht hinreichend verteidigt
waren oder äh was wohl auch teilweise äh ja der Fall war in verschiedenen Gegenden, dass die dann irgendwie äh gigantische Verteidigungsstellungen gefunden haben ähm
die aber auch verlassen worden sind, die halt nie genutzt worden sind, ja.
Ähm und äh das ist ein bisschen das das zweite Problem. Entweder haben sie keine Stellung oder wenn sie Stellung haben, haben sie keinen Bock. Ähm
die zu besetzen äh oder äh sie sind halt überflüssig, weil die Ukrainer leider schon von einer auf einem ganz anderen Weg den niemand antizipiert hat
ähm ähm ja genommen haben und äh es ist eben.
Ja im Moment ihnen alles wegrutscht.
Das ist dieser Einschlusstaktik ne also die gehen dann halt die Stellung von Flanken an, die dann einfach so dicht zu verteidigen sind. Es gibt aber noch einen anderen Grund, warum die äh Stellung so schnell aufgegeben werden
Offensichtlich ist es den ähm den Ukrainern mittlerweile gelungen wirklich äh sehr gute Jamming Methoden zu entwickeln, um die gesamte Funkkommunikation zusammenbrechen zu lassen. Also das ist jetzt
gerade in äh berichtet worden und ich vermute mal, dass es jetzt auch nichts, was jetzt erst diese Woche stattfindet. Das heißt, diese Stellungen sind dann teilweise komplett ohne Kommunikation. Die sehen dann die Panzer auf sie zurollen, Panzer haben sie irgendwie keine mehr,
Die sitzen da irgendwo im Schützengraben mit ihr ein paar Gewehren und vielleicht noch ein paar MGs und aus dem einen oder anderen Panzerabwehrrakete, wenn überhaupt so.
Kriegen aber dann keinerlei Artillerieunterstützung mehr. Das heißt, sie seien ja hier, wir werden angegriffen. Haut mal hier mit der Artillerie drauf, aber wir sind nicht in der Lage, das noch zu kommunizieren. Und dann merken sie einfach, okay, uns hilft hier eh keiner, schnell weg
und das ist das ist sozusagen das, was es noch weiterhin antreibt. Also es ist ja auch gar nicht mal nur ein Faktor, sondern es ist mittlerweile eine
eine Vielzahl von Faktoren, die dazu beiträgt, dass ihnen die äh dass ihnen die Munition ausgeht, dass sie irgendwie die Ausrüstung nicht haben, dass.
Nicht haben, dass sie komplett demoralisiert sind, verwundet sind, keinen Support haben et cetera.
Das kann wirklich gut sein. Äh wie gesagt, der Kampf ums Elektromagnetische Spektrum. Ähm der lief,
am Anfang oder in der Zwischenzeit nicht so gut für die Ukraine, so.
Am äh Anfang erstmal gut waren die Russen hatten selber riesige Probleme, weil nicht genug geplant
war, aber haben's dann irgendwann schon ganz gut auf die Reihe gekriegt und die russische Technologie ist da auch nicht schlecht, ja. Sie haben dann schon gute Jamin Experten, die haben auch dann viele Ukrainer
äh ukrainische Drohnen und so übernommen und andere äh Dinge und es gab dann halt schon also die Ukrainer hatten selbst auch riesige Probleme
äh irgendwann äh zu kommunizieren zwischendurch. Das wird.
Nie so richtig publik äh äh gemacht, aber das war ein Riesenproblem und es kann jetzt äh sehr gut sein.
Offenbar, dass die Ukrainer da jetzt besser äh geworden äh sind und das andere Problem halt äh mit.
Kampf ums Elektromagnetische Spektrum äh der will halt auch koordiniert sein, weil du willst ja selber zwar.
Den Gegner stören, aber nicht deine eigenen
Truppen stören so, das heißt du musst halt vorher dir überlegen äh auf welchen Frequenzen und wie du wann wohin wechselst und unterwegs bist und so, das ist halt auch ein das ist ein
Irre Schachspiel äh so dieser Kampf ums Elektromagnetische Spektrum.
Und da kann's gut sein, dass ohne dass da viel drüber geredet wurde jetzt die äh Ukraine ähm da.
Aufgerüstet äh wurde und jetzt auch einfach besser geworden
ist äh selber den Gegner zu stören und umgekehrt äh in der Lage zu sein, trotzdem noch zu kommunizieren. Ähm.
Und äh umgekehrt äh Russland eben ist da jetzt Sonnenchaos ausgebrochen, dass die wiederum jetzt nicht in der Lage sind, in dieser dynamischen Situation äh dann ihre
Planung ähm so ihre Frequenzplanung und ihre Codes und und so äh ähm das Ganze so abzustimmen,
ja dass sie dass sie schlichtweg auch offenbar den Kampf ums Elektromagnetische Spektrum grade verlieren.
Oder verloren haben.
Also es ist als müsse ein Aspekt, was man nicht vergessen darf, ist, sie haben auch vor allem den äh Kampf um die logistischen Linien äh verloren, weil das ist halt das, was die Ukraine auch sehr erfolgreich machen. Also sie,
bereiten alle äh Vorstöße äh mit Präzisionsatellerie
äh Schlägen vor mit diesen Heimmaßsystemen haben sie einfach eine extrem hohe Treffergenauigkeit sie haben Special Forces, sie haben natürlich auch einen zunehmenden Maße den Support.
Der äh Bevölkerung, die äh entsprechende Tipps geben
infiltrieren einfach das Gebiet. Sie finden raus, wo sind äh hier entsprechende Truppen Standorte, wo sind äh Artillerie äh Orte,
die Russen jetzt auch schon deshalb dazu übergegangen sind, ihre Artillerie noch feiner zu verteilen
natürlich dann auch bedeutet, dass jetzt fast bei jedem Vorstoß und bei jeder aufgegebenen Verteidigungslinie entsprechende Mengen an Munition auch eingesammelt werden können. Sie haben enorm viele Panzer verloren, sie haben noch sehr viel mehr
ähm entsprechende ähm Gerüsse äh na armierte Fahrzeuge äh.
Verloren. Ihnen fehlen einfach die Transportmöglichkeiten und ihnen fehlen vor allem Lastwagen. Das heißt, sie sind nicht mehr in der Lage ihr Equipment zu äh transportieren. Sie sind nicht mehr in der Lage, Verstärkung zu trans
sie sind nicht in der Lage, Munition nachzurüsten. Das ist einfach ein totales Drama. Und natürlich kommen wir jetzt auch langsam
in äh die regnerische Zeit, also da ist jetzt deutlich mehr Schlamm am Start als noch vor ein, zwei Wochen und
das macht die Sache für die Russen nicht einfacher, weil deren Logistik basiert eben auf Eisenbahnen.
Aber auch für die Ukraine, also an sich ist es so, dass schlechtes Wetter eher den Verteidiger äh äh bevorzugt und äh den Angreifer benachteiligt.
Es werden auch zum Beispiel fast kaum noch Einsätze der russischen äh Luftwaffe registriert und
Äh stattdessen sind die Ukrainer jetzt äh deutlich mehr unterwegs und äh die Verluste, das hat man letzte Woche schon angesprochen, die Verluste
äh der Luftwaffe der Russen ist auch sehr hoch, also fast jeden Tag wird da irgendwie wieder in so eine SO 24 abgeschossen, auch Hubschrauber müssen äh drunter leiden. Also denen fehlt halt einfach in zunehmendem Maße,
sowohl das Personal als auch die Munition als auch das Gerät. Und die ganze Power.
Der Russen kommt aus ihrem aus ihrer Militärtechnik, das ist das, was sie so gefährlich macht. Das ist nicht die Soldaten, sondern es sind im Wesentlichen diese Geräte und diese Geräte kriegen sie immer weniger äh zum Einsatz gebracht
aus zahlreichen Gründen.
Plus ist äh wurde ja auch schon erwähnt, dass äh die Ukrainer ähm ihre Flugzeuge mit diesen Harmraketen, also mit,
äh den ähm Antiraderti-Radio äh ähm,
Raketen ausgestattet äh haben. Da haben sie dann zwar nicht alle Features, aber die haben dann eben Librarys äh drin so.
Onboard äh diese Raketen, wo sie dann bestimmte russische Systeme dann auch erkennen, äh beziehungsweise musste ihn dann vorher sagen quasi, nach welcher Art von System äh soll ich denn jetzt suchen?
Und.
Ähm das waren die Russen wohl bisher auch nicht gewohnt äh sage ich mal, dass sie äh ihr Radar abschalten
mussten. So also wie du halt dann wie du rum vermeidest äh äh von so einer harm getroffen äh zu werden ist, dass äh wenn äh du denn dann merkst, dass da eine im Anflug ist äh schaltest du halt deine
war da dein Radar ab, ja? Ähm.
Aber wenn du dein Radar abschaltest, siehst du halt nichts mehr. Das heißt, selbst wenn du jetzt mit den Harnraketen nicht unbedingt äh
jetzt was triffst äh oder zerstörst, weil die das abgeschaltet haben, eröffnest du dir damit eine.
Ein Zeitfenster wo deine Luftwaffe da rein kann, weil die alle ihre Radler abschalten mussten für die Zeit, weil halt Harmraketen im Anflug
äh sind so funktioniert das das Spielchen halt auch und weil die Russen das aber erst nicht gewohnt waren und davon ausgehen, dass halt eine ganze Reihe von äh,
Stellungen einfach nicht abgeschaltet haben erstmal und das eine Weile gedauert hat, bis sich das rumgesprochen hat, äh dass
ja äh dort Gefahr droht und äh so sind wahrscheinlich also ich denke nicht, dass das so weitergehen wird, aber Sie haben zumindest wohl auch ein paar Stellungen
erwischt äh äh damit bis die Russen dann vorsichtiger geworden sind, aber blind dadurch.
Also das ist das ist offensichtlich. Die äh Ukraine können ihre äh eigene Luftwaffe, die nicht nennenswert dezimiert ist, immer besser zum Einsatz bringen und äh das ist halt auch so ein weiterer Faktor. Also man könnte jetzt so zehn, 20 Sachen aufzählen,
generell ist es so die Situation der Russen verschlechtert sich im Personalbereich, im Versorgungsbereich, Logistikbereich, Kampfmittel.
Geht ihnen irgendwie alles verloren. Und es wird nicht besser und es wird noch schlimmer werden. Und bei der Ukraine ist es genau,
andersrum. Es trifft immer mehr gut ausgebildetes Personal ein. Sie bekommen immer bessere äh Waffen. Die Munition wird ausgestattet mit jedem Meter, den sie auch,
gewinnen. Äh verbessert sich ihre logistische Gesamtsituation, weil sie ja ohnehin durch diese,
in die Länge gezogene Frontlinie im Vorteil sind, weil sie innerhalb des Landes leicht verschieben können,
die Russen halt alles irgendwie äh über tausende Kilometer äh hin und her schieben müssen und das halt in zunehmendem Maße immer weniger tun können und dabei auch noch aufgerieben werden von den Ukrainern. Also das ist äh wirklich nicht schön.
Vielleicht äh um diesen Blog mit der Rakif Luhansk-Offensive, wie ich sie jetzt mal genannt habe, äh abzuschließen.
Was könnte jetzt hier das Endgame sein,
denke, dass das jetzt äh noch eine Weile so weitergehen wird, also auf jeden Fall ist der Norden des äh Luhanskoplas, der ist sozusagen als nächstes dran, ne? Er hat ja schon gesagt, also jetzt äh die Region,
äh Rakif, die ist jetzt quasi schon so gut wie komplett zurückerobert. Da fehlt jetzt nur noch wenige ähm Kilometer im Norden.
Aber das äh ist vielleicht schon zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wo wir das aufnehmen
schon getan und von dort werden sie dann weiter nach Osten vorstoßen und ich sehe nicht so richtig, wie die Russen dem noch irgendwie nennenswert etwas entgegensetzen wollen. Da sind einfach die Kräfte nicht da, die sind einfach alle, die stecken woanders fest
und äh mit der Taktik, mit der sie jetzt vorangehen und mit der Technik, die sie haben, werden sie also äh das einfach weiter
fortführen können, das heißt, wir werden jetzt sehen, dass äh äh das ist so die nächste Stadt äh in der Mitte, die dort auf dem Weg liegt, die äh wird sicherlich
angegriffen werden beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich auch wieder umringt werden und dann äh flüchten die irgendwann und äh langfristig
Ist es dann die Stadt äh Staro Bills
Wenn die fällt, dann ist sozusagen auch noch die letzte Nord-Süd ähm Eisenbahnlinie eingenommen und dann äh ist da einfach mal Muffensausen angesagt. Da kann dann Russland eigentlich nichts anderes machen, als sich auf diese 2014er,
Verteidigungslinie zurückzuziehen, also den Bereich von Luhansk zu kontrollieren, den sie bisher schon äh kontrolliert hatten.
Bevor sie jetzt eben den neuen Anlauf im Februar gemacht haben. Das Ganze hat natürlich auch noch ähm
Auswirkungen auf Donetsk, also dieses ganze Geschehen, was wir jetzt beschrieben haben, das ist ja so genau am am äh an so einem Dreieck von Luhansk, Krakie und äh also konkret hat sich das im Norden von Donetsk.
Und ähm dort wird ja noch kräftig äh gekämpft. Es ist so völlig absurd, also überall sind die Russen in der Verteidigung.
Derzeit oder eigentlich am Flüchten, äh nur an einem einzigen Ort, hauen Sie die ganze Zeit noch drauf und das ist halt irgendwie Bach.
Wo sie jetzt irgendwie seit drei Monaten versuchen irgendwie voranzukommen und irgendwie so 50 Meter Landgewinn äh gemacht haben und das ist da, wo.
Gruppe arbeitet und man macht so den Eindruck, dass die sozusagen so aus aus Prinzip einfach
äh weitermachen wollen, äh einfach um da zu glänzen. Aber es macht einfach keinen Sinn, ja. Es ist schon so ein Running Gag geworden, das wie so überall wird die weiße Fahne gehisst, nur ein Bachmuta geben sie irgendwie äh nicht auf. Aber auch das wird dann halt irgendwann ein Ende finden
spätestens wenn ähm tatsächlich
gelingen sollte äh zurückzuerobern, weil dann ist da äh einfach äh vorbei und dann können sie eigentlich nichts anderes machen, als sich in die Stadt Donez zurückzuziehen.
Und dann ähm ja wenn da die Karten auch neu gemischt in dieser Region.
Wenn langfristig natürlich ist jetzt.
Also das denke ich wird noch dieses Jahr passieren. Ja, auf jeden.
Also ja mal irgendwann, gut jetzt mit mit Winter wird halt auch nochmal interessant und
chaotisch äh werden, weil äh wie gesagt, erst mal kommt ja zwischendurch die Schlammzeit, aber dann irgendwann friert das Ganze zu und dann kann man halt doch wieder mit Panzern äh auf den Feldern.
Äh rumfahren oder mit mit anderen Fahrzeugen, das heißt, es wird eben viel auch so noch vom vom Wetter abhängen und dann natürlich auch äh
die Russen nicht dann vielleicht, wenn's zu kalt wird, auch einfach erfrieren in ihren äh Gräben.
Oder äh ja sich einfach keine Ahnung ähm
ja äh wo wo sie sich dann äh noch aufhalten müssen. Sie müssen sich dann irgendwie eingraben und äh dann ja.
Eingraben ist dann auch nicht mehr. Ja, also wenn der Boden gefroren ist, dann kannst du halt auch nicht mehr eingraben, das heißt, sie können dann maximal die Stellung noch benutzen, die sie jetzt haben.
Und da können sie dann erfrieren ähm und wenn sie irgendwie sich ein bisschen aufwärmen wollen, äh müssen sie halt ein Feuer machen, äh weiß man ja sofort, wo sie,
also das wird irgendwie nicht gut enden und ich denke da äh wird dann auch die überlegende Technologie der Ukraine einfach voll greifen. Deswegen, ich denke äh das Ding ist äh gelaufen. Ich sehe.
Chance äh in Luhansk im Norden dass sie das noch in irgendeiner Form lange halten können.
Wir werden's sehen. Das ist mein Tipp. Ich hatte ja letztes Mal schon gesagt, dass sie äh den Norden in Angriff nehmen werden und genau danach sieht es jetzt eben auch aus.
Ja, ich meine, gibt so ein paar Dinge, um jetzt nicht nur sagen, also mein Bild, zum Beispiel der Panzerzähler, den ich äh vorhin,
erwähnt hatte. Äh so, der hat jetzt grade aktuell noch
rund 6000 Kampfpanzer gezählt, die in russischen Depots stehen und das ist jetzt auch nicht nur Alter
Schrott äh den den den sie haben. So also es ist ich meine es ist ein bisschen eigentlich unklar unverständlich
oder das das Problem ist eher, dass die glaube ich es ihnen nicht an Panzern mangelt, sondern an Leuten, die sie bedienen können und die sie warten können, das ist zum Beispiel.
Es fehlt ihnen auch an Bahnlinien, auf denen sie dir irgendwie dahin fahren können.
Ja, das ist das andere Ding, aber das ist halt erstmal also Panzer und vermutlich Munition liegt noch,
irgendwo äh in Massen rum, für für mehrere Jahre Krieg, ja. Ähm so, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das Russland jetzt.
Völlig also absolut völlig am am Ende wäre und Sie haben auch noch
gute Truppen und und so, aber ähm ja, wie gesagt, mit ich meine, die beste Truppe nützt nichts, wenn äh dir deine Führung halt einfach
unsinnige Aufgaben gibt, die äh dich äh
total in Nachteil äh äh versetzen, wenn die dich in sinnlose Angriffe reintreiben, die nichts bringen oder dich vom Rückzug abhalten, wenn
ja also so das ist das ist so ein bisschen mein Punkt und.
Aber auch die guten Truppen sind auch schon seit sieben Monaten dort vor Ort. Die sind einfach ausgebrannt, die sind durchgekocht und auch die äh äh haben Versorgungsprobleme. Abgesehen davon, da kommen wir jetzt nämlich gleich auch drauf, dass viele davon gerade äh in eingeschlossen sind.
Ja aber wie wie gesagt, wenn ich sage mal um
wenn jetzt die Russen irgendwie das mit ihrer Führung auf die Reihe kriegen würden, ja und äh die äh da haben wir wieder das alte die alte Debatte und
die politische Führung äh äh sich da nicht ständig einmischen würde äh und äh irgendwie
verhindern würde äh diesen Krieg vernünftig zu führen so in dem Fall ja mehr oder weniger Putin ähm Putin ist schuld, ja
an vielen.
An allem eigentlich. Ja ja klar, aber das wird sich nicht ändern. Und wenn es sich ändert, dann ist der Krieg sowieso vorbei, weil ohne Putin wird's diesen Krieg äh nicht mehr geben. Zumindest nicht in dieser Form.
Sehr unwahrscheinlich, ja.
Ja sehr unwahrscheinlich. Also es ist überhaupt die einzige äh Methode, wie man das beenden kann. Lass uns mal auf die zweite Offensive kommen, weil die ist äh sehr
das ist die Offensive in. Diese ganze ähm
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine, die ja lange angekündigt war, hat ja scheinbar Interessen begonnen und dann war das ja nur so ein ähm ja so ein Ablenkungsmanöver in gewisser Hinsicht und dann äh hatten wir diese Rakito-Offensive, die dann so durch,
powert hat und alle haben sich gefragt, okay, was jetzt mit passierte nochmal irgendwas und das hat man ja auch schon beleuchtet
dass es eher so aussieht als ob eben hier
Ukraine einfach auf den richtigen Zeitpunkt wartet und einfach abtastet und erstmal das Feld äh bereitet, so wie sie's halt auch sonst überall gemacht haben. Also diese Shaping-Missions und ähm.
Ähm ausführlich dargestellt, hatten wir ja auch schon äh diese Situation, fast vielleicht noch mal kurz zusammen. Also es geht um diesen äh
rechts äh liegenden Uferteil, also den westlichen äh Teil des äh Nipa. Ähm der.
Ähm ja von Russen besetzt wurde mit der Stadt und dort gibt es halt nur zwei Brücken. Eine,
die Alexandriewer äh Brücke bei Caeson.
Die ist halt jetzt weitgehend zerstört worden oder zumindest unbefahrbar gemacht worden und ähm die andere äh ist für normale Fahrzeuge noch befahrbar. Das ist bei diesem Staudamm beim Nova Kakowka und das war's.
Ja und äh da halt die Ukraine so schön gedroht hat, sind dort sehr viele
russische Truppen. Man schätzt so ungefähr 20tausend, die da irgendwie äh abhängen und sind halt umringt von den Ukrainern und die haben halt hier und da mal äh angefangen anzugreifen, aber es war nie so richtig klar, wo die Offensive jetzt wirklich startet, wenn sie startet. Das wissen wir jetzt.
Nämlich ganz im Osten und da sind sie vor ein paar Tagen losmarschiert und es ist so ähnlich wie jetzt äh zuletzt in Aktiv.
Geht's auf einmal richtig schnell. Mit derselben Taktik. Sie stoßen halt in diese schlecht gesicherten Bereiche vor, wo nur so ein bisschen Infratie ist, flankieren die dann äh von verschiedenen Seiten und die sind gerade dabei.
Komplett sich aus diesem östlichsten Teil zurückzuziehen. Also.
Da geht's jetzt äh ähnlich zur Sache und sind wieder mal große Geländegewinne gemacht worden. Sind schon wie 2000 Quadratkilometer schon wieder an die Ukraine gefallen.
Mein Eindruck war auch, so wie du's geschildert hast, das ging ja irgendwie wochenlang hat man das Gefühl, okay es wird
getrommelt und äh aber es ging irgendwie immer nur so hundert meterweise voran mal einen halben Kilometer am Tag äh äh hier und so und kleinere Fortschritte und
Man hat ja fast schon das Gefühl, okay hm wird vielleicht erstmal äh doch nicht oder ja, also es ging jedenfalls nicht voran. Äh so vielleicht
mal einen Kilometer hier, ein halber Kilometer da und mein Eindruck war jetzt, dass äh jetzt an einem Tag plötzlich 20 bis 30 Kilometer äh irgendwie sich die Front verlagert hat, sehe ich das richtig.
Ja, also wir haben irgendwie am ersten Tag irgendwie 25 Kilometer äh wettgemacht so
äh in der Größenordnung. Das weiß man nicht so ganz genau, weil natürlich auch eigentlich alles immer sofort berichtet wird. Aber äh die Position, auf die sich die Russen angeblich zurückgezogen haben, die wurden dann äh ja da wurden am laufenden Meter wieder neue,
genannt. Und jetzt ähm haben sie so eine ja scheinbare Verteidigungslinie.
Die aber auch nicht so den Eindruck macht, als ob die noch groß halten wird und das bedeutet, dass es dann demnächst den Kampf geben wird, um ja diesen Staudamm,
bei Nova Kakovka. Das ist, sagen wir mal, der neuralgische Punkt und da wird sich das dann auch alles entscheiden,
russische Strategie ist und wenn die russische Strategie so ist wie sie bisher war dann ja kann es so aussehen als ob sich die Russen gleich das nächste Ei legen, weil wenn sie jetzt sagen Casson muss gehalten werden.
Dass Putin sagt, weil das ist ja für ihn total wichtig, dass Resson gehalten wird, weil das ja die größte Stadt, die sie eingenommen haben und das ist sozusagen das Tor nach Odessa und wenn sie äh das verlieren, dann verlieren sie diese ganzen Brückenkopf, den sie da äh sich aufgebaut haben.
Na ja und das will er halt nicht. Dementsprechend wird er irgendwie diesen Truppenbefehlen dort zu bleiben. Oder wird befehlen lassen, ne.
Ich meine, hat er ja bereits sich also.
Ja, aber jetzt auch im Kontext dieser aktuellen Kampfhandlung, so, weil jetzt werden sie halt nach Westen gedrückt und jetzt hätten sie ja noch die Möglichkeit, mit Fahrzeugen über diesen Damm.
Zu flüchten, nicht mit Panzern, aber mit Trucks.
So und dann könnten sie halt Personal äh retten und sie könnten sich retten und äh könnten irgendwie Material und Munition äh retten. Sie könnten zumindest irgendwas noch retten. Wenn sie sich aber jetzt sozusagen durch diesen,
hinter.
Äh Nord-Süd äh verlaufenden Innovlez Fluss verschanzen und sagen, nee, wir müssen jetzt hier irgendwie halten, dann sind sie halt in der Falle, weil sie können über diese andere Brücke nicht mehr flüchten.
Auch nicht mit äh normalen Trucks und es ist halt überhaupt nicht absehbar, wie sie halten wollen.
Die Ukrainer werden mit Sicherheit nicht auf Städtekampf gehen, sondern die werden die da halt einfach klein kochen. Und dann äh heißt es halt aufgeben für die, also die haben auch keine Möglichkeit, die können auch nicht durch den Fluss schwimmen oder so. Es ist einfach unmöglich.
Und ich denke mal auch nicht, dass die, ich sage mal so, den den Willen haben, äh den äh zum Beispiel umgekehrt äh.
Jetzt bei dem russischen äh äh Vormarsch ähm so Maria Pohl äh zum zum Beispiel dort die die Verteidiger oder so äh und wo äh dann.
Aber auch Russland ja unbedingt pushen oder Russland unbedingt pushen musste oder oder gepusht hat ohne Ende äh und eigentlich auch nur hätten.
Abwarten müssen, ja? Und das das scheint sich mir wie so ein roter Faden äh durch durch diesen ganzen Krieg.
Bisher zu ziehen. Es ging.
Am Anfang irgendwie in den ersten zwei oder drei Tagen ist das Ganze halt aus den Fugen geraten und ausm Tritt gekommen und seitdem ähm ja haben sie ihren Tritt nicht
nicht richtig wieder äh gefunden, so.
Sie hatten ihn eigentlich nie.
Und äh ja, beziehungsweise und haben ihn deswegen, na ja, äh genau äh und.
Eigentlich, ich meine, dass das bisher fast Vernünftigste, was Sie getan haben, war sich äh aus Kiew,
zurückzuziehen da oben aus dem Norden, ja? Das war bisher glaube ich die vernünftigste Aktion.
So äh und ansonsten ja immer entweder ähm Druck gemacht,
äh und unter großen Verlusten nur kleine Gewinne äh.
Äh erzielen äh können und äh umgekehrt dann ja was man sagen kann ist, dass zumindest auch wenigstens die Leute, also die meisten Leute.
Ähm meisten Soldaten scheinen dann doch irgendwie in der Lage zu sein, äh jeweils rauszukommen aus den Kesseln, aber oft eben ja Material liegen lassen.
Und auch gegen die Befehle, also gerade in Lüman macht es sehr den Eindruck, dass hier also geflüchtet sind, obwohl äh die Order war, ihr haltet jetzt mal die Stellung.
Das ist dann natürlich auch Fieps über viel psychologische Kriegsführung natürlich auch auch dabei und auch in Lümanen, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr's mitgekriegt hast mit den Zetteln.
Und mit den mit den Lautsprecherwagen die rumgefahren sind
und dann Instruktionen gegeben haben an äh russische Soldaten
oder gesagt haben hier ihr seid eingekesselt, ihr kommt jetzt hier nicht mehr raus
aber äh ihr könnt euch äh ergeben und äh wenn ihr euch ergeben wollt, habt
macht das so und so, also sozusagen Instruktionen gegeben an Russen, die sich noch versteckt haben, wie sie denn äh kapitulieren können und dass sie den kapitulieren sollen und.
Das ist das sogenannte i want to live Programm. Äh wo gerichtet wird, dass also schon 2000 Soldaten sich auf diesem Weg äh ergeben haben. Ob das äh so stimmt wissen wir nicht genau, aber äh das findet auf jeden Fall statt.
Was auch noch äh äh stattfindet äh das ist die jüngste Meldung.
Dass äh die Ukraine jetzt wohl dazu übergegangen ist, ihre Panzer, mit denen sie vorrücken, auch mit V und Z äh zu markieren.
Mhm.
Fragt so, äh wie was, äh das ist doch äh daran erkennt ihr doch wer zu euch gehört und so weiter. Macht wohl den Eindruck, als ob sie mittlerweile alle Fahrzeuge mit entsprechenden elektronischen IDs ausgestattet haben.
Und äh auch noch der kleinste Hamm, wie äh in der Lage ist, über die elektronischen Meldesysteme genau äh zu melden, wo denn jetzt sozusagen die eigenen äh gerade rumfahren und wo man jetzt hier kein Friendyfire starten sollte.
Während die Russen wiederum total verwirrt sind, weil da kommen dann auf einmal die V und Z äh Panzer und das sind ja teilweise vielleicht auch noch ihre Alten. Ja weil da.
Die ja alle, ja? Äh und äh dann entsprechende Fehler machen, weil sie dadurch äh verwirrt sind, ne.
Ja, wobei mein Eindruck
dann auch oder meine Vermutung wäre mit mit elektronischer Freundfeind-Erkennung ist so eine so eine Sache äh da will man sich nicht drauf verlassen, ja?
Ähm weil ja das kann halt schiefgehen, aber was so halt stattdessen eben einfach machst ist durch
gute und richtige Planung, indem du halt einfach weißt, äh also indem deine Truppen wissen, wo die eigenen Truppen sind und wo nicht, so dass es eigentlich egal ist, äh wie die
markiert sind in dem Fall und die wissen dann, okay, dann schickst du dann so einen VZ-Verband, sage ich mal, rein, äh dein dein
eigenen und äh alle anderen wissen aber, okay, erstens, der ist unterwegs und der Verband selber weiß, wer dazugehört
und äh auf alles andere wird geschossen. So ja.
Na ja, also man merkt einfach äh die Ukrainer hat die Russen im Griff und eine Feststellung, die ich gelesen hatte, fand ich auch äh ganz interessant,
dass es wohl kein Land gibt, was äh so viele äh kompetente und russischsprachige äh äh Agenten äh in ihrem Militär hat wie die Ukraine,
die wissen einfach, wie die Russen
denken. Die haben die jetzt einfach komplett dekodiert. Die wissen, wie sie kommunizieren. Die haben jetzt irgendwie ein halbes Jahr lang äh beim Funk zugehört. Die wissen, was sie machen. Die kennen alle Movements, die können.
Beobachten, die haben hervorragende Intelligenz, weil sie dann halt auch von den Amerikanern entsprechend gefüttert werden.
Die die wissen wahrscheinlich oft besser, wo die russischen Truppen sind als die russischen Führung.
Ja, genau.
Ist was dran, ne? Und dazu kommt auch noch, dass sie jetzt Interessen auch in zunehmendem Maße so die Lufthoheit haben. Also ist einfach jetzt mittlerweile viele Einsätze von der Luftwaffe äh geflogen werden. Offensichtlich ist einfach sind die entsprechenden Verteidigungsstellen der Ru
schon ausreichend ausgeschaltet. Ja
nochmal so das äh Endgame äh für diese Region habe ich ja teilweise schon äh angedeutet, also äh das kann gut sein, dass eben dieser Kampf um diesen Staudamm bei Nova.
Dass das so entscheidend ist, wenn sich halt die Russen äh Richtung Westen nach zurückziehen, dann äh kann es durchaus sein, dass die Ukraine sogar.
Vielleicht sogar einen Brückenkopf im Süden errichten könnte. Das wäre jetzt die optimistischste äh
Annahme, also dass sie sozusagen nicht nur die Russen zurückdrängen, sondern wenn sie ihn in irgendeiner Form auch noch gelingen sollte, durch geschickten
Einsatz von äh Artillerie, was jetzt nicht ausgeschlossen ist, weil sie haben jetzt diese Präzisionsatellerie. Die Russen soweit zurückzudenken, dass sie eben selber mit ihren
wiederum auf die Südseite äh kommen können, dann ist, glaube ich, auch für diesen ganzen Südbereich game over
und wie sich die Situation jetzt in konkret, also in der Stadt äh auflösen wird, das wird man dann sehen, dass es halt äh schwierig, aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass wir es dann hier auch einfach mit hohen Zahlen an ähm.
Sich ergebenen Truppen zu tun haben, dass dann einfach was ausgehandelt wird, weil die einfach überhaupt keine Option mehr haben. Die werden sonst da einfach nur erfrieren und verhungern.
Ja, wobei, wie gesagt, laufen können Sie ja. Also so zurückziehen, so äh da sind sie nicht schlecht drin. Äh.
Ja das äh hat nur das Problem, dass wenn sie dann irgendwie über diese Antonowski-Brücke äh laufen.
Das sind natürlich eins Atelierfutter sind. Also ich denke auch Herr wird dieses Jahr.
Befreit werden und das Ganze wird mit großen Verlusten für Russland gepaart sein
gesehen davon, dass dann das äh russische Programm, also sozusagen die Bereitstellung von Kampftechnik dann auch nochmal neue äh Spitzenwerte erreichen wird, ne.
Die letzte Statistik, die ich gesehen habe, ist das tatsächlich
offiziell jetzt äh Russland der größte Waffenlieferant äh für die Ukraine bei einer Reihe von Systemen, also bei Kampfpanzern definitiv.
So sind es einen Ticken mehr äh als äh sagen an an Ostpanzern äh von ja Tschechien und Polen und so geliefert äh Freunde.
Endcounting, also das nimmt äh nicht ab, ne. Fehlt jetzt eigentlich nur noch.
Um das Ganze abzurunden, dann eine Offensive in Saarborisia, also sozusagen da in der Mitte des äh ganzen südlichen Kampfgebietes und das ist äh durchaus,
dass eben äh die Ukraine sich auch dort nochmal verstärkt, weil die Truppen haben sie und die Technik kriegen sie in zunehmendem Maße auch und die Panzer kriegen sie von den Russen und dann äh wäre da äh glaube ich auch game over.
Ja, meine naive Vermutung ist, äh sagen, dass sie vielleicht möglicherweise auch statt jetzt bei Kaison über den Fluss zu sitzen, sie eher aus der Richtung dann kommen.
Das können Sie auf jeden Fall auch tun, aber wenn Sie sozusagen auch noch diesen Brückenkopf äh äh dort äh über den ähm aufbauen können, dann geht das halt alles sehr viel schneller, weil dann bleibt den Truppen in dem Hinterland
nördlich der Krim
gar nix mehr anderes übrig, weil da ist einfach nur Felder, da ist offenes Land, da ist irgendwie keinerlei Möglichkeit äh sich groß einzugraben. Da können sie sich dann einfach nur noch auf die Krim zurückziehen und äh da dann schauen, wie's äh weitergeht.
Ja ja man wird sehen. Also ja.
Ist meine Einschätzung.
Es kann ja ah es kann es es kann dann auch wieder noch etwas länger äh dauern, wobei natürlich jetzt
klar angesichts auch der Mobilmachung, die vielleicht oder.
Ja doch dann irgendwann früher oder später äh doch eine Verstärkung für die Borussen bringen äh wird sicher ist es.
Nicht, aber aber solange die Russen und weiter unter Zeitdruck sind, unter Zeitdruck gehalten äh werden äh macht Putin halt einen Fehler nach dem anderen. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was die Ukraine
jetzt gerade tut, ihn weiter unter Druck zu setzen und ihn zu weiteren Fehlern äh zu provozieren.
So, als äh.
Letzter großer Block äh müssen wir natürlich jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen dadrüber reden, was jetzt noch kommen kann, ne? Also es ist so wir wir mögen uns da jetzt im im Detail in der Einschätzung äh voneinander abweichen
wie's jetzt konkret weitergeht, aber es ist halt offensichtlich, dass die Russen einfach keine Gewinnperspektive mehr haben.
Ja, also gehen wir mal davon aus und das ist die wahrscheinlichste Variante, so ähm dass die Mobilisierung nicht.
Zum Erfolg führen wird, sondern die Ukraine.
Weiter, mal kürzer, mal schneller voran äh kommen wird und Russland große Verluste haben wird und irgendwann äh ja äh.
Wird Putin das erkennen, dass das so nicht funktioniert.
Und ähm dann ist die Frage, was kann er als nächstes tun?
Genau. Was jetzt in aller Munde ist, ist natürlich neue Waffen äh oder was heißt neue, alte alte Waffentechnik zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Äh ja chemische Waffen, Atomwaffen haben wir ja auch letztes Mal äh schon drüber gesprochen äh das.
Waffen können wir, glaube ich, schnell abhaken, dass es so äh etwas, was immer wieder im Raum geworfen wird, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Russen äh
übernehmenswerte äh chemische Waffen äh verfügen
ist sowieso schon sehr gering, weil wenn da sind die sehr alt und das Zeug hält sich irgendwie gar nicht lange und man müsste auch solche absurden Mengen ausbringen davon, äh
da gibt's einfach überhaupt gar nicht die Transportmöglichkeiten äh um das halt in irgendeiner Form auch nur an die Front zu bringen, geschweige denn irgendwie gewinnbringend auszubringen. Das kann man glaube ich
komplett abhaken, aber.
Gerade jetzt nach seiner komischen Rede äh steht natürlich diese Drohung, nuklearer Waffen weiterhin äh im Raum. Du hast ja noch ein paar weitere Gedanken dazu gemacht.
Ja ja, ja ist ähm.
Es ist dann halt insofern interessant, also nicht nur alles meine äh äh Gedanken, sondern viel habe ich auch aufgesammelt äh so
aus unterschiedlichsten Quellen äh was denn auf der Liste jetzt der möglichen Reaktionen auf.
Ja einen Atomschlag der der Russen und äh sagen nicht nur nicht nur Atomschlag, sondern.
Jede Art von ich sage mal weiterer Eskalation, wie auch immer, die die Aussehen mag und wie dann sagen, wenn diese Eskalation äh oder wenn wenn Putin irgendetwas,
tut, sagt in der in dieser Kategorie Massenvernichtungswaffen oder ähm,
ja andere, andere Dinge, was weiß ich
Anschläge auf irgendwie Zivilbevölkerung oder äh mal gut viel mehr Kanada jetzt nicht mehr nicht mehr steigern, was was das angeht, aber ähm ja,
äh Sabotage oder wie auch immer. Also jedenfalls er eskaliert auf irgendeine Art und Weise, die wir entweder nicht vorhersehen können oder ähm eben atomar.
So was wie könnte dann äh die die weitere Reaktion, also welches Eskalationspotential hat dann der Westen oder welche Antworten äh äh.
Wir denn äh dann eigentlich? Gehen wir mal vom einfachsten aus in Anführungszeichen. Er zündet irgendwo eine Atom.
Vielleicht als Demo äh oder auf irgendein militärisches Ziel, wie auch immer und dann ist die Frage, was passiert dann? Wie.
Der Westen, dann reagieren wir, werden vor allem die USA reagieren, wie
können die USA oder andere Länder auch reagieren und ähm wirtschaftlich äh gibt's da erstmal noch ein paar Eskalationsmöglichkeiten ähm.
Nämlich äh eine permanente Beschlagnahme allen russischen Auslandsvermögens. Da liegt ja vieles äh im Moment nur fest so, aber das ließe sich dann auch noch mal
deutlich ausweiten. Ähm aber ähm.
Der nächste Schritt könnte dann auch noch sein eben dann unbegrenzten Druck auf China Indien und den Rest der Welt äh.
Auszuüben, also in dem Fall dann zu sagen, okay, Putin.
Hat jetzt eine Atomwaffe gezündet und jetzt ist der Punkt gekommen, wo ihr entweder wo ihr euch entscheiden müsst, wo ihr steht, wo ihr nicht mehr neutral bleiben
äh könnt und entweder ihr schließt euch jetzt den Sanktionen an.
Äh so oder wir werden euch genau so sanktionieren, ja? Das wäre sozusagen das Ding.
Dann äh der nächste Schritt wären Militärblockaden.
Kaliningrad äh zu blockieren oder dann eine komplette Luft-und Seeblockade Russlands äh durchzuführen. Nach dem Motto okay, äh ihr habt's jetzt getan und äh jetzt äh ja
Wenn ihr irgendwie ähm auch aus eurem Land irgendwas rein oder raus transportieren wollt, ähm so.
Per Luft oder per Schiff äh wird das versenkt. Ähm ja hm und dann.
Der nächste Eskalations äh Schritt ähm wäre dann tatsächlich äh.
Ja konventionell jetzt russisches Militär.
Anzugreifen und zwar äh gäb's dann erstmal die Kategorie
Zerstörung, russischen Militärs in von Russland besetzten Gebieten auf fremden Territorium.
So habe ich mal die Kategorie zusammen.
Gefasst und da äh kommt dann schon eine gewisse Liste zusammen, nämlich in äh Georgien gibt's die siebte Militärbasis in Abrasien, wo viertausend
500 Mann stationiert sind und in Süd-Osien die vierte russische Militärbasis mit noch mal 3500 Mann. Und
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Georgier da so richtig was dagegen hätten, ja. Äh so ähm dann.
Aber Moldawien so, dass äh Munitionsdepot in was die Russen dort angeblich
bewachen, weswegen sie da 1500 Mann stationiert haben. Äh ja, also da könnte man auch noch,
wahrscheinlich größere Explosionen herbei äh äh führen.
Also nicht Moldawien, sondern eben dieses Transnistrieren, ne, dieses.
Also in Transnistrien yeah, aber es äh gut, es ist immer noch es gehört halt nach wie vor zu Moldawien und ist dann halt, ja
äh und da stehen eben auch steht Russisches äh Militär. Ja und dann natürlich.
Die Ukraine. So Thema äh einrichten, was ja am Anfang so in der Überlegung stand.
Oder ganz einfach direkt intervenieren
in der Ukraine also quasi militärische äh äh Ziele direkt äh in der
äh in der Ukraine angreifen, also schon dann Kriegspartei werden, aber nicht
russisches Territorium, sondern gut ja jetzt mit den Annexionen, aber wie gesagt, pseudo-russisches Territorium.
Das spielt ja eh keine Rolle mehr und dann könnte man halt auch noch den Militärhafen in Sewastopol äh zerstören und die Schwarzmeerflotte versenken, aber das hatten wir glaube ich
schon beim letzten.
Das ist ja vor allem das, was dieser General äh Patreos auch in so einem Interview vor kurzem äh als ob.
Genannt hat, ne? Er meinte, das wäre ja nur hypothetisch und äh würde sowas ja auch nicht vorschlagen, aber wenn man jetzt mal so ein Beispiel nennen würde für diese ganz.
Der Dimension, die das haben könnte, dann wäre halt die Zerstörung sämtlicher russischer ähm Militärstützpunkte in der Ukraine und eben.
Schwarzmeerflotte, ne? Das wäre sozusagen und das wäre halt für die Amerikaner auch äh ein Leichtes.
Und wie gesagt, dann kommt aber eben noch ja Georgien und Moldawien äh auch noch äh,
dazu in in Frage, ja.
Aber eher für na ja.
Ähm ja ähm so gut und dann hm ich meine,
dann ein weiterer Eskalationsschritt äh wäre noch äh Druck auf Länder auszuüben ähm
wo es eine einvernehmliche, russische Militär äh Präsenz äh gibt, dass man dann sagt den Ländern also entweder.
Ihr sagt den Russen jetzt, dass die dort die Militärbasen zu schließen und das Land zu verlassen haben, sonst greifen wir das an, aber wir sagen euch das netterweise vorher, also und,
Ähm ja, so ein bisschen einen einen Deal zu dem man auch gleich wie die Amerikaner eigentlich mit den Russen hatten im im im Syrien äh Krieg.
Und ja, also da käme in Frage dann in Armenien zum Beispiel die 10zweite Militärbasis in 5000 russische Soldaten stationiert sind oder waren vor dem Ukrainekrieg
äh wie viel da jetzt abgezogen worden sind, weiß man nicht genau. Äh dann könnte man,
äh russische ähm Militärinstallation in Belarus. Da ist dann gibt's in Barannavic eine Radarstation und in Längstwellensender und dann in Barawitsch noch so ein Luft.
Waffenausbildungszentrum so. Ähm halte ich auch für unwahrscheinlich. Aber wie gesagt, das ist halt jetzt so ein so ein Menü. Ist jetzt keine bestimmte Reihe, beziehungsweise.
Serviervorschlag.
Ja also wir Vorschlag ja
so dann, ich meine wo was ich nicht hoffen würde ist, dass es dazu kommt, aber in Kasachstan gibt's halt noch das Kosmodrom in Balkon nur, wo du dich wahrscheinlich besser mit auskennst und das ist zwar jetzt
von einem private contract da glaube ich äh wird das jetzt äh betrieben, aber wird halt eben auch von Russland genutzt und da könnte man sagen, okay, ja.
Nee, Schluss mit Beikongur. Und hm, wie siehst du das?
Also.
Halte ich jetzt für ausgeschlossen, dass ihr dann ausgerechnet in Kasachstan irgendwie was platt machen, was ja da im Zweifelsfall irgendwann mal vielleicht mal Kasachstan gehört so und Kasachstan verhält sich ja nun gerade nicht so, dass sie jetzt besonders bestrafungswürdig wären, also das.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, aber äh ja.
Gut, du zählst jetzt einfach mal auf. So.
Ich zähle sie jetzt einfach mal auf, wo überall sozusagen Eskalationspotential. Besteht. Ähm.
So dann ja und dann natürlich Syrien. Äh Syrien so sagen das hatten wir glaube ich auch schon beim letzten Mal und zwar die einmal die Marinebasis Tatus äh so wo,
ja Russland jetzt auch ein paar größere Schiffe gerne mal parkt oder oder versorgt.
Und äh dann gibt's auch noch wohl drei Luftwaffenstützpunkte, ähm die entweder von Russland genutzt
werden oder mal genutzt wurden so je nachdem und da gibt's eben äh als größten Stützpunkt in My Meme heißt das Ding, dass die Hauptbasis, da sind ungefähr tausend.
Man stationiert und ähm ja.
Irre an äh mein ist äh im.
Zwei0achtzehn, also am 5. Januar 2tausend8zehn, wurde das von einem Drohnenschwarm angegriffen. So der erste Angriff vor dieser Art, 13 Drohnen, die dann von Russland,
wurden und äh überwiegend glaube ich mit elektronischen Kampfmitteln ähm,
Und ähm so insgesamt in 2018 gab es Dutzende von Drohnenangriffen, sowohl,
auf diesem Luftwaffenstützpunkt da Malmin, wie auch auf diese Marinebasis in äh Tatus. Und insgesamt äh meine ich.
Bis zu 200 Drohnen, die in diesem Jahr äh äh dort äh,
Griffe geflogen haben oder mit denen, die angegriffen wurden und äh Russland hat damals dann die USA beschuldigt hinter dem ersten Drohnenschwammangriff zu stecken und die USA haben das aber zurückgewiesen. Wenn man sich die Drohnen anguckt
die da eingesetzt wurden, also jeder.
Drittklassige Hobbybastler oder so. Hier würde sich schämen
so etwas zu zu bauen. Also es sieht wirklich aus wie
äh aus irgendwelchen Teilen vom Sperrmüll zusammengenagelt das Ganze. Das ist ein Wunder, dass das Ding überhaupt fliegt. Aber vielleicht ist das ja genau die
die List äh so, dass dass die Dinger halt aussehen wie home made, aber in Wirklichkeit Hightech. Keine Ahnung, aber was dagegen spricht, ist dass halt, wie gesagt, Russland wohl angeblich die alle äh.
Abgewehrt hat. Aber ich fand's spannend, weil ich wusste es gar nicht, dass irgendwie da Russlands Luftwaffenstützpunkt seit unter permanenten Drohnenattacken
äh leidet. Insofern muss man denken, dass die Russen eigentlich Erfahrung haben so mit Drohnenangriffen, ja. Ähm ja und dann.
Gab's halt äh auch noch äh Truppen in heißt das auch in äh Syrien, Flugplatz.
Und äh da hat Trump 2tausendsiebzehn 50 Tomahawk-Cruise-Missheits äh hinschicken lassen als Antwort auf äh.
Eben äh Chemiewaffeneinsätze damals und äh
Ja und da haben sie eben Russland vorher informiert, weil die Russen dort auch Flugzeuge geparkt hatten, wohl.
Und äh die haben sie dann wohl rechtzeitig wegbringen können, so dass dann die Amerikaner dann quasi nur in Anführungszeichen jetzt die Syrer bombardiert hatten. Also
ja kuriose Geschichte. Ja und in Tajikistan, in sind noch 75hundert Mann, die irgendwie auch Ärger kriegen können.
Und ansonsten ja generell russische Schiffe, die weltweit irgendwo rumfahren, Kaliningrad äh ist halt auch ein Ziel dann
wurde halt die Zerstörung aller russischen Opitalplattformen und Satelliten ins Spiel gebracht und unbegrenzter Cyberkrieg.
So dass äh sind dann.
Quasi ob's also ein kompletter Angriff auf die äh ja russische Infrastruktur. Das sind so die Dinge, die sich jetzt gerade, ja, in der in der Diskussion befinden.
Ernsthaft, einschließlich Satelliten. Also ich glaube, das fällt mal komplett aus.
Also ich glaube auch nicht auch nicht daran würde ich auch für unwahrscheinlich halten, aber darüber wird geredet.
Vollkommen ausgejagt wer wer redet darüber? Also das ist äh ein Satelliten angreifen, das ist eine ganz schlechte Idee. Eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Mhm. Ja würde ich.
Also falls das nicht jemand nicht nachvollziehen kann, also wenn wir eins nicht mehr brauchen, dann Weltraumschrott.
Nur ich sage mal, wenn wir schon sozusagen nuklear angekommen sind, ja. Stelle dir also einfach mal nur sozusagen ich meine, dann sind wir schon an einem Punkt äh so ja wo.
Hm auch so was ähm ja nicht mehr undenkbar wird.
Aber damit schadest du halt äh dir selbst noch am meisten.
Ne? Kommt drauf an, auf welche Art und Weise du das machst.
Da gibt's keine Methode, die äh irgendeiner Form.
Na ja, wenn du einfach nur das Ding äh mit äh ich sage mal entsprechend ja elektromagnetischer Energie äh,
oder mit Lasern anstrahlst und dass das mechanisch intakt bleibt oder zusammenbleibt, aber halt einfach nur.
Elektronisch nicht intakt ist, dann kann es seine Bahn nicht halten und dann hast du wiederum Schrott. Also das ist einfach eine.
Ja nee, dann kommt's ja runter.
Ja
Tausend kleinen Teilen äh verteilt über 20 Jahre. Das äh fällt nicht einfach mal so runter. Das ist irgendwie im Orbit. Also das äh vergisst das mal. Das ist einfach Unsinn. Das das äh würde,
die Amerikaner niemals machen. Ich meine, das haben die Chinesen mal gemacht und das war eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Ja ich äh fände das auch eine ganz schlechte Idee, insbesondere äh weil äh ja hm ich sage mal.
Eher die USA viel abhängiger sind äh davon äh und.
Sagen man dann natürlich auch potenziell natürlich Gegenschläge dann auch wiederum äh äh herausfordern würde und
und die meisten
ja größeren Flugabwehrraketen eignen sich durchaus davon, also du brauchst da keine speziellen Raumfahrzeuge oder Weltraumwaffen, um so einen Satelliten abzuschießen. Da genügen halt
auch äh so ähm ja größere Luftabwehrraketen oder an die Schiffsraketen oder so.
Dreihundert, 400 Kilometer hochkommen.
Die müssen ja nur ballistisch. Die müssen ja nicht in die Umlaufbahn. Und einige davon schaffen's halt auch, also Interkontinental-Raketen gehen daher durch den Weltraum.
Gut, lass uns bei den realistischen äh Szenarien.
Ja ja, nee äh aber es gab, ich meine, es gab Übungen, also äh Amerikaner haben halt eigene Satelliten äh schon abgeschossen auf diese Art und Weise, um zu gucken, ob das geht.
Ja und auch die Chinesen haben äh so was gemacht und das äh ist gar nicht gut angekommen.
Ich finde das ja, ich finde das gruselig, ja, aber ja so.
Aber was mir in dem Zusammenhang äh dann halt äh auch nochmal ich mir ich mir angeguckt habe ähm was denn jetzt so,
an Militär äh hat zur Verfügung hat, weil dachte man ja ich meine.
Die NATO-Armee auch in dieser Debatte Qualität versus äh Quantität, hm.
So was was ist denn da an an Quantität eigentlich bei der bei der NATO, weil wir haben ja relativ kleine Berufsarmeen, alles überwiegend professionelle Soldaten nicht.
Also.
In den meisten Ländern auch in den USA, die die größten äh das größte Einzelkontingent stellen, gibt's ja keine Wehrpflichtigen äh und so und der Trend ging ja weg davon. So, aber.
Ähm und und insgesamt denkt man ja so so viel so viel ist es dann eigentlich dann doch wieder nicht. Also,
weil kalte Krieg ist vorbei und alle haben ihre Arsenale verkleinert und es ist überhaupt weniger Waffen. Und äh ja
Und weniger Soldaten, aber guckt man sich dann an, wie viel Soldaten denn der NATO zur Verfügung stehen, dann sind das insgesamt 4,7 Millionen. Und zwar 3,4 Millionen davon,
Tiefe, die sich im Dienst befinden
und 1,3 Millionen in Reserve und zwar richtige Reserve, sage ich mal, die auch wirklich Ausrüstung und Waffen haben und aktivierbar sind.
Dann hat die NATO 20.000 Flugzeuge, ja und 3.500 Kampfflugzeuge.
Davon 8.500 Hubschrauber von 1360 Kampfhubschrauber.
1540 Transportflugzeuge und was Micho umgehauen hat 60 Tankflugzeuge.
Äh nicht 680 Tankflugzeuge und davon sechs
27 von der USA. Wie sechshundertsiebenundzwanzig
Tankflugzeuge, also die USA betreiben irgendwie so einfach eine globale Lufttankstelle im Grunde genommen.
Mhm, dann äh äh obwohl ja gerade die USA so Panzermäßig und so nicht so
ja Panzer oder die großen Zahlen von Panzern sind aus der Mode gekommen. Nichtsdestotrotz würde die NATO dann doch über.
Insgesamt 15.000 Kampfpanzer verfügen und über 116.000 Panzerkampfwagen
Ja, 116.000 Panzerkampfwagen.
Fast also äh dann von diesen, ich sage mal ja, im Prinzip sind nicht Panzerhaubitze 2tausend alles, aber die zählen halt dazu, aber von solchen selbstfahrenden,
selbstfahrender Artillerie 5000 Stück ungefähr und ähm.
Fünftausend
800 noch Artilleriegeschosse, die man hinter einem Wagen einspannen kann und äh ziehen kann. Dann von diesen Raketenwerfern, also ich sage mal Heimmaß.
2900 Stück in unterschiedlichster Form, aber im Wesentlichen, ja, 2900 Raketenwerfer und.
240 Schiffe da und davon.
Dreißig Flugzeugträger äh nicht fast alle USA hundertzwanzig Zerstörer hundertvierzig,
Frigatten 90 Korvetten und 220 U-Boote, ja. Ähm.
Also ich ich weiß nicht, wie's dir bei dieser Zahlen auflistung geht, ah, das ist äh ich fand das.
Deutlich mehr als äh ich so ausm Bauch raus gesagt hätte. Wie siehst du das?
Äh so mit den nackten Zahlen, da da hätte ich glaube ich bei den wenigsten Zahlen irgendwie richtig geraten.
Also ähm äh ich glaube wir haben einfach zu viel.
Das hat ein gewisses Abschreckungspotential.
Ja ja ja gut, ich meine das meiste davon ist halt auch die USA so dann sagen äh gut je nach je nach System,
Kann man sagen, zwischen 70, ja sechzig, 70 bis fünfundneunzig Prozent.
Äh davon äh es ist USA und ähm.
Ja. Äh das ist es ist find's grundsätzlich zu viel so und.
Wäre gut, wenn man irgendwie was davon wegkriegen könnte so auf Dauer. Aber es ist gerade, glaube ich, die falsche Zeit,
äh duperweise, weil äh wir bauen halt äh schon doch noch,
mehr davon gerade. Also es wird wird ja mehr und nicht weniger so. Und gut wieder ist es sehr ungleich verteilt und äh aber,
auf der anderen Seite, ich meine wer will sich bitte schön mit der Nato anlegen, ja? Ich meine Selbsthitze ich eben ein.
Und diese 4,7 Millionen Soldaten, also es ist die NATO hat nicht nur Quantität, sondern das ist auch
alles äh eine ganz gute Qualität und Führung und Planung und Aufklärung und Zusammenspiel und so, dass ich mein gut, Militär ist trotzdem ziemlich oft ein Fuckup und so, weil
Ja, äh aber hm ja, wenn ich mir, wenn ich mir das angucke, so.
Bin ich schon schwer beeindruckt. Auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite ja.
Irre. Irre.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ist es nachvollziehbar, ähm dass man sich mit der NATO nicht äh unbedingt anlegen äh möchte und dieses ganze Anti-Natorgeschreie äh in Russland ist glaube ich nicht unbedingt unter dem Eindruck solcher realen Zahlen äh.
In der Wahrnehmung.
Da wird auch klar, also selbst wenn Russland irgendwie alles äh in die Waagschale werfen äh äh würde, was das hat, also konventionell äh so.
Ist da nix zu wollen, ja, gar nix. Und deswegen vor dem Hintergrund jetzt also,
warum mich jetzt diese Zahlen auch noch mal äh äh gebracht habe oder rausgesucht hatte war wie realistisch ist es denn, dass quasi, wenn es zu dieser Eskalation kommt, äh was
kann denn da die NATO ins Feld äh äh werfen und ich,
glaube nicht, dass da Russland irgendwie äh ja konventionell irgendwas entgegenzusetzen.
Gut. Kann man ja äh langsam zum äh Ende. Die Sendung ist definitiv äh schon lang genug.
Vielleicht so zum Abschluss nochmal so ein bisschen die Wahrnehmung ähm des Konfliktes.
Aus der westlichen.
Perspektive und zwar jetzt nicht irgendwie so von den Regierungen, sondern von so allen anderen. Ich meine, wir haben ja nun auch in Deutschland die ganze Zeit diese Debatte.
Die so äh zwischen man muss irgendwie alles dafür tun, dass die Ukraine gewinnt oder ein leichterer Abschwächung. Man muss alles dafür tun, dass Russland nicht gewinnt.
Schon mal so eine Formulierung, die man mal so mal so findet. Aber dann haben wir halt auch immer wieder so diese Leute, die eben der Meinung sind oder zumindest eine Meinung verkünden.
Ja, diese ganze Krieg, das ist ja alles so bedrohlich und der Putin, der ist ja so böse und Russland ist ja so gefährlich und überhaupt und das kann ja alles noch weiter eskalieren.
Ne? Gut, jetzt haben wir jetzt gerade über Eskalationspotentiale gesprochen, so wie sie irgendwie äh vor allem jetzt, sagen wir mal, als die.
Antwort auf eine mögliche atomare Eskalation Russlands vielleicht stattfinden könnte.
Aber äh im Wesentlichen sind hier vor allem so diffuse Ängste am
man hat halt einfach Schiss vor diesem Krieg äh Schiss überhaupt vor diesem ganzen Konflikt, dass er sich auf das eigene Land aus
wirkt direkt oder auch äh auch nur indirekt. Weiß noch keiner genau, was jetzt in diesem Winter äh passieren wird im Rahmen der Energiekrise, inwiefern die Härten die Leute jetzt finanziell zu erleiden haben oder vielleicht auch einfach.
Irgendwelche äh sekundären Auswirkungen davon wie wie ihn das äh.
Was das dann auslöst und wir haben ja auch die ganze Zeit so auch diese extreme Debatte mit irgendwie ja äh warum gibt sich denn die Ukraine nicht geschlagen, die haben ja sowieso keine Chance.
Das verstummt jetzt so langsam ein bisschen im angesichts der.
Erfolge kann aber auch wieder umschlagen, ne. Und äh als ob wir nicht schon irgendwie alles gehabt hätten.
Äh und sich nicht jeder schon zu Wort gemeldet hätten hätte kam jetzt irgendwie auch noch Elon Musk ausgerechnet irgendwie aus der äh.
Heraus und musste dann irgendwie auch noch seinen Senf dazugeben.
Hat irgendwie so einen Tweet abgesetzt, der irgendwie wunderbar uninformiert daherkam und irgendwie halt auch dieses diese Eskalation sozusagen als
Drohung irgendwie in den Raum stellt und man müsste sich doch irgendwie einigen und man müsste doch irgendwie vielleicht dann doch Gebiete
treten und äh meinte dann auch, ja hier irgendwie die Krim war doch irgendwie immer schon russisch und so weiter. Also sozusagen auch so eine.
Mischung aus äh dieser ganzen Putinpropaganda, die seit Jahrzehnten da äh ausgeschüttet wird über der Welt plus eben solche solche.
Diffusen Ängste, die dann so in Raum kamen. Und wir haben das ja hier auch mit der Wagenknecht.
Auf der einen Seite so ja oder AfD auf der anderen Seite, die ihr aus welchen Motivationen auch immer heraus auch ähnliches argumentieren, ne und das ist irgendwie weiß ich nicht, da fühle ich mich.
Drehen weit von entfernt von solchen.
Ja ich ich versuche ja immer bei sowas äh schon auch.
Die andere Seite zu verstehen und diese anderen Sichten auch äh zu verstehen und zu gucken, ob da nicht vielleicht.
Auch was dran ist und ähm so was jetzt die Krim.
Angeht beispielsweise ist die Situation.
Bisschen komplizierter würde ich würde ich sagen ist auch rechtlich so ein bisschen äh kompliziert, weil hm,
bevor sich die Ukraine von äh äh der Sowjetunion.
Gespalten hat, was in einem äh ja in diesem offiziellen quasi Sowjet weiten
Referendum dann äh stattfand, also in allen Teilrepubliken und äh der der ehemaligen Sowjetunion und
gab's halt Referenten, die auch äh ja aus heutiger Sicht
als fair betrachtet äh werden und wo dann im Übrigen in allen,
ukrainischen Provinzen auch
auf der Krim. Äh da war allerdings das niedrigste Ergebnis. Ich glaube mit irgendwie etwas über, also 54 Prozent oder so in der Größenordnung hat sich die Mehrheit für ein
weg äh von der Sowjetunion und für einen weg von Russland ausgesprochen, ja. Ähm.
Vorher fand aber äh äh auf der Krim ein eigenes Unabhängigkeitsreferendum statt.
So vier Monate früher wo die Krim sich eigentlich unabhängig erklären wollte äh was mit einer deutlich größeren äh äh Mehrheit äh.
Ich glaube auch, achtzig, neunzig Prozent oder so.
Ungefähr beschlossen wurde. Insofern äh ist dann jetzt nicht sagen, okay, die Frage äh so hätte man vielleicht,
äh der ist der Krim unrecht getan worden, weil sie eigentlich autonom
sein wollte oder auch ein eigener Staat und da sind ja auch teilweise kleinere Zipfel sage ich mal von von der Sowjetunion dann äh autonome Staaten geworden. Warum äh durfte die Krim?
Jetzt nicht.
Auch ja wo sie doch wo doch die Leute des des das wollten und es da nicht vielleicht dann doch was dir respektiert worden. Aber.
Ähm zum einen, wie gesagt, rechtlich war's halt kompliziert auch, da galt eben noch die Verfassung, auch der.
UdSSR und äh ähm deswegen war das dann hinterher auch nicht nicht bindend, aber es es lief alles nicht ganz fair und nicht ganz ganz ganz fein ab. Nur erstens.
Hatte damit nix zu tun
Ja, das hat sich erstmal äh sozusagen Russland selbst angetan und äh auch
der Grund, warum in den meisten Republiken für die Unabhängigkeit gestimmt wurde, hat was
mit dem Verhalten von Russland zu tun in der Zeit der Sowjetunion, weil wenn all das Gefühl gehabt hätten, oh die Russen sind unsere Brüder und in der Sowjetunion lief das ja alles alles so super äh so nee, mit denen wollen wir dann lieber weiter bleiben. Nee, nee, so war's nicht.
So ja und äh.
Spätestens aber, selbst wenn man jetzt sagen kann, okay, da ist jetzt der Krim vielleicht mal Unrecht getan äh worden, aber eigentlich.
Spätestens jetzt mit der gewaltsamen Invasion und Annexion, ja äh.
Von ukrainischem Territorium ist das auch alles hinfällig. Ähm so äh und.
Ich sehe es halt so, es gibt es gibt keine Russen auf der Krim. Ja, wenn man das immer von irgendwie in Russen oder ne an unterschiedliche ähm.
Unterschiedliche Bezeichnungen äh gewählt, aber das sind halt russischstämmige oder russischsprachige Ukrainer. Die haben sich irgendwann entschieden so ähm,
Ukrainer zu sein, ja und einen ukrainischen Pass zu kriegen. Wir hätten auch problemlos wahrscheinlich einen russischen Pass kriegen können und als Russen in der Ukraine leben oder
als äh Russen in Russland leben, diese Optionen hatten sie ja, ja, weil sie haben sich
entschieden zu sagen als Ukrainer in der Ukraine zu leben und insofern ja.
Ist das also.
Sehe ich äh klar jetzt sagen okay, man könnte das vielleicht korrigieren, aber der Zug ist abgefahren, ja für äh das lässt sich jetzt nicht mehr korrigieren nicht nachdem
äh nicht nach der ganzen Gewalt, die jetzt äh passiert ist, nach dem ganzen Unrecht, nachdem alles, was Russland getan hat, ja, hat es im Grunde genommen auch
ja der russischsprachigen Bevölkerung äh der Krim ein Bärendienst erwiesen und.
Deswegen halte ich auch sagen jetzt Reden darüber, dass ja man irgendeine Lösung finden muss für,
die die kriminal, man muss irgendeine Lösung finden für die Krim, aber
Ähm es gab ja selbst am Anfang der Invasion hat Zelenz gesichert, dahingehend geäußert, ja von wegen mit Autonomiestatus äh und und so, die hatte sowieso schon einen gewissen.
Autonomiestatus in der äh in der Ukraine, aber äh
Ja. Diese diese Option hat Russland zunichte gemacht. So und leider werden halt dann wird die Bevölkerung der Krim äh jetzt darunter leiden
müssen äh am Ende und entweder dann wahrscheinlich äh ja.
Von der Krim vertrieben werden oder äh ja sich halt dann mit äh damit arrangieren müssen, Teil der Ukraine zu sein. Andere Variante sehe ich jetzt nicht als realistisch an.
Ja, mir ging's jetzt auch nicht so sehr um die Situation der Krim sondern mir ging's jetzt eigentlich mehr so um diese äh Frage der der Ängste, die äh.
Sich sozusagen in solchen Statements und solchen Fallstricken angeblich historischer äh Realitäten äh
ausdrückt so, was was treibt die Leute? Was was hält sie zum Beispiel davon.
Jetzt hier eine ganz klare Position äh zu beziehen. Und dieser Tweet von äh Elon Musk hat das so ein bisschen auch noch mal hervorgebracht, weil der einfach so so so halt so wirr und so uninformiert ist so, ja? Also ist von.
Hat's halt einfach mal historisch nicht richtig betrachtet, aber vor allem war eben so dieser
der Vater des Gedankens so bisschen so dieses oh da ist eine bedrohliche Situation, die verstehe ich nicht irgendwie. Ich mache jetzt hier mal einen Vorschlag. Also ausgerechnet eher zu solchen Konflikten berufen wäre, sich überhaupt dazu zu äußern.
Ja, ich meine, sorry,
das mit den Raketen und mit den Autos und meinetwegen auch noch mit den Robotern. Ja, das verstehst du, das ist irgendwie deine Welt so, aber es gibt einfach Bereiche, da musst du dich einfach äh mal raushalten. Da gab's ja irgendwie auch vor
zwei Jahren gab's auch immer mit diesem was war das? Dieser Fall wo irgendwelche Kinder in irgendeiner Höhle da.
Waren, wo er dann irgendwie mit seinen Robotern da irgendwie halt dich einfach raus, ne. Mir geht's auch nicht um äh.
Ich habe einfach einen schönen äh Twittersread äh gefunden von ähm.
Nur äh Smith, der auch in meiner Ukraineliste drin ist. Den habe ich mal übersetzt und ich wollte den einfach mal so vorlesen, weil ich glaube, dass der das ganz gut ähm,
zusammenfasst. Äh er adressiert jetzt hier Amerikaner, sagt er. Damit ähm,
das halt ein bisschen auf die USA fokussiert und natürlich ist damit irgendwie erstmal Elon Musk gemeint sozusagen als Auslöser, ohne dass er ihn jetzt explizit benennt.
Aber ich glaube, das gilt äh in irgendeiner Form auch äh für alle anderen,
Ähm lese das mal vor. Herr, die mit Friedensplänen für die Ukraine aufwarten.
Suchen nur nach der Illusion von Kontrolle in einer beängstigenden und unkontrollierbaren Situation.
Die Wahrheit ist, dass Putin an einem solchen Plan kein Interesse hat und dass es seine Entscheidung ist, ob er weiter eskaliert.
Wir möchten glauben, dass wir irgendetwas tun können, um die Situation zu deeskalieren und Putin wieder in die ruhiges Pfingst zu verwandeln, die A1 zu sein schien.
Aber wir können einfach nichts tun, um das zu erreichen, genauso wenig wie wir Trump wieder in Trumpf verwandeln können.
Wir schreien uns gegenseitig an, weil wir es nicht tun, was auch immer
kurzzeitig davon überzeugen, dass äh es den Krieg beenden würde. Aber die Wahrheit ist, dass der Krieg genau dann endet, wenn Wladimir Putin aufgibt, stirbt oder in eine Zelle geworfen wird,
Wenn sich die Ukraine morgen bedingungslos ergeben und ihre gesamte Bevölkerung Folter, Unterdrückung und Hinrichtung aussetzen würde, würde Putin seinen Blick auf Polen und das Baltikum richten.
Und so weiter bis er entweder geschlagen wird, bis er stirbt oder bis er aus dem Amt entfernt wird.
Ein paar der Leute, die Amerika für die Eskalation dieses Krieges verantwortlich machen, sind echte russische Handlanger, aber die meisten sind nur verängstigte Menschen, die daran gewöhnt sind, die Kontrolle über die Ereignisse zu haben und plötzlich keine Kontrolle mehr haben.
Und es ist nicht falsch, Angst zu haben. Russland ist unheimlich. Putin ist beängstigend. Krieg ist beängstigend,
Aber es gibt nicht immer etwas, das sie tun können
die beängstigenden Dinge verschwinden zu lassen. Manchmal musst du sie konfrontieren oder sie fressen dich auf und manchmal konfrontierst du sie und sie fressen dich trotzdem auf.
Lindenby Johnson sagte über äh Rusewelt, er war die einzige Person, die ich je gekannt habe irgendwo, die nie Angst hatte.
Solche Leute gibt es, aber es sind nur wenige, die überwiegende Mehrheit von uns ist kein Rosewelt, also haben wir Angst und wir zeigen mit dem Finger und geben die Schuld, weil wir es äh.
Weil wir's können.
Die schreckliche Wahrheit ist, dass Wladimir Putin beschlossen hat, Eroberung und Imperium zur Aufgabe seines restlichen Lebens zu machen und er befehligt die Überreste des alten sowjetischen Nuklearsenats.
Ist die Realität, der wir uns auf die eine oder andere Weise stellen müssen.
Sehr schöner Sweat.
Ja und das ist glaube ich auch nachvollziehbar. Leute haben halt einfach irgendwie äh eine Angst und.
Damit verbundene Kontrollverlust, der ist halt irgendwie äh schwierig und ich meine, das ist auch der Grund, warum wir sowohl diese Reihe über Corona gemacht haben,
als auch jetzt diese Reihe über den Krieg, weil wir auch in gewisser Hinsicht Kontrolle.
Zurückerhalten wollen über über eine Situation, die einfach generell beängstigend ist. Ist nicht die einzige Motivation, aber ist Teil.
Motivation, den würdest du wahrscheinlich auch zustimmen, ne.
Absolut. Es ist halt ich sage mal meine Bewältigungsstrategie äh um äh mit,
äh sagt zu einer furchtbaren Situation, wie eben tatsächlich einer drohenden nuklearen Eskalation fertig äh zu werden. So, ich kann mich ich habe,
früher auch als Jugendlicher noch äh so Mitte der Achtziger habe ich irgendwie live und in Farbe vom Atomkrieg geträumt. Ja also war irgendwie alles sehr sehr.
Präsent und ähm und ich glaube halt, wie gesagt, wir sind ähm
sondern nuklearen Eskalation so nahe äh wie wir es lange nicht mehr waren, ja und,
ähm aber äh umgekehrt halt nukleare Erpressung ist halt auch keine,
so also sonst weil ja das das geht einfach nicht ähm so
Und das war eben auch äh ja ein bisschen Anlass, warum ich in der letzten Sendung dann ja,
ähm mir so ein bisschen ja ich,
Da wurde dann eher auf Twitter äh gesagt, einige Leute waren halt ein bisschen erschrocken, dass ich das so sozusagen ohne das ins Lustige zu ziehen oder so, sondern einfach quasi relativ
emotionslos äh dann über Atomkrieg äh gesprochen habe und das ist eine große Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt
im Moment äh ja, dass wir uns in der Eskalationsspirale befinden, die eben.
Ähm wenn wir dort nicht ausbrechen können irgendwie äh dann äh weiter eskalieren äh wird äh und.
Umgekehrt hoffe ich aber oder es passieren halt immer Dinge, mit denen niemand rechnet,
glaube ich, beim letzten Mal auch schon. Das ist halt jetzt auch dieser in diesem Krieg sind halt, ich meine, am ersten Tag sind Dinge passiert, mit denen niemand gerechnet hat. Äh dann äh Russland.
Ja die Russen haben sich von Kiew zurückgezogen. Damit hat niemand gerechnet und mit den letzten Offensiven hat auch niemand gerechnet und ich hoffe einfach äh darauf, dass jetzt eben auch neue Dinge passieren
werden, mit denen auch niemand gerechnet hat. Ach so, ja, mit mit der
Jetzt mit der Mobilmachung hat auch eigentlich niemand gerechnet, weil das halt so eine schwachsinnige Idee äh war oder schien.
Und äh ja ähm und.
Interessanterweise äh ja diesen äh äh Shred, den du ausgegraben hast dazu passt, dann äh wiederum ein anderer Shred, auf den ich zufällig gestoßen
bin und ähm wo äh Michael Mac Fall halt äh.
Paar Zitate bringt zum äh Thema,
Und äh ich weiß nicht äh ich habe jetzt nicht vorher übersetzt äh so ähm aber ich versuch's dann mal oder willst du dich dran versuchen an dem an dem Text?
Ähm das äh Freds.
Oder soll ich es machen?
Äh warte mal, ich kann den ja einfach mal übersetzen. Ähm
widerspricht dem Diktat des Realismus und ist daher eine fantasievolle und gefährliche Strategie.
Es ist unwahrscheinlich, dass es einen gefährlichen Feind in ein freundlicheren, netteren Gegner verwandelt, geschweige denn in einen friedliebenden Staat,
Äh in der Tat wird Beschwichtigung wahrscheinlich den Appetit des Angreifers auf Eroberung wecken.
Nicht schrumpfen lassen. Kurz gesagt, Beschwichtigung wird wahrscheinlich einen gefährlicheren.
Rivalisierenden Staat gefährlicher und nicht weniger gefährlich machen.
So genau und weswegen ich das halt äh
so interessant fand war äh nämlich von wem dieses Zitat stammt, nämlich von John Mersheimer aus seinem Buch irgendwie Tragödie äh von äh Großmachtpolitik von zweitausendvierzehn
ähm und Mersheimer äh war derjenige, den wir irgendwie, wo wir glaube ich vor vielen Sendungen mal drüber gesprochen haben,
der ähm
ja einen einen sieben Millionen Mal abgerufenen Vortrag äh auf äh YouTube hat
wo er im Prinzip sagt, äh ja der Westen hat
irgendwie Russland dort äh hinein äh getrieben in in das Ganze mehr oder weniger mit der Ukraine und vorhergesagt, dass irgendwie Russland dann irgendwann.
Ja äh die Ukraine angreifen äh wird so, aber das Interessante ist eben äh dass er aber auch ähm der Meinung ist oder sich da, wenn du so willst, widerspricht.
Äh dass äh ja der Westen im Grunde genommen auch keine andere Wahl hatte oder jetzt wir keine andere Wahl haben, ja. Also wir können, wenn wir mit anderen Worten.
Je netter wir zu Putin sind, umso,
gefährlicher wird er. Ja, das ist das ist die Tragödie oder das ist einfach diese Zwickmühle, in der äh wir uns befinden und das passt jetzt wieder gut zu dem Sweat,
äh den den du vorher da übersetzt hast von äh Noah Smith, wo ähm.
Ja er auch sagt, man kann sich die Welt leider nicht immer so äh
äh oder oder zurecht wünschen äh wie sie ist, sondern äh man muss eben manchmal auch mit beängstigenden Realitäten
leider umgehen und wie gesagt, beängstigende Realität ist, dass wir diese Option nicht haben.
Ja äh zu deeskalieren oder irgendwie Putin irgendwas zu geben oder einen Deal mit Putin zu machen.
Weil wir haben's ja schon versucht. Wir haben ja schon nach 2tausendvierzehn
im Grunde genommen ja, auch wenn es nicht wirklich anerkannt wurde und sanktioniert wurde, aber im Grunde genommen so wurde Putin.
Die Krim überlassen, ja.
Wenn man, wenn man so will, das war ja ein Versuch, eigentlich von einem Stück weit von the peace nimmt, ja und die.
Und Ukraine wurde auch nicht in die NATO aufgenommen, ja und äh wir haben und Deutschland hat's versucht mit
Wandel durch Handel und nicht nur das, sondern es wurden riesige Mengen investiert in in Russland und
ja es war war nicht so, dass wir jetzt irgendwie böse und gemein zu Russland waren oder das Land irgendwie ausgeplündert hätten und mit wir meine ich jetzt.
Den Besten, sondern äh ja das das Land
ist, äh hat sich entwickelt. Es sind unglaublich viel Kapital und Know-how und Technologie und äh es ist halt viel reingeflossen, ja. Äh es hat,
allerdings nicht gereicht und das liegt aber nicht am besten, sondern das liegt halt daran, dass Putin irgendwann sich überlegt hat, äh.
Halt lieber weiter äh mit,
sagen korrupter Sowjet, Tradition äh äh weiter zu verfahren und äh sagen den den starken Führer äh den den den Autokraten zu machen, weil er irgendwann äh.
Der Meinung war einfach so, er ist Russland und äh er ist das Beste für Russland und ohne ihn gibt's kein Russland, so ungefähr.
Und äh ja wir haben und ja der Zug ist,
abgefahren, so fürchte ich äh so und.
Können jetzt nur drauf drauf hoffen, äh dass äh ja ihm.
Die Puste ausgeht äh oder äh ja irgendwie andere Leute dort zur Vernunft kommen, ob er zur Vernunft kommt, wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Gut, damit können wir das glaube ich äh dann äh beenden. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie äh vier Stunden vier Stunden irgendwie eine Woche geschehen äh zusammengefasst. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das enden soll. Ähm.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen, hoffen wir mal, dass nächste Woche nicht so viel passiert, weil von der Art Nachrichten äh wie sie gerade aus der Ukraine kommen, kann ich eigentlich noch mehr gebrauchen. Äh schauen wir mal was.
Was noch passiert. Wird auf jeden Fall noch was passieren.
Also es könnte schlimmer sein, sagen wir's mal so.
Das könnte schlimm.
Es ist schlimm, aber es könnte schlimmer sein. Ja.
Alright, dann äh alle die bis hier durchgehalten haben. Vielen Dank fürs äh Zuhören und äh kommentiert wieder fleißig und äh wir melden uns dann, sobald wir wieder das Gefühl haben, dass.